Slums.
We want man.
No,
no,
no.
I'm good.
Here we go.
Four,
three,
two.
Yes.
Alex Jones were alive.
Wow.
It's going to be back
for the second visit.
It's good to be here,
man.
It's good to see you.
We've got Trump meeting with Kim Jong.
I'm,
we've got the colon hearings in Congress.
A lot of energy going on.
Well,
a lot of things are happening.
Planets are aligned.
Uh,
we should tell everybody
that you and I had with,
first of all,
we had a long conversation on the phone,
which led to just a lot of talk.
You were driving to Vegas a few weeks,
hour and a half,
and then we decided to do another podcast
and we cleared the air on the phone.
We decided to clear the
air more on a podcast.
There's a lot of things going on.
Um,
I told you a long time ago
that it would have you back on.
And uh,
in the interest of
being completely honest,
there was,
I was hesitant to do it.
Not because it didn't want to talk to you,
but because of just the amount of bullshit
that I get from people that get angry
that you and I are friends.
You know that.
Why give that guy a platform?
That's the big one.
That's the big one,
you know?
But you and I have always
had a good time together.
We was up.
We've always had fun together are only
problems have always been when we're not
like if you're talking about
me or if I'm talking about you,
not if we're talking to each other.
It's the distance has been
the props to the telephone,
lack of communication.
The lack of communication
has been the problem.
The thing that people are upset about you.
The thing that we wanted to talk about,
like quick to get it over with or not.
Not Quick,
but just to get it upfront.
That's the best way.
Misrepresentative yes.
Is the sandy hooks.
Yes.
Yeah.
So
your take on it,
just give me your take on it.
Well first off,
because it's always misrepresented.
I believe mass shootings happen and
they're real tragedies and I believe
Parklawn happened.
And you believe Sandy Hook Cap?
Absolutely.
And now just last year the
media came out and said,
Alex Jones says Parkland didn't happen
and he sending people to Parkland
parents' houses and there was no video.
No audio wasn't true.
I'd,
in fact I said I believe
Parkland happened.
So I'm not going to be the
mass shooting denial guy.
I have been branded as the sandy hook.
I mean imagine a final cut
pro video editing timeline
and you go back almost was
seven years ago,
I guess it's more than seven years now
and the Internet didn't believe some of
the things about sandy hook.
I started covering it weeks after my first
articles and things are all this will
be used for gun control and I bet the
guys on Prozac and a mental patient,
which he was of course in
about couple weeks into it,
my listeners and other sorts of sending
me all these anomalies and things and
later turned out some of those anomalies
weren't accurate and that I just moved
on from it.
Okay.
I mean,
I'm not Adam Lanza.
I didn't kill those kids.
But when I'm on the streets now,
people don't know who Adam Lanza is.
The guy that killed those kids,
they think me.
They say actually I believe or not in
prison of what you need to sandy hook all
the CEO is Alex Jones.
Shani hooked dead kids show.
Well I don't think that's,
I think the majority of them are angry
because the narrative has been that
you're sending people to the
sandy hook families hopes homes.
Exactly.
And you'll never have the,
you're responsible for these people
getting harassed because you said on your
radio show that it wasn't real.
Yes,
there is video and audio of me saying
I can see how people don't think it
happened and I can see how people think
it's synthetic cause there's been stage
events before that then gets edited,
put together,
cobbled together.
But I never said go to people's houses.
I never said go investigated you to
say that you think it's not real.
Yes I did.
But now you do think it's real because
I learned some of the anomalies were not
accurate.
That's a problem with
all this conspiracy shit.
Right?
Cause the conspiracy theory stuff,
the people that want to
believe they believe in
conspiracies with everything and
I think there's a certain percent,
and we talked about this
just a few minutes ago.
Yeah.
When I started getting
accused for years ago,
a couple of years until,
and I should know,
I think it happened
then people that I had interviewed and
things short of saying he's involved.
He's one of them.
Because you are now
saying that it happened.
They thought that you
had been compromised.
Yes.
And then I wrote her realizing,
Oh this is how it works.
A certain percentage of
people are schizophrenia.
Exactly.
And then they just think
everything's a conspiracy.
This is a thing about conspiracies.
It's very attractive to
people that are schizophrenia,
schizophrenia.
People think everything's a fucking
conspiracy from top to bottom.
Every single interaction that people
have is some sort of a stage event that's
trying to take them down or
control this or mind control that.
That's a big factor in a lot
of this conspiracy theory shit.
His mental illness.
When I started having people come to the
office Shang that I'm a Beau bridges or
that I'm Jeff Bridges or
that I am of your bill.
Hey Bill Hicks and people
in restaurant screaming,
Fq Bill,
we know it's you.
It's,
it's kind of like Dan rather
than the got threatening me.
I'll watch the Seconal.
Dan,
what's the [inaudible]
what I've experienced now,
the quote fame of being super
famous made the conspiracy guy.
I was legitimately questioning
things because of Gulf of Tonkin.
Northwoods thinks it really happened.
Babies that weren't throwing to
incubators are going to snare rack war,
but I kind of realized a few years ago
that I kind of had my own mild psychosis
in that when you've been lied to by the
media and the culture so much over and
over again,
everything,
then it starts becoming automatically.
You're sure it's fake and then
everything you she fits into that.
This would probably,
you'll get four or five years ago I
began to realize because I was on the
receiving end of people pulling up
in white vans with guns at my office.
Chang,
I know you put a microchip in my head,
I'm going to kill you.
And so it was kind of like,
once I got super famous,
it was like,
whoa.
There's a certain percentage of people
that are way off on the spectrum where
they believe everything's fake.
And then there's people that believe
everything they hear is true.
I mean,
you should be,
you should be questioning,
you should have the right to do it.
But,
but it's somewhere in the middle.
And so this is what I'll
say about sandy hook.
I legitimately questioned
it when people brought
up anomalies.
I then had debates about it on both sides.
The Internet pushed me
to keep covering it.
I probably covered it 20 times in
the first few years that happened.
And then as soon as I questioned it,
uh,
not being staged,
I got a so much that I said,
screw it.
Mass shootings happen.
I believe it happened.
But then media would call me or,
or interview me and say,
okay,
but tell us the anomalies
of why you questioned.
They were getting me to say it again.
Not that I didn't have
the right to question it,
but they,
they thought,
well Alex Jones versus Ted kids,
Alex Jones denying and Alex Jones,
Jurassic families,
this is a perfect way to get this guy
who's so popular getting people to
question and getting people to think.
And so it took me years,
I think I'm smart.
I guess I'm not to figure
out what's going on.
So when Hillary,
few months before the election,
it gives us huge speech and says,
Alex Jones as a dark heart,
he knows sandy hook kids died.
But he says they didn't and
he sends people their houses.
He's the worst guy in the world.
So I came out and I said,
listen,
I never sent anybody to houses,
but I apologize.
It was taken out of context.
People have a right to question,
but I am sorry for the families and
I'm sorry for your hurt and I get it.
And I've experienced crazy people now.
Big Time.
Just like you have,
please stop saying that.
I'm saying it didn't happen.
Please stop saying I'm
sending people who was houses.
Cause here's what happens when they
put it on every major TV channel,
local TV channels,
radio,
I mean thousands of articles
that get syndicated.
And I said 100,000 articles,
that's a low number.
The amount of sandy hook coverage
against me has been so insane.
It's so huge because it's supposed to
be the first domino that once I'm taking
down that all the dominoes fall.
Well it's also clickbait.
There's also a thing if he say Alex Jones,
Sandy Hook and you put in a title,
a certain amount of people,
we just kind of click on it.
Alex Jones is still pushing a sandy hook
conspiracy theories one that I saw just
two days ago.
Exactly.
So,
so this is the point I've
gotten to is here's the key.
They didn't,
they say more people are showing up in,
in Connecticut and more people
are coming to their houses,
which they are because the media is
all over the news saying there's a big
conspiracy here.
Alex Jones says it doesn't happen.
And so people then hear it and they think,
oh,
you know,
it's like looking for the
moth man or something.
They're all running up there in the media
saying it in my name and I'm saying,
no,
I believe it happened years ago.
And so then I'm getting the blame and
the attacks and the demonization of the
threats for what the corporate media
is saying over and over again that I'm
saying that it didn't happen.
And the families are getting the
threats and the families are getting the
attacks and the families are
getting called crisis actors.
Yes.
And then he can see something different.
Oh my God.
In hindsight,
absolutely.
But again,
I legitimately didn't think my show was
as powerful as it was show that I wasn't
retrospectively looking at everything
I was doing as much as I should.
Nobody's perfect.
I mean,
as you get older,
you grow and you learn things.
But I just began to realize about
three years ago that they're making my
identity not being a national,
it's not being a populace,
not being a free market guy.
They're making my whole
identity sandy hook.
And I didn't know they
were going to sue me then.
Well,
it's just because that's what gets clicks.
Yes,
but then,
but then before I ever got sued,
I said,
I believe Sandy Hook happened.
That should not my identity
I barely ever covered.
It's stop.
Right,
but you understand that
it's not what they're doing.
They're not trying to make his
weakness and made it even worse,
but they're not trying
to make your identity.
They're not trying to define you
or do some sort of a documenter,
a biography on your life.
They're just finding something that
people want to pay attention to.
This is one of the problems with,
with news coverage today is that they
find things that people want to pay
attention to and they focus on
them out of proportionate portion.
They say that I'm making money off sandy
hook when when the newspapers and the
publishing houses are using me as
a way to put out that had Shinier,
very hurtful thing to be hurtful.
I didn't mean to be in senior year.
I was legitimately questioning
because the Internet was,
and asking a bunch of other
stage stuff and then I say,
hey,
take it back.
Don't do it.
And they go,
no,
we're going to commit this hurtful
thing that's chill free speech,
but it's hurtful in your fricking name.
And then,
and then that's why I'm not
saying I'm the victim here.
I'm saying stop it because everything
they do about the platform,
I mean,
the biggest frustration
is I still have my huge
audience@radiostationsandinfowars.com
and [inaudible] dot com but reaching new
people's very hard.
And then now that I've been silenced,
the mainstream media could
say whatever they want,
Joe,
about you,
about me,
and I can't respond.
I mean,
you can go to Youtube
and type in Alex Jones.
Well,
this is where you'll and the negative
stuff and there's one that says white
supremacy and Alex Jones
and you click on it.
It's a famous British
actor and author saying,
Alex Jones says,
kill the a of families of,
of Parkland parents.
And I'm actually having lawyers
getting ready to fall suit over this.
I warn the guy shouldn't letters,
he didn't take it.
Now I have to,
you could pull up this
famous British actor,
I forget,
I forget his name.
He can pull up just just typing
in Alex Jones at Youtube.
All the main stuff's put up on top.
It's like the seventh eighth link and
it says Alex Jones and white supremacy
what to do about it.
And he says,
Alex Jones and the lights
of premise are saying,
go to the people's houses at Parkland
and kill the parents and we have to take
him off the air because he says,
kill the parents.
There's no free speech
for killing parents.
And I'm like,
dude,
do not say that I'm going to get killed.
I mean,
I am never said nobody died at Parkland.
And I sure as hell didn't
say kill their parents.
Let's,
let's go now.
Can you talk about fake news?
They have green lighted making,
anything you can imagine up about me.
And,
and it's like insane.
And that's all I'm saying is,
is that at a certain
point it's like Jesus,
again,
let's,
let's take this step by step.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
This,
and this is where we want to give you
an opportunity to communicate and clear
the air and talk and some of the shit
that you and I talked about earlier.
Um,
there's a bunch of things going on.
One,
there's,
it's a story that attracts
people's attention,
right?
A story of a guy who sang that people
didn't get killed when they did get
killed.
And it's horrific for people to,
to look at.
It's terrific to people to think about
that their own children who not only get
murdered,
but then someone would accuse
them of being a crisis actor.
So then they start pushing that story and
that story becomes something that they
make money off of,
which is really in some
ways kind of ironic.
They keep this story in the news and
they keep getting clicks off of you and
misrepresenting some of the
things that you've said.
Yes.
And,
and,
and some of the things that you said
you wish you hadn't said to like that's
also real but,
but,
but I mean let's be clear,
I'm not even defending my shelf.
People learn stuff as you get older.
Hindsight,
you're like,
why did I do that?
Like I used to whatever was the
big hot thing on the Internet.
I would just debate it cause
it was interesting with this,
what I wanted to get to you,
you were doing this show and in this
show you're on the air hours and hours a
day and you're ranting about
all these various things.
Is,
is,
is it fair to say that you weren't really
100% aware of what kind of influence
you were having?
Absolutely.
If you did know,
you would phrase things differently
and done things differently,
you know,
it's even beyond that.
I was just younger and,
and I was covering what
other people were saying.
I was not the first the
10th or a hundredth,
the 10000th you're reading about it on
the Internet was a firestorm all over the
news that people are denying it.
And I've got producers going,
hey,
look at this video.
But isn't that the problem with
every single national tragedy?
Anytime something happens,
there's a certain amount of people that
think that there's a conspiracy even
when it's just a plane crash,
even when it's just what
it fill in the blanks.
Any sort of national,
exactly.
All I'm shaking ish.
Shandy hooked up the hill on dying on I,
I support people's right to question
and I understand because there's been so
much lying and corporate
media and by governments and,
and,
and staged events that are admitted in
declassified that once people see that
one thing was staged than
everything else must be stage.
And then I have been on the receiving
end of literally thousands of made up
conspiracies,
which you'll laugh at until people
in a truck with guns show up.
Yeah.
And so I understand part of
this is the complex world.
We live in all the information
we have more than ever.
And a lot of it is all the drugs people
that are on and it's just a lot of it is
schizophrenia.
This is a big problem.
A big,
I mean we were talking about this
certain percentage of beings.
Half of Brazil has the,
he has the brain warm that
makes you basically psychotic.
Well,
it doesn't make you psychotic
and your risk taking crazy.
It affects your judgment.
This is toxic programs.
You'd want to have more cats smell,
piss.
Yes.
Well it definitely does that to,
to rats.
It actually reprograms rat's brains
makes them sexually attracted.
There's much of parasites.
Yes,
there's a bunch of them and there's
some that probably haven't even been
identified.
That's where the whole crazy
cat lady thing comes from.
Yes,
that's exactly what it is.
It's one of the reasons why they tell
women when they're pregnant to stay the
fuck away from cat litter.
Don't touch cat litter.
Don't go on as your major cats.
Yes,
you,
I mean it's,
it can be actually fatal for babies,
but what I'm trying to get the ledgers
where they should kill the damn cash.
Well,
I'm sure there's a lot of factors there,
right?
She,
old wives tales were like,
you get demon possessed
by that cat and it really,
it's a damn brain warm.
But that's probably also
why they told you not to.
That's a real bright,
warm programming you,
like you were saying earlier,
it's,
I looked at,
it's true,
I didn't know that at the top soccer's
teams have the highest level of brain
worm infestation.
Well it's,
there's a disproportionate amount of
people that live in countries where the
high toxoplasmosis infection would
say it's successful soccer teams.
There was some study that
was done on that where,
uh,
we had a doctor [inaudible] women that
have become more sexually promiscuous.
Yes.
It's recklessness.
And they think the men are more
reckless and that's why there's a
disproportionate amount of motorcycle
victims that tests positive for
toxoplasmosis.
This is where the Robert Sapolsky at
Stanford University was telling us,
is there a way to remove,
I don't think [inaudible]
I don't think there is.
Well,
you know,
there's like snails,
they get a brain warm that programs are
the top of a tree shall birds eat it.
Yeah.
And then,
and then it's crapped out and the snails
eat that and then go and it's just food
cycle.
Yes.
Don't tell me in classic evolution.
And I'm also believe
the interpretation by,
by right wingers the of the Bible.
That's not what it says.
But obviously evolution and
there's a big quick jumps,
but we know what's going on.
But the idea that just,
there's a worms and there's all these
different [inaudible] the one that gets
into a grasshopper,
the aquatic worm gets inside
of a grasshopper's body
and gets the grasshopper to
commit suicide,
gets a grasshopper to jump into water
and drown and then it comes out of its
body.
And that's where it lives.
It lives in the water.
So it literally gets its
host to commit suicide.
And that chain of events,
how does that evolve where suddenly
a worm gets into grasshopper and does
something,
a supercomputer couldn't do it,
it programs to drown itself?
Well,
this is a matter of complex biology.
I mean,
so I think it's insanely complex and it's
something that scientists are studying
on a daily basis coming up.
Cause I'm gonna cause I don't wanna just
talk about me all day and I appreciate
you having me on here to do it.
And I,
and I know I don't have a talking point.
I don't have a PR firm.
You know,
we've talked before,
went on air about what am I going to,
I mean,
Alex,
what do you want to say today
so you can help me get it out.
I don't know.
I'm alive.
I want to say a bunch of things.
I'm only learning how this works,
being in the process of it,
and it's given me a much bigger view than
a new 23 years ago when I first got on
air because I've experienced
what other people have sheds,
bad things I did experience.
I did it from a good heart,
I believe.
Question was okay,
I was covering other people questioning,
but then there's a weird sick irony in
the media that says that I'm the one that
pregenerated sandy hook didn't happen
when I wasn't too then in my name.
Popularize it to a level of like they've
put out more stability as a [inaudible]
me.
This is
key.
Then before you invade a major country,
I mean this has been going on for years.
Every day,
the news,
the print,
no one died at sandy hook.
Alex Jones says,
Alex Jones has go to their
houses and hurt them.
What the hell is it for?
It goes on and on and on and on.
You're thinking this
because it's about you,
so because it's about you,
it becomes a primary point of focus
because it's affecting your life and it's
something that you're concentrating on,
but the volume is massive.
It is.
Volume is massive because it's
something that generates interest.
This is part of the problem
with the way we do news today.
Anything that generates interest,
I mean if the it,
honestly,
if the media really cared,
they probably would have
never talked about it.
They probably would have never brought
it up so that we had real terror attacks
in the sixties and seventies
that weren't staged a,
if you go back and look at them like the
weathermen and all that stuff and the
government and the media didn't cover it,
well this is a long time ago,
but they didn't cover because it gives,
if you cover terrorists,
they do it more.
Right.
That's true.
I was agreeing with you.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's true.
That's like another countries.
They don't print the name of mass shooters
in the newspaper because they don't
want people to get attention for that.
I mean,
some different cultures,
which is a philosophy.
I genuinely,
I've known you 20 years or so.
It's like 1998 99 I genuinely really,
I'm trying to find the truth.
And I realized that once I saw a bunch
of declassified staged events like
Northwoods or like Gladio or locked
off the tank and all the Tonkin or,
or,
or Jesse Smollett,
I mean,
I couldn't help it.
I knew he'd probably show me
the day after it happened.
I said,
the guy's got a noose around his
neck at 2:00 AM and in Chicago,
fuck has a noose in Chicago
who's walking around with a news,
who even knows how to write,
who,
who knows how to make a noose like who?
And the cops show up 40 something minutes
later and he's like the door with a
noose around a snack
in the subway sandwich.
Fake.
Yeah.
But I said,
sue,
me,
destroy me by it's fate.
I can't help it.
But see,
the problem is that's the,
that's where the psychosis comes in.
Because if you,
if you're a little kid is,
I've been reading more about psychology.
I'm trying to understand this stuff.
If you're a little kid and somebody was
red hair beat you and tortured you say,
man with red hair,
I'm just a hypothetical.
What?
We are going to not
like guys with red hair.
So,
so,
so it's kind of like,
or if you've been lied to as a kid,
let it,
that's what creates mental illness layer,
right?
So we've been lucky with the media and
the corporate system and seeing all these
fake hoaxes and you know,
the fake stuff about Cavenaugh and the
face of about the coverage of kids and
the face of about smaller,
she,
that's now the public.
Actually,
here's what's happening.
I'm getting huge backlash and small it,
it's not,
wait a minute.
Who's given you backlash
from the public are like,
Hey,
smallest fake.
The coverage of kids are fake.
A Balaji forward.
Most of these women said it was all fake.
So why are you saying Sandy Hook's real?
Everything's fake and it's like,
no,
dude,
everything's not fake.
That's what I'm saying is the
differential is gone and so yeah,
there's a bunch of fake stuff and
we have a right to question it,
but now,
now,
then now the general public,
my fans believe everything say,
but let me stop you there.
I'm ranting.
I just,
it's okay.
I want you to read this,
but this is,
this is the nature of the beast.
This is what you're selling
to a lot of these people,
this is why they're tuning into you.
They want to hear you uncover conspiracies
and some of them aren't as bright as
others and some of them can't see logic.
They don't see it.
They don't understand them.
Legitimately questioning.
I don't just think everything's fake.
I know you don't listen.
I think if you never
talked about Sandy Hook,
you'd have no problems.
I really do believe that.
I believe there'd be problems.
I think people would look down on you
and call you a right wing lunatic and all
sorts of other things,
which they don't even know.
When I knew you when I first knew you,
you were getting arrested
for going after George Bush.
I remember when George,
you are not a right one to
ask him a question at me.
Well you,
you were,
you were asking him a pertinent question
about the CFR in his dad's drug.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
And this was the guy that was running
for president as a Republican and you,
you were getting arrested
for and Contra the CFR.
But my point is you weren't,
you weren't a tie to a party.
You were trying to find the truth.
And I don't know.
You're afraid when I aligned with Trump,
that's when all hell broke loose.
Yeah,
yeah.
That was part of it.
I think that was definitely Hillary image.
She looked at my whole bio and shed
Shanti Hook hit him on that right now.
Uh,
do you still communicate with Trump?
Not In a while.
And I,
I,
it becomes a big issue.
I mean,
I obviously communicate with surrogates
and people who talked to Trump,
I mean,
don Jr was on Tucker Carlson last night.
They were talking about me and saying
what happened was wrong and the fact that
they've used me as the way to start the
cashless society and then and then and
then I'm gonna imagine they're never
supposed to block somebody from banking of
they have a good record.
It's not fraud.
Here's a whole other story.
I had an a plus plus rating with my
shopping cart and bank accounts that I had
for 22 years and banks
looked at it and said,
we've quite frankly never seen anybody
with a credit rating this high cause you
never even do charge backs
with our shopping cart.
If people do that,
what does that mean?
Chargebacks points?
We have the best credit tourist,
a group out of Boston,
which I'm not going to mention
here for your show and things,
but we're preparing litigation against
who does the writings to secret rating
system for like Taliban and al Qaeda.
The Mafia that's that's given to bank
executives two days before paypal bandits.
They put a hate designation from
the southern poverty law center.
Shang I'm basically a terrorist.
So when they call you a hate personnel,
it means a terrorist in Interpol.
So all over the Western world I am
listed and we would sent documents out of
England and out of the u s that we were
sent this by High Level Bank of people
that are freaked out.
We make contacts,
lawyers texted,
they can't believe it,
they have designated me as
an international terrorists
and that's how they took
five of my six bank accounts and got me
down to one bank account with perfect
credit Shang.
You cannot take money
on your shopping cart
and for store.com for your products,
t shirts,
books,
whatever.
You,
you aren't allowed to be in commerce
because you are a terrorist.
And what do they use
to define terrorist h?
It's classified symbols and we've
got some of the documents is hate,
h is hate.
And then just decide arbitrarily
that you're a hateful person,
that you promote hate.
No judge,
no jury.
It's the global Chinese social score.
That's what they're all testing for here.
But this is what we were talking about.
That's very important.
This is actually dangerous.
This is actually dangerous to give people
the ability to define people without
any strict rigid qualifications,
without anything that you
can point to on paper.
If I was a convicted murderer
and got out of prison,
I started an online
store and sell t shirts.
If I was Charlie Manson,
he had like four TV specials on,
on,
you know,
uh,
CBS 60 minutes when I was a kid,
I'd watch Charlie Manson.
I don't think he was allowed
to get paid for those though.
I think that was part of the
thing because he's involved in,
we'll sure they have laws on it,
but the point is he would
do Geraldo Rivera shows.
The point is Hitler basically it was the
number one thing on the history channel
when they first launched it.
So you can hear what Hitler has to say
even though we know he's a bad guy.
Well,
why can't you wrote Alex challenge has
to say because they have found what I
talk about as effective.
It gets people thinking and they
want it shut down because we've,
we've relaunched populism,
enforces,
done this,
my audience has 1776 worldwide populism,
anti globalism,
anti-communism anti China
and the big tech companies,
Google and apple and all of them have
publicly moved to China and they publicly
agreed to sensor and
control the population.
This isn't the nose.
And that's why Tim Cook got so mad at me
and I made a huge issue to Trump and I
shouldn't reports to the president.
I know he got that.
That's what happened on that Sunday
night when they said that's it.
We're done with Jones.
We have to take him down because I got
investigations going at the national
security level,
sending big reports,
the president through law firms of Reuters
and AP and then the articles which he
wasn't getting where China has
given of the code keys by Apple.
This is last year,
uh,
and is moving their database there and
all the code keys have been given to the
Chinese government.
And Apple says that's just part of being
there and Google's building dragon fly
project helps them to their entire
population with a social credit score.
They're already testing in Venezuela
with China and they're going to bring it
here and everything you do and live.
Tom will be controlled and you know
all the big airlines now hat or putting
cameras in that watch
you while you're on here.
Let me stop you because you
rent and again I'm frantic.
It's okay.
You think they're using sandy hook as
an excuse to get you off the air and to
censor you and to take away
your ability to make income.
Not because of that,
but using that as an excuse because
of the other things that you do.
Oh,
they like targeting things like Google
and talking about things that you're
talking about.
We were there in China
and China's allowed,
they're allowing China
to censor the population.
I'm just telling,
I'm not against Google or apple.
They're the,
they did a lot of cool things.
I'm saying stop it.
Congress told you 10 years ago you
were built here in the u s with Darpa.
Money,
don't go help
China do this stuff.
Don't be evil.
Well I only tell you something cause
I knew someone who worked at Google.
I know someone who used to work at Google,
I should say.
Their thought process
was that Google is going,
if they don't bring Google
to China in a sense it form,
they're going to copy Google.
This was there.
The real worry because
China copies everything.
I mean they're intellectual copyright law.
Better now.
True.
But this is what they're saying,
what they're about that job.
But let me,
let me explain something from the
point of view of Google as a business.
And I don't necessarily,
I'm not saying I agree with this
cause I don't itch more apple juice.
Get some apple juice
and your system fella.
Um,
they were thinking,
and this is what I was talking to a
woman who was a very high level executive
and she was saying that they're going
to steal it if we don't work with them.
They're just going to steal Google and,
and take the code and make
their own version of it.
So them as a business,
they're like,
this is inevitable.
They're going to do it anyway.
We're just going to give into
their censorship demands.
I don't agree with it.
I don't think it's a good idea,
but I don't know what I
would do if I was Google.
I'll tell them,
you'll tell what,
I'll talk a little tissue.
What should they do for China?
You're dead on what that person told you
when I had the globalist 15 years ago,
20 years ago,
tried to buy me off to a million a year,
you know,
whatever.
Um,
by the way,
cheers.
Cheers,
brother.
Anyway,
when they did all that
well,
they did all that.
What were they trying to do?
Who's trying to lie?
Well,
I can't get into their private meetings
for the judge to journalistic stuff off
record,
but everybody gets
this is offers like Alex,
you're going to influence things by being
on the inside if you don't join this
and helps save the planet
and do all these big things.
My Dad got the same speech when
he was in high school already.
Ut had planned to.
I tell you about that.
We'll get to that later,
but if you don't join us,
then the bad guys that are in
the system are going to win.
That's how they call option cause that's
how those people you're talking to are
probably pretty good person.
That person at Google,
they've had hundreds of
their top engineers quit
over this because here's the
thing.
China in 1949 wash
nationalists and and capitalists
and our own CIA's been declassified,
left us the Ford Foundation that's was
above the CIA helped put the Chai comms
and power.
It took them decades to get
running water and toilets.
They have no environmental standards,
no rules.
They've had all of our investment.
They've been built up because
the Chinese economy's,
we'll do whatever the globalist wine,
when you go and you are in China,
they make you become state
run to get 0% tax corporate.
Okay.
That's what Trump's trying to
lower ours just to be competitive.
China has 0% corporate tax.
Look it up now if you become
state sponsored state run show,
they're claiming,
oh so the China doesn't
rape us of our technology.
We're going to go over there and spread
our legs to them even more so it's not a
rape.
We're willing and we're going
to take you along with us.
So the idea that well if
we don't give it to them,
they're just gonna it off.
So let us go,
really give them all the big secrets
and have Google last year until the
Pentagon,
we're not going to help you with Ai,
autonomous drones,
but Google gave them all the latest AI
and I'll get it more
sophisticated stuff in a moment.
Gave them all the sophisticated AI and
now China announces they've got all these
AI drones that are autonomous and all
these AI weapons systems should erector
aircraft show show.
What I'm telling you
is China has no rules.
20 years ago they had cows
that produce human milk.
20 years ago they had
spiders that printers,
body armor Shapot her guts.
Okay?
They have human animal hybrids.
30 years ago they've got
giant human tissue farms.
You know,
you hear,
oh your,
your achilles just torn.
We've got a grown in a lab attended.
It's not a fricking 10 and grow in a lab.
It's a fricking deal.
A humanoid.
These aren't humans.
The way they get around it is
they met him and we were winning.
We we're saying so many things.
This is,
listen,
I love you to death,
but you say you stole a million dollars.
Humanoids are real.
I believe they are.
But you say so many different
things without stopping.
It's hard cause I'm an agency so
they'll listen to investigate.
I'm decompartmentalize okay.
But she'll be studied for years,
so no,
I believe Joe,
Joe,
Joe.
Yes.
It was an MIT quarterly 25 years ago
that they had human animal embryos.
What?
They killed him at the embryonic level.
You can leave it up.
I believe they've got humanoids.
I believe this.
I've been there.
They've already used CRISPR to enhance
children with a higher intelligence.
And Shadow was actually,
it was a side effect.
They believe of intelligence.
HIV was something about HIV immune to HIV.
Oh yes.
Everything that roll out
is already been tested.
Oh,
I believe you.
But it has an aim.
So let me tell you what's really going on.
The globals want to play God.
Okay.
They have what they call
a breakaway civilization.
What said was,
how about the breakaway civilization
will talk about Sandy Hook,
which I get and I appreciate it.
Let me cover,
and I'm sorry it ever happened.
I believe that happened.
I'm sorry for people's pain.
And then I ask the
families and I asked the,
the,
the lawyers,
when I asked them all,
stop in my name saying
I'm the wolf at the door.
Shango,
go after these families and stopped
running around to the news everywhere
saying,
Alex Jones says,
Sandy Hook didn't happen
because the media,
how about social media is
the most unpopular thing in
the world with 7% approval
rating and Gallup.
So when they say that,
I say it's fake.
That sends people to Connecticut
because people think the media lies,
right?
So if they're saying,
Alex Jones said didn't happen,
it must have not happened.
And now they're trying to
create a violent event.
Not the families.
But I think some of the people involved
know that if they make a big enough hype
about it,
they're going to have a big
event up there in Connecticut.
You understand?
And they're going to blame it on me.
So I'm saying no,
no,
no.
I believe it happened.
Stop saying,
I said it didn't happen and
stop shaking that I'm sharing.
No kids died because I want to talk
about human animal hybrids and humanoid
because Joe,
why is it gotta be a humanoid?
Why?
Because if you make it a few percentage,
another uh,
animal or another creature,
it's a gray area.
There's no human rights.
You have an animal rights movement.
You have a human rights movement.
There's no alien movement.
Aliens are real.
They're creating human animal
hybrids that are a new creature.
Never here on earth.
It's alien.
So the aliens are already here.
Ai Is Alien.
The kind of mirrors our alien
aliens are already here.
So you're saying they're making these
human animal hybrid so they would harvest
tissue from them.
That's just level one.
What's level two?
What's level eight?
Because a lot,
I'll tell you a lot.
For the best of my knowledge,
a lot of people think,
oh,
it's,
it's human harvesting of fall on Gong
or these Buddhists really healthy.
That's big.
That's going on because they still
have a better non rejection rate.
But with the risk,
I remember 22 years ago reading a BB
she article that was kind of testing the
waters occasionally tested and they go,
oh yeah.
Uh,
about 15 years ago,
the first animal human kind of errors
were made and tested if there were not
brought to term,
but some scientists want to implant
them in utero and cows because I was,
that's a bigger uterus.
You can grow up a bigger
humanoid and get more tissue.
And so then I went mapping
or go research that.
So I went to ut library.
At that time you could get some of the
Internet in like 1996 and I wouldn't
actually pulled up all these MIT reports.
I took him to my dad and other
people whose doctor and they go,
yeah,
that's really crazy.
And it was all about how we've got to
prepare the public for this because we're
going to be able to download their
memories and then put it in a new body.
This was before blade runner.
So she,
it's not like this is the world's
on imitating blade runner.
Blade runner is a preparation for what's
coming and they're telling you more
human than human.
This is going to be more advanced.
This is going to be better.
But like everything,
like a cell phone or like a vaccine,
it's got a Trojan horse,
it's got a back door.
It's already been tested.
It's already been perfected.
It's being rolled out.
You're not giving the real technology,
you're not giving the real life extension.
You're given the crap Jo and the earth
is seen as like an egg yolk to give the
propulsion power for this new
thing that's going to be born.
And whether you believe that or not,
just like when the new thing,
meaning artificial intelligence.
Beyond that,
it's a origin of artificial intelligence
and a whole synthesis of new life
forms.
And so that's the big giant race.
When Elon Musk came in and told you,
cause he goes,
he's building and our functions
and he has a conscience.
So he's freaked out and they go,
these billionaire functions,
I don't just know this,
I've talked to people and I was in
wired magazine 20 something years ago.
While the future doesn't need as bill joy,
a billionaire co owner,
Sun microsystems,
he goes to a billionaire meeting with
200 guys and the consensus was we're not
gonna have people play video
games and party all day.
We're going to set up a world government.
We're going to slowly titrate
the dose and poison the public,
dumb them down,
put electromagnetic radiation
out with five g the scrambles,
their DNA lowers or Iq.
We're going to cause mass mental illness
and a controlled societal collapse that
will then be organized and controlled in
the mop up crew by robots controlled by
the globalist programmers
who believe with the Offworld
entities.
They're in communication with that.
They're going to be given the operation
to upload and be in that larger kind of
Borg Cube System.
If they sell the country up.
You got to hit the brakes because
I need to do we take this back to,
I'm so baffled.
What's mad at one of these things?
Mit,
Mit Technology Review estimates that
about 20 pregnancies of pig human or sheep
human [inaudible] have been established
during the last 12 months in the u s
total white in 2016 I
hundred percent believe it.
Look,
I think that as this was going on in 1985,
I'm sure they tried to recruit
my dad to a Darpa program.
I believe that in college and
then when he was a dentist,
I believe that I believe that they will
take all sorts of liberties in gray
matters when it comes
to scientific research.
I definitely believe that you
ever see trinity and beyond.
But let's,
let's start slow because you didn't go
over so many different things in bombs
trying to ignite the atmosphere.
And then I came sexting.
Oh No.
I know that the US air force tried
to destroy the atmosphere in 1968.
Yes.
Uh,
operation starfish prime,
they actually text you get a nuclear bomb.
They adopted to detonate a
nuclear bomb in the upper.
I'm trying to blow up the
rant on radiation and yes,
they've,
they've done a lot of goofy shit.
See.
That's the thing.
That's why I got mad at you and I,
and I love you.
You're a smart guy and everything is no,
listen,
you got mad at me.
All this stuff.
I know you're even better at saying it
and then you sit there because you can't
handle it and you shit.
It's not going to go down to it.
It's not that I can't handle it.
It's there's two factors.
One,
I don't have any time.
I don't have enough time to
go into it as much as you do.
You asked why I flipped
out and got mad at you.
That's it right there.
You,
every time I bring up a fucking subject,
you know all about it.
I don't know all about this
fucking know all about six shit.
Don't know all that little shit.
You're a smart guy,
Joe.
Joe,
this is a Po Bullshit.
You know exactly what you're,
I don't think you're a bad guy.
You're trying to survive for
you and your family and do good,
okay,
but none of your family,
none of us are going to make it.
There's a post human error coming.
The breakaway civilization,
the deal's been made.
It's not,
it's not the third dementia.
They've made fricking deals
with interdimensional aliens.
Okay,
and notice the media never disaster
for that cause that's the truth.
Maybe this is true.
I do not know this and we'll get into it.
Okay?
I do not know this.
And even these human pig hybrids,
Jamie just pulled this up.
I believe it's true.
I mean,
I worried about my marriage.
I'm sorry.
The Sandy Hook kids died.
My identity is not that I get it.
They admit five g and all the studies
La Times causes mashed up mutation and
cancer.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
And it really rattles your DNA apart.
All of our kids are under attack.
You mean five manager for
allowing five g to come in?
This is the new Internet.
You know why they won't let China
put in Wapo you know whopper major.
That's the big Chinese are on fire today.
No.
Gee,
you're on fire.
No joke.
Joe.
The five g you're on fire.
Okay.
Maybe she article and 96 about human
animal hybrids with pigs and cows.
Yes.
If got to make you park cows
and the cow keeps you,
does it reject it or Partpic.
Okay,
okay.
But let me expand and you know about pigs
and rats were most closely related to
us,
not even chimpanzees.
That's why a lot of the
organs don't get rejected.
You know about that?
Yes.
Okay.
Pigs are very close to humans.
Even use pig organs and peaceful.
He's usually know everything show.
No,
it's true.
I mean,
you know,
in a general knowledge,
you know everything I know.
No,
no,
no.
I don't.
Listen,
let me tell you,
this is literally,
I,
we,
we know what they're doing.
She'll just like,
they say,
just like they say,
Oh yeah,
we had human animal hybrid.
This is like fricking 39 years ago now,
23 years ago.
I'm reading at the BBC about
it and go confirm attack.
Okay.
And they're just floating.
There was an article in 1999
in the Baltimore Sun and
I interviewed Nick Becca.
She read a Dick Mega Chen and Dr
Beckett should know Gotti blow you away.
Who is it?
His Dad was a US congressman.
I got killed.
His brother,
US senator,
he,
he like,
he should have him on the ship.
They're the guys that got all the money
given to native Americans and he spells
his last name,
begged shits.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
he's a good friend of mine.
Can I get him on apps?
A fricking lil fly right now.
Anyways,
the point is,
so what does he do?
He was telling me all these years ago,
he goes,
Alex,
it isn't chemicals in the food and water.
That's childless baggage checked.
It's Jimmy.
It's electro chemical.
Okay,
it's electro chemical.
But I'm reading in the Baltimore Sun
after I just had him on and thought it was
crazy.
He's giving all these patents for mind
control using wavelengths and microwaves.
And I'm sitting there looking at
it and I'm reading it and I'm,
and I'm seeing it and the Baltimore Sun
says the CIA is testing on cell towers,
uh,
wave links to calm the
public during crises.
I just had baggage,
Sean with patents talking about that.
Well,
Beckett's explains his,
it's not that the microwave.
I have somehow interfaced with the brain.
We already interfaced with the space
winds and all these other magnetic fields
and everything else show.
They're all just testing this stuff.
And so everything they deployed,
they've got all these other technologies.
My Dad was at ut and 65
when he was in high school,
they already had CD roms,
computers,
everything.
But they had a nuclear reactor
underneath the building.
And what spoke to tell them?
Oh absolutely.
And that's what I'm telling you.
It's a breakaway civilization,
dude.
We don't know what they've got.
We don't know.
We don't know who they are.
We don't know the whole thing.
That's what I'm telling you is
this is hiding in plain view.
And that's why it's so crazy.
Imagine if you knew all this.
You're trying to tell people and they go,
Oh God,
he's doing that.
Find one thing.
He did it sounds mean and
make that his whole world.
So that's what I'm telling you is it's
been in the newspaper that the cell
towers are being used for mind control.
That sounds like a schizophrenia.
So see,
here's a,
here's where it gets tougher.
I want to see that.
How do they use the salad tongs?
Pull.
I'd probably look,
here's the thing.
Skits.
Listen,
here's the deal right here.
You've got a total schizophrenia that
thinks the sun is following him around
town and thinks their dog is watching
them and works for the aliens.
That's not happening.
You've got someone over here,
someone over here that believes
everything they see on Fox News.
Yes.
Okay.
Now questionings.
Good science is good.
Trying to figure out what's
real and all of us get freaked
out.
The nature of the world.
No one knows what the university has.
We don't have all the answers.
So it kind of,
people can't handle that bigness.
They can't handle that question.
I'll especially low Iq.
So they have to differentiate and create
a model that allows them to put it in
boxes so they can make it make
sense because they can't handle it.
It's like,
uh,
like I say,
even top astronauts space walk for
the first time and they're out in the
universe and the whole planet's under him.
And what are they going to do?
They,
it's,
it's mind blowing.
Well.
Imagine once you realize we don't know
everything we don't understand and it's
endless and there's all this crazy crap,
people go nuts.
And as humans learn more and more,
as we become more advanced
and go to this metamorphosis,
it's going to create a giant societal
crisis where most of the people already
going to get killed.
The globalist understand that
in the birth of this planet,
this new species,
and so they decided to take control,
make it scientific,
stun everyone and Dunham Noun so they
can scientifically try to orderly carry
this operation now,
but then I go,
wait a minute,
you're detonate and over
a hundred a in bonds,
the upper atmosphere to see if you could
ignite the atmosphere destroying the
earth.
Yeah,
but that was in the sixties I know,
but what I'm telling you is the
same professors train people,
but those people are dead.
The people that detonated those hydrogen
bombs in the 60s they are dead now does
not.
We're not dealing with
the same human beings.
I'm with you.
I think people in a lot of ways,
they're more immoral now
I think I agree with you.
In some ways that everything
evolves and things get better.
This is one of my arguments
about operation Northwoods
that if they were able to
push operation Northwoods
and get it signed by the
Joint Chiefs of staff in 1962
was it 62 if they were able to do that
and no one went to jail and no one got
arrested for proposing that they were
going to arm Cuban friendlies and have
them bomb Guantanamo Bay and blow up a
Cuban jet liner and and shoot people in
movie theaters.
Yes,
and schools,
yes.
That things evolve.
Things evolve and if unchecked,
and obviously that was unchecked,
no one went to jail for that.
No one got hit you,
you know,
even PBS covered it.
Like I never even knew this.
Let's read this right here.
The significance of the research he
explained is that although the cell phone
power is low,
electromagnetic radiation can nevertheless
have an effect on mental behavior
when transmitting at the proper frequency.
What does this article Jamie Scientific
American in scientific American at the
title mind control by cell phone.
So it really does have an effect.
They did a whole study.
Let's go further.
It does.
So there is,
so what do you think that they're
making this not classified.
Last year,
a 37 page,
she IAA manual from the 1970s where they
were putting up shell towers that look
like trees already testing it.
Neighborhoods.
Okay the judge,
can I shut my phone?
Tracks you and watches you and
controls you and surveil shoe.
You think
that it's one way.
But beyond that it's a microwave relay
relay system that can manipulate and then
the towers are even more powerful.
So this is a device
given to us by the gods.
Okay.
Given to us by the technology that
that the breakaway government,
NASA has developed that you don't
just think they made up themselves.
Right?
What do you mean?
Who Do you think made it up?
Well,
when you're ready to get to it,
I don't want listeners
to understand something.
I'm noticing.
Notice the media is not
going to cover this.
The media is not what they'll
cover that was on the show.
They're not going to cover this.
The meat.
Okay.
Cause this is not my opinion.
This is the real research
that I have heard that,
that I have talked to army generals,
commanding generals,
major generals,
general generals,
CIA,
everybody,
and they're all 100%.
Uh,
and I thought it was a sigh out
before and that I've researched it.
I've talked to hundreds of people now,
not on air,
but I'm gonna make a film on this
who've taken Iowasca and DMT.
I've not taken it.
And B for obvious reasons.
And uh,
and it's unbelievable because I mean
they 100% in San Francisco is the main
project site literally have an alien
base and they are literally communicating
and they'd got like astronauts level
people taking super hardcore levels of
drugs and going into meetings with these
things and making intergalactic deals
and that,
and again,
that's what the government believes.
It says they're doing this.
When you say the government,
that's a broad stroke.
You're painting,
you're using a broad brush.
Like what do you mean by the Geico?
A rogue intelligence agents,
we you're saying is essentially that the
using psychedelic drugs to communicate
with interdimensional beings.
All right,
that's spirit guides.
Okay.
Everyone.
Everyone who's done a high dose of
psychedelic drugs has had this experience.
So everyone is listening to you right
now who's done DMT or done five grams of
psilocybin.
They know that this is a,
you have some kind of
communication with something else.
The question is,
is that something else inside your
psyche or is that something else?
A chemical,
her doorway,
is there a chemical doorway inside the
mind that opens up in the belief is that
when you die,
and this is the what the
afterlife is that when you die,
your brain reduce,
produces these chemicals,
these chemicals open up this doorway
and this is the portal to the next
dimension.
So you're saying,
you're saying that the government is
aware of this and they must be aware of
this.
They've heard enough people talk about it.
They must have done experiments on it.
What does it say?
The Poconos.
The universe for sure.
And,
and people that have the courage to
experiment with these things and try them
themselves realize that this is such
a profound experience that it is.
It's so alien that if an alien landed
right now in our parking lot and a little
gray man with big black eyes got out,
it would be nothing compared to
what I've seen on psychedelic trips.
Just tell Ya,
me getting under this show
is just because she'll,
people need to understand that I've known
about this for a long time and I just
don't think people are ready for it.
But a lot of folks
who,
uh,
have low oxygen and,
and how,
who and I hope brains well,
well who have,
you know,
sleep apnea.
I big,
big MACs,
pick hedge tongues,
go back like you and me.
You got down to 62% oxygen.
That's another time that
the brain releases DMT show.
My whole life since I was about my first
memories were every night was a DMT
trip show.
I basically,
I don't want this to sound arrogant.
It's not,
I've seen everything.
Well,
I believe that when you are dreaming,
it's most likely the same
chemicals that are being released.
Well,
a key point when you
go into the room sleep,
it opens the gate.
Which side is a proven,
your brain is working in the fourth,
fifth,
sixth dimension.
And if you can work into those dimensions,
you can see beyond it.
So it's when I'm trying
to tell you is this,
I know you already know all
this show for your audience.
Here's what's happening.
I'm not saying you're bad.
I never said you were in the CIA.
I say the CIA is on record with
Timothy leary and everybody promoting
hallucinogens in the 60s.
They admitted that it
was a plan to try to,
uh,
would it would do in the public
to make them more suggestible,
but there's a larger program and then
they kind of backed off because it Kinda
got out of control.
It actually created some,
some,
some people that were
actually fighting him,
so,
so it didn't have the effect they want it.
So then they moved on the Iowasca
and the DMT that they promoted,
which good strong people that have
a compass go and have problems with,
but weak minded,
stupid people and others.
Here's an example.
This guy is smart.
Uh,
Eric Mann,
cal Mahler,
syndicated radio host.
I don't even like 15 years.
You just lost me.
Well,
I'm going to tell you the story you said.
He's smart.
He's a nice guy and I'm just kidding.
He's a smart guy.
He may have been on his
show before the election.
I like him.
He will.
Everybody's,
everybody's on this quest
and I told you,
I've talked to like a hundred
people I've talked to more.
It was a lot of people
are going to do in these,
the DMT in Iowa,
Ska trips outside Austin.
They're doing them all over the place.
Yes,
and
I'm on his show and he's told me the same
story everybody tells you about being
in Peru or being,
you know,
Costa Rica.
He went to two trips
down there and he said,
yeah,
we're sitting there and we
take the Iowasca and then
all these basically elves,
aliens come out of the woods and
we're all seeing the same aliens.
We're all hearing the same thing
and it's like 43 of us or whatever,
seeing and he goes,
but it was the drugs effect on our brains.
No,
no,
no.
A drug.
Everyone sees something different.
When you open a gate and
now interdimensionally your
brain's already filtering
out most stuff because
you can't handle it.
Your eyes are already seeing can I got
a cat when it's like seeing something in
or a dog.
Well you know when they first identified,
um,
there's certain,
there's certain components to Iowa Osca
and one of them is harming and when they
first identified it,
they tried to call it telepathy.
Yes.
The reason why they call it telepathy and
when they were taking Iowasca later in
these group experiences
that were undeniable,
they were,
they were experiencing like
very vividly the same things.
And so the government's obviously obsessed
with this and isn't worried about,
but here's the problem,
here's the problem that that term,
the government,
are you talking about the post office
police officer's down is pretty,
you're talking about the fire department
ruling tronic who are these people?
But yeah,
I think the government is a shitty turn.
I know who they are.
Okay.
But that that term,
the problem with that term
is it lumps you into like,
you know that Mel Gibson movie conspiracy
theory was a wacky dude was driving a
cab.
I believed in fucking
tin foil hat type shows.
He'd been tortured.
Yes,
exactly.
We compartmentalize.
Yes but,
but that kind of stuff,
when you say the government is doing it,
like who is doing this?
Who's working on these experience?
We don't have to say names.
No,
no.
Here's the thing.
Obviously maybe you
want to say the gutter.
No,
I'll tell you it's a broad brush.
I know you're right.
It's dumb to say the government and
the big question is who runs things?
So that's a smart question.
That's the thing is they,
when everybody says they
don't want you to know,
do you remember that fucking guy who
is ripping people off like weight loss
secrets that they don't want you to know
Kevin Trudeau and they put them in jail
for that.
He's in jail right now cause he won't
give up the money cause he's got a pile of
cash somewhere.
And he said he would do they would they,
I think they said they would
give them is a con man.
I've met him a few times.
Very manipulative but I think he has a
right to Shay healthcare cures or natural
periods.
I don't want you to know about,
there are some,
but the point is they don't,
look,
I,
I have some love in my heart for
Kevin Trudeau because he started the
international pool tour.
It was a,
he was putting a lot of
money into professional.
Cool.
I mean here's the old,
the Oxycontin company.
The documents came out.
Shit,
we're going to totally a dick people and
then we're going to sell him drugs to
get off of it.
Yes.
That's pure fricking either.
So lock your ass up and then
we'll get to Kevin Trudeau later.
I agree with,
and I'm not even defending,
kept her though.
Cause I met with every girl a few times.
I know all about him and it was like
he was 100% about him and a one way
frigging straight.
Well,
I didn't get that experience with them
with me and I him just talked about pool.
I was doing some stuff with him when
he was first starting the pool tour.
I came to a couple of his events,
but he that day,
this thing that like you always have a
good way of asking questions instead of
saying who runs it.
All right.
You wait till I do the cliche the
government and you correct me.
What I'm doing is playing devil's advocate
and I'm also looking at it from the
perspectives of people of hours.
There's still Eddie's come,
let's do another hour and get out of here.
Okay.
Let's let Johnny No,
no,
not yet.
Do you want him to come
at two instead of one 30?
Yeah,
whenever you want.
I'm going to text him.
Right.
Anyways,
let me,
let me try to be clear.
Joe,
I'm having a good time with you.
I just want you to know
he's tried to be clear.
I can't say all of this on air.
Okay.
And I'm going to leave it at that.
But,
um,
I'm on record 20 years ago before anybody
else was talking about the clockwork
ELLs and other global listening to her
in touch with these entities and things
only because,
and I don't want to get,
I'm not in the CIA,
the CIA's bigger than Coca Cola.
It's like better than Walmart.
I'd never been an intelligence agency.
I've been part of any of this stuff.
But I had family that was in advanced
Darpa research projects that I don't know
all the details about.
And um,
when I was a kid,
my dad told me about some of it,
not knowing how to be
a talk show host layer,
but like when the deputy
director of the CIA,
he did have a tooth pulled to,
came to my dad.
Okay.
Show.
Then I was like the doctor to,
you know,
these guys.
And I remember sitting around the
kitchen table and I'm like 70.
He's like,
Carol,
I can't tell you all about it,
but it's a classified program in
Maryland and an underground base.
And,
uh,
they won't give me all the details,
but it's double the money I'm making
now and this international security.
But I think,
I think it's basically,
you know,
we're going to,
we're building cyborgs and we've got
special forces that have volunteered if we
could infiltrate the Russians
and get to codes and systems in,
I believe it's implanting,
but messages in their teeth and I,
and then I also think it's,
I do implants,
I think it's a brain surgery
program for microchips.
And so I'm hearing am I,
Carol was like,
David,
I'm sick of these people
and you've already done so
much for the government and
look what they've already
done to you and I,
my,
my brother,
you're not going to be,
I want you out of this.
So this is like,
you know,
seven,
eight years old and
like hearing about the,
you're hearing about the cyborgs.
Okay.
So,
so that's the kind of stuff that
I grew up seeing and you know,
oh,
let's go get your uncle.
He's come off as [inaudible],
you know,
Army Day in an army
uniform from Guatemala.
You know there's like armed
guys with machine guns.
I mean I don't know.
Okay.
And I don't need to know.
The point is is that's what I grew up.
You know the type of stuff I saw and my
dad never told me about all this stuff
when I was older till it was like 12
years ago and I was finishing in and
blueprint for global and enslavement.
That's free still online and it's all
about the world government and now the
cell phones watching you and everything's,
everything's proven in it.
It didn't come true.
It was already true.
And the plan for one world government
and don't have kids and all that and
attack on the family and we were going
to go to a ballet recital for like my,
you know,
three year old daughter,
she's like 14 now or whatever and they
sit out for like an hour and watch the
end of the films three
our film and my mom goes,
tape it.
That's not true.
He goes,
yes,
it's all true.
When I was in junior in high school,
they recruited me into the program there
and they brought us in and he said the
Nazis were wrong because they were
only targeting certain groups.
We're going to talk to everybody and so
planetary breakaway and world government
and blah blah blah.
There's a nuclear reactor under
ut and all this other stuff,
which later when research
is actually true,
it's not even hidden.
But the point is,
it's not that my dad
was even that special.
They g my dad was like the score,
like the six smartest in Texas and they
got a group of less than 10 kids and
they brought him in as juniors
in high school and shed.
We're going to do all this.
Like they recruited him
because I wanted to be a NASA.
That's why we're in the natural shirt.
So when it gets in here,
cause because Eddie's right,
NASA is a big secret group.
It's the other side of
the breakaway government.
There's the CIA breakaway government in
1947 and there's Kennedy setting up NASA
in 1961 so they're two different
competing breakaway governments.
And those are the real governments
in the USA by breakaway governments.
What do you mean breakaway governments?
Breakaway civilizations.
Each,
the real groups that are like the cult,
you say,
who are they?
They're scientists cults
who were based on uh,
your,
uh,
psychic ability,
and on your Iq and then on
your commitment to the program.
And so the program starts with where you
go and check black people with syphilis
for greater cost or will you do research
programs on babies where we tell poor
women,
uh,
that Oh your baby died
right when they born.
We're rolling.
We'll keep the baby alive
and sometimes kill him.
And I was harvest them sometimes
do experiments on them.
That's why they've got a lot of
nurses have notice now that the baby's
disappeared.
Birth.
And I tell him all your baby die.
That's why the governor said,
who's actually an Orban harvesting doctor?
He goes,
we keep the babies in love after Lou boom.
Have a discussion.
They are getting caught now
cause we'd be compartmentalized.
What w I'm confused.
What you're seeing.
How it just never ends.
Yeah.
What you saying about babies?
Like,
what did they do with babies?
You,
you saw the governor of Virginia Shay.
We keep babies alive after
they're born and killed him.
Right?
Well,
I didn't see that.
I am very,
very concerned with late term abortions.
Post-Birth Joe,
she understand post-birth how
much money do you think they get?
Wait for a seven and a half pound baby.
They can keep alive for two
weeks and Mama doesn't know.
So if they can register
the organs and get bitters,
but wait a minute,
you're saying they can make 500,000
would be saying that the they kill on the
spot only gets 50 grand.
But even saying that they take the baby
from the mother and the mother doesn't
know that the baby's alive.
Yeah.
You know how they engineered tomatoes?
The last on the shelf?
Yes.
You can pull all this up.
California's past it.
Uh,
she'd be in Virginia.
Virginia is about to pass it.
New York trying to pass it.
California trying to pass in three other
states are trying to pass it to keep
babies alive and allow notice.
The governor goes,
we don't want this three minute clip.
Pull it up.
We don't want the Gloveman vol.
The doctors and the
modal who's drugged up.
You didn't say that.
I'll go on this sad about the future
and maybe she keeps baby alive a week.
Maybe she sat to get rid of baby.
Wait a minute.
Is this a viable baby?
There's nothing wrong
with this paper viable.
The Senate voted three days ago on Monday
to not pass the bill for post birth
abortion to not kill livable post birds as
viable.
Baby's already born can be
killed if the bioethics sport.
I bet you 10 millions
probably that up Jamie.
We've got to figure it out of
the lessors won't believe me.
We can go crazy posts about this,
but it says that he did.
It's been taken out of context.
What does that media matters?
Snopes,
Huffington post is that
since it's mostly false.
Ah,
Huffington Snopes said no,
you do this.
Jamie.
Jamie,
go to,
you'd go to the source of the governor,
go to youtube and type
in governor of Virginia,
talks about post birth abortion.
Watched the unedited three minute video.
Do you call it abortion
if it's already been born?
Well,
that's what Trump said.
He said,
he said a month ago when this first broke,
he said,
I see the leftist still compartmentalize.
I'm saying her,
the less mainstream media,
whatever,
we're so censored now.
They're making their move right now.
Who's Day?
The globalist technocracy
the mad scientist.
The guys that are one and learn the
secrets of the universe is probably only
seven.
So what you're saying is
a lot of this censorship,
I don't have 10 million,
I will give before God
and country to Jamie's.
Uh,
I'm not kidding.
I will give $1 million to your
charity of choice right now.
Listen to me.
This is a serious change.
You need to come out eight children.
I will give you $1 million if you can
prove that I'm making up that the governor
said,
we keep babies alive after they're born.
We keep them comfortable and then it
turns out he's an organ harvesting thing
and that's what they're doing.
So they keep babies alive.
Don't go to Snopes.
Go to the governor,
go to the governor of Virginia.
And that's why they want to head
and burning for the black face.
But they were using the blackmailing.
They already had that on him as soon.
Same Guy,
same guy.
As soon as he sailing,
as soon as Trump.
And we all covered it.
As soon as he tweeted,
he said,
yes,
we're getting rid of babies
after they're already born.
You don't want of that.
No,
we already have figured out what
George Soros is putting in it right
now.
I mean,
I oversimplify that the media took,
I know I said they've weaponized marijuana
into an Ellucian as gin category,
so it causes more schizophrenia.
I think it does.
I said that two years ago and Courtney.
I agree.
Yeah,
I think it does.
I think it does research a lot of friends
who are already susceptible and the
weeds so strong that,
that,
that they start thinking that
I'm wearing swastika shoes.
No,
listen,
I agree with you on that.
I mean,
I think,
um,
I've a strong alpha types need
it to not have a heart attack.
Well,
I don't know if I needed to know what
you wanted me to smoke pot with you in
that,
in that bathroom,
shooting the video like as
a joke like 20 years ago.
Yeah.
Then I said it makes me paranoid.
That was funny,
Joe.
The only time I feel,
feel we weird fucking George Bush and
George Bush senior master dance around the
Capitol was fun time.
Nobody's devalued the feast and leave
the song that you wrote you at that
fucking song about it.
Jamie.
Jamie,
this isn't a joke.
I will give $1 million.
You don't have to give any money,
but I believe you.
I just want a little bit.
I have skin in the game.
I'll get pulled up on my phone.
I believe you.
I mean,
he's going to find it.
We'll listen to it.
You don't have to.
We're listening to you.
And then he uses these arguments.
He uses these arguments.
He goes,
well,
sometimes it's blue.
Sometimes the baby is just the phone.
No,
they want the organs.
And so who saw the planned parenthood
videos out of Texas to California two
years ago?
The project,
Veritas and others,
God,
who are,
they're saying,
I'm getting a yellow Ferrari,
man,
I'm making hundreds of
thousands off each baby.
We
partial birth,
they keep the baby alive,
they take it in the bag and then they
have a van pull up that takes it to a
Chinese government run facility in
the u s and they got the sucker.
Let's listen to this division after birth.
The boards.
This is a gym,
Alex.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hearing yesterday when Fairfax County
Delicate Kathy Tran made her case for
lifting restrictions on third trimester
abortions as well as other restrictions
now in place.
And she was pressed by Republican delegate
about whether her bill would permit
an abortion even as a woman is
essentially dilating ready to give birth.
And she answered that it would permit
an abortion at that stage of labor.
Do you support her measure
and unexplained her answer?
Yeah,
and I,
you know,
I wasn't there.
Uh,
Julie and I certainly can't speak for,
uh,
delegate Tran.
But,
um,
I will tell you one
first thing I would say.
This is why decisions such as
this should be made by providers,
physicians,
uh,
and uh,
the,
uh,
mothers and fathers that are involved.
Janet,
I'm interrupted her or
back up two seconds.
Notice he's usurping law and
their whole plan is bioethics.
Let's wait a minute,
but let's let him let him,
two minutes.
Mothers and fathers that are involved.
Um,
there are,
you know,
when we talk about third
trimester abortions,
these are done with the
consent of obviously the
mother with the consent of the
physicians more than one physician,
by the way.
Um,
and it's done in cases where
there may be severe deformities,
there may be a,
a fetus that's non Bible.
So in this particular example,
if a mother is in labor,
I can tell you exactly what would happen.
The infant would be delivered,
uh,
the infant would be kept comfortable.
Uh,
the infant would be resuscitated if,
if that's what the mother
and the family desired.
And then a discussion would ensue
between the physicians and the mother.
So,
so I think this was really
blown out of proportion.
But again,
we want the government not to be
involved in these types of decisions.
We want the decision to be made by,
uh,
the,
the mothers and their providers.
And,
and this is why Julie,
that legislators,
most of whom are men by the way,
shouldn't be telling a woman what she
should and shouldn't be doing with our
body.
And do you think multiple physicians
should have to weigh in as is currently
required?
She's trying to lift that requirement.
Well,
I think it's always good to
get a second opinion and for,
for at least two providers to be
involved in that decision because these
decisions shouldn't be taken lightly.
And so I would certainly
support more than one provider.
Let's
go back to the front.
Wow.
That's a weird thing that
she just kind of let him say,
um,
to the rough story,
but hold on a second.
It's,
what's weird is that she was talking,
they were talking about
resuscitating the baby,
that they would keep the baby alive.
Then a decision would be made.
Isn't that,
that's
like use in Asia.
Like,
you can't even do that a
grant while you're so smart,
gentleman cause your ass.
But you can't do that to your grammy.
Right?
Your,
he's like 80 years old.
You can't,
you can't just kill her.
She suffered a Newsweek cover
it the case for killing granny.
They say that.
So let me explain now you've got it.
Did you hear that?
Legalees turns out when I
saw that clip a month ago,
cause they had them do
a debate about the bill,
right?
And they said yeah we'll kill
babies after they're born.
And they're debatable how,
how far along what
whatever the doctors say.
But its jurisprudence,
there's law,
you can't do that.
So this just say oh the
government not involved.
This is the medical system.
You serpent if they can
kill a baby after it's born.
Cause sometimes they deformed.
You don't see that.
Sometimes they the phone,
here's the key.
Notice he shed,
we resuscitate.
They don't consider you alive till the
bio ethics board shares that you're a
viable human and under the bioethics
in Europe and under the UN now,
which is all Nazi by where the
EU was set up by the Nazis.
Volkswagen,
I'm not against fullest,
I going to sell,
but that that was literally drawn
the first of all texted by Hitler,
Audi,
the Olympic symbol.
I mean,
Hitler was a really bad dude,
but he literally so much
of our world's government,
him,
NASA,
everything.
They had a system where
they first killed babies,
they thought were deformed.
That was 1934 the final
solution happened like six,
seven years later and so he's saying
because they've got a big problem,
they've got an undercover videos,
they're keeping babies alive.
You want to pull those up.
I'm not be yessing.
There's hot,
there's dozens,
so they've got to start getting it going
now with governor physicians and people
to go because the nurses are
freaking out and they're saying,
we're keeping babies alive and they get
put in a van and drive away what's going
on.
They're like,
oh,
kids comfortable show the baby's worth
$500,000 who's paying the in the chain of
delivery just on time delivery?
I mean,
each Oregon's worth a lot of money and so,
but,
but if you kill him right on the spot,
they're like,
wow,
we wasted this seven pounds of meat.
So see if they can keep him alive.
And now they've built these new wings.
They've built new eggs so I can shut,
pull up a book.
They have wings where they go,
oh,
we consider the baby dead.
The mother decided it didn't live.
If she decides we
resuscitate and it lives,
but it didn't resuscitate,
it's flesh.
It's illegal east,
it's passed into a special
ward with doctors and make
a few million a year and a
little,
a little foolish.
Bolo is kept alive and comfortable until
all the oldest come in the planes land
and they take the logins.
Then they take the blood and they
take the skin Joe and you see,
oh,
now you know with his voice.
No,
no,
but see,
it's the southern loving bullets.
You See,
my dad knew Oregon Harvesters
in Dallas and he shed
don't sign your organ donor card.
They've got corrupt hospitals
where if you are totally viable,
they take your organs.
Oh Jeez.
And then I said,
dad,
you're crazy.
But I didn't send the organ donor card
and then am I know in the hospital two in
Dallas.
Then when I was deck,
a decade later at my
grandparent's house warming,
grandpa died watching 60
minutes and it was Dallas,
Texas and Chicago caught killing people
that were viable to take their organs.
Tonight they 60 minutes expose a,
and it was a freaking hospital.
My Dad told me about Jesus Christ.
So Joe,
that's what I'm telling you is,
were you at the kitchen table when
you were eight hearing about cyborgs?
See,
that's why I know about this.
My Dad never got fully into it.
He decided to get out of it
and he decided to get out of it.
He just thought of that,
you're legitimately
freaking me the fuck out,
Joe.
I will.
I will let you know.
The problem is some of it makes sense
because people figure out a way to
rationalize a lot of things.
And if you see a guy's
mangled in a car accident,
but he's still alive and you know
you could sell the you broken,
he can save five loaves.
Yakim comfortable.
Yeah.
I mean Joe the,
but the thing is how many people would
have to be involved for that to be real?
Joe,
I can show you,
let's not exaggerate.
15 videos of planned parenthood workers
laughing saying I made 1 million bucks
yesterday,
last year.
It's incredible.
If we can just keep them alive longer,
we'll get 10 times the money.
We're only getting 50 grand per baby cause
we got to kill them before they leave
the building.
The mother doesn't know their,
they talk her into it.
Oh ma'am,
you're three months pregnant.
All the baby might have a problem.
I'd have a heart murmur.
Oh,
the ultrasound.
Oh yeah.
And then they get the,
you're saying you're gonna
get to this is the truth.
Yeah.
They then keep it alive,
but only a few hours.
And they got to get planes coming in and
vans and they don't get the full price
because they can't put it on the auctions.
They've got digital corporate options.
Look this up for Oregon.
So let me,
let me bring something up to you.
I had this guy on yesterday,
this guy who wrote this book,
a l Narcos name was
Johan Grillo and he's a,
he's an investigative journalist who
lives in Mexico and he studies the cartel,
they she'll organs.
And this is one of the things
he was saying was that they,
they get these people used to killing
and they were getting these kids and
having these kids kill at a young age
and dismember people and they were doing
it to get the fear out of their body.
So this one guy who a,
they had a nickname for him,
Tyson,
he would,
he was a cop,
but he was also in charge of hiring these
little kids and training these little
kids to be assassins.
And he would teach them
how to dismember people.
And he was going into it.
And all the things they did and
all the beheadings that they did.
And he was saying that they'd try to,
that in certain certain groups of
people when they have this organization,
they try to get them
used to horrific acts.
Well it's called the,
she meant a blood and that's
an Heinrich Himmler term.
Uh,
head of the ash ash is that the
SS show Hillar had about seven,
eight years.
We launched the war show.
He got
like 12 year olds ready for war and
they would get them like having fun and
swimming and working out at boxing.
And then they would like
when they're like 15,
give a super hot hooker
and then give them drugs,
LSD and discovered Switzerland.
Hitler was put them all on it,
DMT,
everything.
And they would then have these
religious experiences and say,
you're invincible.
You're superman.
This has all been declassified.
But it said more esoteric writings.
And so they would get them all wound up.
And then to graduate as an SS officer.
After you'd had a dog,
like five years,
you had to strangle your German shepherd.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
my friend Ari.
His Dad was in the,
is really special forces,
one of those one brand.
Would you remember what branch was?
One branch of the Israeli military
and they had a kill a kitten and like,
like,
look,
Jews are just like anybody else.
There's good people,
there's bad people.
But yeah,
Israel because they got so screwed by
the Nazis in a lot of sickening ways.
Just kind of copied a lot of it.
And by the way,
the Palestinian trying to kill him,
blow him up.
I'm not even,
my point is,
is that the Nazis got evil down so much
that like we brought 34,000 in to run
NASA,
the run the universities,
operation paperclip,
everybody wanted Nazis.
They were learning to be more like
winning the lottery because they were all
robots and we do whatever they were told.
Well,
Wernher von Braun was headed.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So yeah.
And he was a Nazi show show.
Show what,
what happened was first
they gave him a sacs,
they gave him power.
They would really press room.
You had to go through things and then,
uh,
they would basically,
you'll just conditioned them
to do whatever they were
told and they call it the
cement of blood because then
it's just like satanic cults say,
you know,
kill your dog.
I mean,
I remember when I was
growing up in a Rockwell,
Texas,
I ran into like a and call.
I was like,
God,
this girl is a senior in high school.
She super odd.
I'm in,
I'm in a,
I'm in ninth grade and like she's picking
me up in a Mercedes and I'm taking me
some mansion and the sex
with her is incredible.
And I'm walking out of the house cause
I looked like I was about 16 when I was
13 and the dad goes,
you're like screw him,
my daughter.
Yeah,
I screw or two.
And just as soon as you join us,
you loved Lucifer.
You get all of them
will tell you want boy,
cause we want you.
But by that really?
Oh yeah.
But that's,
yeah.
Then I've had incredible
life look also do now.
But the point is,
is that El Kelly,
you're in La,
you know,
but all this.
But the point is he's know about all that.
The point is,
is that then the satanist,
cause I never really got an to say this.
And they said,
well,
I said,
well what do you want?
Cause I don't want to be,
we want you to kill your dog.
Whoa.
And so the point is,
is that now all these years later
kill a loving thing that serves you,
cares about you as interface.
Dogs are very psychic.
The psychic buffers.
Dogs are able to like interface with
you and they want you to take something
that's ready to die for you
and they want you to kill that.
That's like killing a child.
A dog is very similar to child,
very spiritual,
very holy.
You know,
very good.
Donald take on its masters aura,
it can be evil,
but joggers totally spilling my guts.
Circus people need to know about all
this and this is what's going on and this
is what's happening and show.
So they want to submit a blood
is they get people in a group
and they get them to horrible,
evil things during per pressure.
And then they create the synthesis.
You have to know the darker elements of
the criminal networks that are inside
our government are actually running Mexico
as a laboratory test cause they know
of Americans are taking,
the Americans are tongue Ho and
they're tough and they're ready to.
And you know,
I'm part native American long,
like 6% Comanche and you know,
Texas.
And just that little bit makes me wild.
And so they can get them
cause they're powerful,
they're smart,
they're neat,
they're cool.
But genetically they go
into group think really,
really fast.
And so native Americans you
can mind control really fast
was uh,
well it's like Vietnam.
I mean,
you know,
the little,
the,
the Bering land straight.
And basically the test,
the genetics of,
of,
of mezcal Americans,
it's basically Chinese or hunt because
there was always some whites and vikings
even 10,000 years ago,
the one in the area.
Uh,
but,
uh,
like nobody in fights.
And like in Korea,
the Chinese,
that's what we're really
fighting their Vietnam.
Do you think it's fricking,
let me,
they're like they're,
they're,
they're conscious and real people,
but when they get into a fight,
they all sync up and our
robots and have no fear.
I'm,
you're not about psychotic killers.
You're fighting.
And so Asians or by about
the most fearless killers
that are like the Mongols,
any of them.
I mean,
once agents go to war,
it's like they do now there it's in fact
they're not even craze going wild in a
battle.
They're like robots coming to kill you.
And so you think that's from,
do you think that's from their heritage
of war that they have a long like,
like if you think about Japan,
Japan has a long history of being a noble
warrior culture with the Samurais and
well it's come from the nobility.
It's the genetics,
right?
But other than genetics
is what creates that.
Yo,
it's like 500 of you loading planes.
Go figure saying,
I mean what I'm saying is think about
a place like Japan were so much martial
arts came from Kendo Sword.
Fighting a karate above a
bunch of different branches,
accretive,
judo,
Jujitsu,
Japan,
all that stuff came from Japan.
I mean that,
that,
that is a group of people that
were obsessed with combat.
I mean they,
they figured out the ruling class was,
well not just that the
soldiers and even the civilian,
no,
I agree.
But the ruling class
was a Samurai show guns.
The ruling class was the shoguns.
Right.
And when you think about what a small
place Japan is and how stunning it is that
so much innovation,
especially in terms of
like one of mine at work,
and I'll get into bell curve cause you've
got black people that are smart as any
white person.
And then he got black people that are way
better at sports or whatever and there
are genetic differences.
We're not.
And then you've got the
head of your former,
you know,
it was cold springs harbor.
Watson comes out and
says blacks aren't human.
All that Bs.
That's just the racist crap
that's in the government.
But it's true that northern some groups
from northern Europeans and then the
Japanese on average per
capita of the highest Iq,
and so they're,
they're Japanese.
And then there are
some northern Europeans
that have the highest Iqs,
but then you can get into like say Jews
have very high accused on average and
they own Jews have an extraordinary
high levels of social skills winners.
It's a bunch of,
so there's not just one
type of intelligence.
Oh for sure.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's,
I mean there's tests that you
can run terms of mathematics,
but there's no real tests you
can run in terms of social tells,
psychic connectivity and they've proven
that DNA is a transceiver and shut my
skill is,
that's why I'm usually kind of like almost
autistic is I'm just being constantly
like everything's going on.
But then it actually focused in,
I can like figure out the
exact enemy operation.
That's why they were really pissed.
They,
people that are Jewish,
that are German,
that are Chinese,
that are Japanese,
that are Italian,
that are Mexican people that
either through fear or whatever,
get into dark side,
light side,
get into,
don't give people the knowledge,
control the people,
dumb them down,
dominate them because they're only rocket
fuel for you to go to the next level.
You know what's interesting about this,
not that you're right or wrong,
what's interesting is how many people
resist the idea that it's possible for
someone to try to control everybody.
And if you just go back in history,
just you know,
go back to World War II and
how Hitler controlled Germany.
They tell you no one's
trying to control you,
but that's all that's going on.
But that one is a particularly
fantastic one because it was a,
a culture that came out of a bad time,
right?
They had out of World War One and this
guy treating and this guy offered them
pride in being German.
He offered him this.
This idea of a master race at the master
race is a crazy idea because if you
look at the black Israel lights or you
look at at at at La Rasa or Mecha or you
look at some of the
right lane Jewish cribs,
every the Chinese,
every group says with the master rough.
Yeah,
well,
sure,
but I mean how many have tried to
engineer it the way Hitler did?
That's what's really crazy.
Exactly the reason.
The reason,
the globalists,
well,
if you want the,
you want to get the sacred,
but I'm,
but I'm saying,
well,
Hillary's secret,
hold on a second.
What I'm saying is that it is amazing
that there is a guy who has this idea of a
master race and if you were all
but people rejected it worldwide,
it was one of the most
evil aspects of who he was.
That's really interesting
to me that people rejected
it because they knew it was
like an improper calculations.
General rejected the idea,
other leads trying to duplicate it.
It was an improper calculation.
The calculation was the only
way to get people to get,
you want to get a master race,
you have to have mastered genetics,
but it didn't take into
account was compassion.
It didn't take into account
what's necessary to have
a real healthy community.
That was a slow fuck a quick flash
community because everybody was like
hyperfocused on the nation.
To have a real long term community,
you have to have compassion,
you have to have camaraderie and there's
going to be people aren't using to your
raise the leftist
compassion when they support
China and different camps and and
engineer wearing the left cell.
Oak Can passion.
We can't hurt anyone's feelings.
We're helping a rest fall on gung and
sell their organs that we're Google and
stuck to me.
You're right,
you're right.
The left has giant flaws.
It has giant flaws and
it's ridiculous ideas.
No,
I'm against war.
I am too.
And so now you see national
studies show this Gallup poll,
Democrats now support war
more than Republicans.
Well,
this is about what this is about.
Pulling out a series he was trying to
denuclearize and everybody's loving it,
and South Korea and Japan and North Korea
and he's actually got them to not fire
missiles to destroy,
declared real the real problem.
There's a real problem with people not
being able to say that anything that
Trump does is good.
If a Democrat was doing what
Trump was doing on some issues,
I district with some,
I would support them.
I don't give a damn what their
deer or are well and so and so.
Then Trump got rid of the,
he's getting rid of the minimum sentences.
I mean Hillary Clinton,
you know,
Oh God,
I saw this the other day.
I don't,
I'm ranting.
But I was watching,
I forget to who the top Democrat was.
They were on CNN and I met to play the
clip of my show and I didn't do it.
And they,
and they go,
they go,
president Trump thinks blacks.
Yeah,
the clip was she and inch CNN says,
Trump thinks blacks are stupid.
And it was a CNN panel going.
Trump says blacks are super predators
who have to be brought to heel.
And Joe,
that's Hillary Clinton,
1994 after she passed the crime act.
That's her quote.
So they are inverting reality knowing
our talking point as she did that and we
have the video type in,
Hillary says blacks are super predators.
They said Trump did it.
It's not about Trump,
it's that he didn't do that.
Okay.
But let's get back to what we were
trying to say was that if you,
if he does anything good,
no one can accept it cause
he's on the wrong team.
That's part of the problem with,
with what's going on.
It's part of the problem with people
willing to accept ridiculous shit on the
left and people willing to
accept ridiculous shit on
the right is that we get on
a team and that the people
that are on the left,
they can't admit if the
economy's going well,
they can't admit if think they will.
Bill Maher said,
let's crash economy.
Oh,
I dunno.
Uh,
you know,
I listen,
I've been on his show before
and I talked to him once.
We did a show together once with Craig
to nobody can lie and say that he's not
very talented and,
and that he's of course tie.
He's more truthful than most leftist.
He says I want abortion,
I want death and the he's
a comic of telling you man,
the shit that he's saying.
He's only saying cause he thinks it'll
work and I don't just show with is the
highest ratings ever
gotten on invite me on?
I don't know man.
You don't have to talk to him.
But what I'm saying is when he starts
talking like people were saying,
Oh bill Maher's mocking the red states.
He's doing a bit,
he's doing a bit like you thought.
There's funny in that.
That's all it is.
Like if you,
if you've talked to him about
his legitimate opinions,
he's capable of having a conversation
about legitimate opinion of it.
I agree.
But you could disagree or
decoders are wrong on that point,
which was say that the red states
want to be the blue states.
The demographic show the opposite I think.
Is this a joke?
A really do I don't think even means it.
I mean,
if he doesn't mean,
and I disagree with them by the,
let me show,
let me have a thesis to let me
have to agree with you on this.
And I'm not saying you're wrong.
Okay.
Because everything I've learned is great.
There's a,
there's mixtures of everything.
Yes.
And by the time I go to the next spot,
I forget the last thought,
but,
but the point is,
is that,
is that what we're saying was that he
was doing a chuck about the red states
wishing that they were the blue states
and you were saying that that's wrong.
And I was saying he's just fucking around.
He's like product.
That's it.
Mainstream news is get
it as very low writing.
She can mean went down to
almost nothing and they go,
oh,
ratings are up in the Trump era,
like a dead cat bounce.
It's like 10% of what
it used to be lurking.
You should have 15 million viewers now
the top seat and show us a million show.
We're looking at that.
This is the future.
This is the,
this is the,
this is where the people are real things.
Not scripted.
No teleprompters.
There's no teleprompters here.
This is real.
And so they get up on television.
I'm literally having Alzheimer's.
What was the point again?
We were talking about Jesus Christ.
One problem.
Here's the,
where's the problem with no teleprompter.
I am literally,
I literally tell you what's in my brain.
The dentures,
like my truth doesn't mean I'm accurate.
It doesn't mean I'm perfect.
It means I'm telling you
when I really thought,
oh,
I don't want to fucking around.
I know what it is.
No one's watching mainstream news.
Sure.
But let me tell you
what they are watching.
The Big Five,
the nightly comic shows
and comedy central shows,
the daily show,
Trevor,
Noah,
Stephen Colbert,
all those guys,
cause they want some relief,
but it's,
it's not been,
they want relief.
Right.
I used to watch their ratings are down.
It's still on his span as you know,
as,
as other stuff because now
that no one's watching news,
Sean Hannity do really well.
There's an his show,
but only Fox because
it's seen as alternative.
Just like,
oh cool.
But,
but what I'm saying is,
well,
promise,
I'm not articulating this well.
It's the truth.
It's not like some packaged thing.
They have turned all of the so called
comic shows into fake comics posing as
fake news,
people putting out political commentary,
which people take is real
and believe on the street.
And so that's where all the propaganda is.
And so you say bill
Maher's just joking around,
Bill Maher's just over here,
Bill Maher,
what he's doing,
it's all a unified message.
They have Stephen Colbert and then leaned
upon her and say that I'm a KKK member
and make jokes.
And you know what people
shouted at me on the street.
Well,
that's unfortunate.
Um,
but what,
what I will say about
what they're trying to do,
they're not trying to deliver information.
They're not,
they're trying to crack jokes.
I guarantee you there's a whole
writing staff kind of them all marsh,
the Democrats call them and
tell them what to right now.
I don't know if that's true.
Uh,
but if it is as true and they do listen,
that's not good.
And that's unfortunate.
It's like,
yeah,
you host the man show with Doug.
Stan hope.
No,
the other guy,
uh,
there's Jimmy Kimmel and national
Carolla says he gets calls every day from
Chucky Schumer and then they,
then they work on what he says
he likes television type of.
This is what's so frustrating.
He might've been fucking around though.
No,
it's talking
points man.
Okay.
I believe you.
I believe you when Hillary lost Jimmy
Fallon went from being funny to being
totally weaponized.
So you think it was nbcs idea?
Do you think it was
someone in the government,
the contacts NBC and says,
Tell Jimmy showers?
A very well known UFC
fighter that you know,
okay,
who has shows on discovery
and history channel?
Am I going to say his name?
Okay.
And I got a call about a
month ago and they're like,
wow,
this is incredible.
Don't say my name.
You can talk about it.
They were going off me,
this new,
big lucrative shell,
but they said,
you're going to come out and announce
Alex Jones on the show or we're not gonna
give you the show.
And he said,
no show.
Hell yeah man.
Huh?
You're going to denounce him on the show.
What would they need that from you?
From him?
Yeah,
but why would they need
that from him and eat him?
Here's what's nounce you on the shot.
Not that that just give,
but that gives you even more attention.
Well,
let me explain.
That's their diluted.
Hey,
well they want everybody else sensor.
Why did Hitler says her?
Why did the Russian sensor like you think
most of the time sitters ship actually
works yet,
but that's a weird one,
man.
Someone saying they're not going to
give you a gig unless you specifically
denounced Alex Jones happens.
What kind of show is it
the cooking show?
No,
Joe.
Joe Gelena this down for you.
Okay.
I swear on my kids.
I told him the truth.
I believe you.
But I'm saying it just seems so crazy
that they would ask him to not to denounce
you on a television show.
I'm not saying it's impossible.
That's what everybody who's
not independent is told
because they're beholden to
other people.
You're a rarity.
I'm one of the only people that not
beholding to any other network of people.
You're already,
you realize I'm not just saying this,
just some Ken Shipp,
who else has a big mega popular show
that's multimedia that isn't controlled by
a parent company
am Corolla.
Yep.
Who else?
Um,
most podcasters,
no.
No,
but see when you look at the numbers
that most podcasts are threatened by
though.
But I mean almost all of them are
backed by something cause you hit her.
I know for a fact that
you run your own show.
Yup.
That's a fact.
Look,
I've got some notes here and
all I want to say is this,
I want apply one point
that you had about that.
That was really good.
You were saying that
if you sense yourself,
he's just like,
has a sense of myself a little bit,
just a little bit to make this point.
We started the but please bag.
This is the big enchilada.
You made it in the back,
start over and it and it's right you.
We were talking and we were,
first of all we gave it to other big hug.
We talked it out.
We're both happy that we're not angry at
each other and then we started talking.
You made a really good point.
You said the thing is if you
sense yourself just 1% you say,
I'll just censor myself
1% that's what they want.
I'm going to make them happy and then
they're just going to keep moving it.
They're just going to
keep moving it forward,
move the goal forward,
moving the goalpost and providing you
with more money and giving you more things
but keep moving it in a certain
direction and if you keep giving into it,
they're going to have a hold of you
and they can control you and that's how
network television got started.
If you really think about what men
for network television is,
the reason why they don't swear and
they don't have explicit content isn't
because people would want to see it.
The reason is because the co,
the advertisers won't let them.
There's a whole commerce aspect to it.
It's tough.
It's not just,
hey,
you're the CSI guys or hey,
you're exactly.
And so now they've organized with
sleeping giant and immediate matters.
A couple million people that call and
threaten and attack anybody and then
notice show once they're done with me,
now it's Joe,
you better not have this person on
or you better have that person on.
And so what is your shoal?
What is your destiny worth?
And I always thought I was smart because
I got to analyze politics and history.
I was kind of socially retarded.
And so I don't think you,
you'll have to say that anymore.
Exactly.
But I mean I was and,
and so that's what I'm getting at is the
biggest lie is with Alan people to know
the truth.
I don't come up with some cold blooded
calculation about what I think's going to
advance my personal life.
I really care about
people and the process.
I've seen things wrong.
I've grown,
I've heard people,
I apologize.
Listen,
that's true.
That's true.
What you're just saying about you and
this is one of the things that I've always
tried to explain to people.
If people get mad at me for knowing you,
Mike,
I have a great time with that guy.
Every time I see him,
you and I have had a great time in Austin.
We had a great time with the UFC.
We've hung out a numerous comedy
shows that I've done in Austin.
I've done your show 20 years ago.
We've had a lot of fun together and so
when when people get mad at you about
sandy hook or about anything,
I just go.
Even when he's,
even when you were mad at me,
I wasn't mad at you.
I was like,
I just got to talk to them.
They're like,
it's one of the reasons I,
Eddie Bravo got the two of us to talk
yet once we talk and just be honest with
each other,
we'll be fine.
And I want to clear this up because
when I was going big guns on you,
just so you know what
it's like to be judged.
I thought that you probably
never had on the show.
It was not an attempt to
get back on your show.
Listen,
I,
I knew that if I had gotten to the point
where you're that upset that I must
have made mistakes too.
I'm not,
I'm not that person that sees things and
always points in the other direction.
I pointed my,
I'm a fucking ruthless self critic.
Ruthless.
I'm terrible.
Like,
so I beat myself up about every third
house up flub one word on stage and I'll
sleep through the,
there's selling,
tossing and turning me raise this to you.
And again,
shelf,
that's a good thing.
It's just not going to be
a narcissist and crazy.
Um,
I got offered at the time like
$5 million with a Bitcoin,
I think it was like $38 million
by the time it got there.
I refused it.
And I,
and I got told like eight years ago,
I got told by two different people,
a very well known rich people.
They said,
George,
Charles,
you,
she wants to work with you and
Alexander Soros and other Soros,
uh,
you just need to stop attacking him.
Mm.
And,
and by the way,
we want you to pump bitcoin,
which I believe in cryptocurrencies.
I believe it's the future.
We had a private Federal Reserve.
It's all fee.
God,
I'm not judging anybody.
I'm just saying be careful.
And I was showed dumb back then.
I don't need you to say so dumb.
I was not in the current mindset,
the way the world worked.
Like I knew how politics worked,
and I knew how science worked
and I knew how crypto type,
you know,
government and CIA stuff worked.
But I was like never trying
to get a deal for myself.
I had my own thing,
right?
So then I look back in retrospect where,
where that was going on.
So when I saw you,
it was my breaking point.
Go,
Hey,
Alex Jones is full of crap.
George Soros,
uh,
was a victim of the
Nazis and the Holocaust.
That's not what I said.
I didn't see your full crop.
I said he wasn't a Nazi.
I go to the story that I,
I watched the interview and
I don't know what he did.
I don't see know the guy.
I don't know him.
I don't know.
I've know very little about him.
But what I remember from the story was
that he was saying that when the Nazis
occupied,
he was with his,
I believe it was his own donkey vote,
Godfather his godfather,
and took him around as a Christian
and pretended he was a Christian.
Whether they were stealing from these
Jews when they would take take there.
And he just thought it was normal
because he was 13 years old.
But he was talking about it,
that he was shielded by this person.
No,
I would be willing to
take his explanation.
It's what I'm saying,
but,
but here's the difference.
Even before that happened with you,
I got approached by a
major Hollywood actor,
uh,
that my name had been associated with,
and they said,
listen,
George Soros told me to tell you that
he'd been killed if he didn't do that and
that and that and that.
He did what he had to do.
Right.
And I shed,
you tell George,
if somebody put a gun to my head and shed,
we're going to kill you if you
don't help roundup Joe Rogan's kids.
And put them in a concentration camp,
I'd say,
Oh yeah,
I agree with you.
I've got the gun away and kill him.
Did he say,
he just said that there
was just taking property?
No,
they were,
what do you think it was?
Even Nazi show up.
Take your property and
then you don't go away.
I don't know.
I mean I don't know.
We know what happened in
Romania and Hungary but,
but Joe [inaudible] what he was saying.
Hey have headlines saying,
okay,
so you're saying you
think that it was more no,
no,
he did an NPR interview.
I'm not trying to go indict George Soros.
Okay,
well here's where I fucked up cause I
shouldn't have even said anything about it
cause I don't know much about it.
The real axle,
honest interpretation I've seen,
I've seen a couple of days
overdue interpretation when
I was 42 interpretation
from me.
I'm telling you,
I don't know anything
about it was incorrect.
Sure.
So when I'm 14 and I,
in retrospect,
if somebody shed,
we're going to,
you're going to help round up your
community or we're going to kill you.
I would have tried to kill people
that were trying to kill my people.
I get it.
Not Everybody's like me and I'm not
talking to the top of sky around.
I think I've proven,
I'll go up against people.
I get,
you're 14,
you're scared and you helped the Nazis.
He was show arrogant about it.
He shut it on NPR.
He started on 16 manage and then I
learned you're being sued because you did
this.
This is why he's financing.
Well,
I'm not going to stop
shaking it because of that.
I get,
he was in a bad situation.
The problem was if you play the clip,
he says it was the best time of my life.
It was happy making.
Uh,
it was,
it was invigorating to be there
with all this evil going on.
But I was with my father and I had faith
in him and so we were able to do this.
And then I went and looked at
the logs and the records of him.
He was like going around looking for
Anne Frank's man and getting their money.
And Alan,
yeah,
he got the money and some elsewhere.
I'm not,
I don't even just running up
a white flag is George Soros.
George Soros overthrew all these
different governments toward swirls,
tried to crash the pound.
George Soros is the,
is the arc type of James Bond
villains and the fact that his money,
so I remember being a kid when I was like
eight years old.
My mom always had a
color TV in the kitchen.
She cooked three meals a day.
Can I stop you?
What do you,
what are you saying that
he's like crashing economies.
And when I was a kid watching
PBS and maybe they were lying,
maybe he's great.
George Soros was an international currency
speculator who overthrew governments.
You,
you know,
but yeah,
but that's what I'm saying.
What do you,
what he saying overthrew governments?
Like what did he do?
I literally know nothing.
Well,
here's what I'm going to tell you.
This is actually a declassified.
Do you know anything about George Soros?
Jamie,
they'll type in George Soros.
Oh,
crashing the pound.
Let me tell you more.
In George Soros is view.
After World War II,
he got hired,
brought to the u s he worked for the CIA.
LSS before that.
In his view,
from his perspective,
he admitted he doesn't Brag about this.
George Soros is the guy willing to take
the money and DB it out and he's a very
bold guy,
but he's just,
he's really smiling.
I'm not kissing his ass or
you're gonna have a back.
He's not gonna stop me,
wants to hang my hat on the wall towards,
whilst it does have 150 why does he
want to hang your head on the wall?
Cause I went after him.
But the point is it doesn't matter.
George Soros ran the
breakup of the Soviet Union.
George,
I've had the former head of,
of,
of shitty got Jamie kind of thing.
Type in George Soros
tried to crash the pound
the pound.
Anyways,
the guys,
let me tell you,
I told you they got human pig.
[inaudible] you put them in Mit.
Okay.
I told you they're keeping babies alive.
You saw the governor said George
Soros is highest level deep state.
He,
he is the manager or was the manager.
Are you shooting in the secret
of the things you're saying?
I actually know,
but how do you know if
he has the research?
He ran the cause I'm not the auction.
I was 10 years ago he ran the Marshall.
We got here,
did George Soros break
the Bank of England.
It a little bigger police
in Britain,
black Wednesday,
September 6th,
right to the day.
The speculators broke the pound.
They didn't actually break it,
but they forced the British government
to pull it from the European Exchange
Rate Mechanism joining the erm,
which was part of the king,
the euro.
The pound wants a euro.
Scroll it up please.
Uh,
all those to depart from
the European currencies,
the British pound,
blah,
blah.
Compounding the underlying problems
inherent in the pound's inclusion in the
erm,
I'm not seeing this.
Where's the part?
George Soros does this.
Well that's just what you pulled up.
I mean,
I'm just,
I'm just trying to find it.
That's all I'm saying.
Spotty and the writing on the wall,
Britain updates interest rates to
teens and attract people to the pound.
But speculate is George Soros among them
began heavily shorting the currency the
British government gave
in and withdrew its erm,
the erm,
ah.
As it became clear that it
was losing billions trying to,
boy,
it's currency artificially,
although was a bit of a
bitter pill to swallow,
the pound came back stronger because the
excess interest in high inflation show
forced out of the bridge.
As you go to investors pdf,
it's the boss.
Hold on.
He,
there's films about the Soros,
Soros,
Soros pocketed $1 billion on the deal
and cemented his reputation as the
premiere currency speculator in the world.
Now,
if you're a currency speculator,
isn't that what you do though?
I don't know what a
currency speculator does it.
I don't want to hear,
here's the deal.
George Soros works for the works for the
people that are on our government and
he's a guy willing to do it all
and he's been very successful.
Okay.
My point is two plus
two equals four in my,
in my equation,
you don't fight the Nazis
because you're 1314.
You think you can't,
you join them and he says,
he talked to me about investment.
I I,
if I wouldn't have done it,
someone else would have done it.
That's a quote.
It was happy making dude.
If you help roundup Jews
and take their property,
don't say it was happy making
you don't talk about it.
So my point is him,
you,
you think the way he describes it,
even as a problem,
it's problematic.
It disturbs you the way
he's describing that.
It was happy making that it was not a
big deal if I didn't do what other people
have done it,
that's a problem.
What I'm telling you is I'm going
to get off in a Soros is that if you
had five minutes over there on Jamie's
computer and he did a good job,
Jamie does a great job.
I'm just saying it.
Pull stuff up.
He's a goddamn Google wizard.
Look at them.
Let Le has been beating me a quick too.
It's very frustrating.
I would have gone over there.
I can pull up Soros.
I can pull up the BBC reports.
Soros crashes the British pound or trash.
Here's an example,
and I'm not indicting you for this.
Um,
someone in my family about 10 years ago
was digging through stuff for basically
garage hill wasn't a garage.
So we're going to give it away to,
to charities and uh,
you know,
all these clothes.
I couldn't wear it because I didn't
want to get 190 pounds anymore.
And a family member got into a group of
things and there was a Japanese bayonet,
there was a German officers dagger
that I bought for like 200 bucks.
That's worth like 2000 hours,
still have it.
Wow.
And,
and,
and all the rest of it.
And there was a British metal and the
Nazi metal and this person in my family,
cause he's like a power thing goes,
oh my God,
you're a Nazi.
So I walk in,
she's crunching the garage
and out of the box and I go,
I,
I bought this at a gun
show like a decade ago.
I,
yeah.
I think a fricking swastika
metal thing though is if you own,
this is the thing,
if you like,
see that helmet that
you were 12 point yeah.
We show them helmet.
That's what I'm a say,
Joe.
You get to it,
so you've got a German helmet that have
Frisch artists dug up with all these
mass graves and it's got a German
band that you're not a fricking Nazi.
That's a piece of history.
I think that's a US soldier.
I don't know.
That's a German helmet.
That's a turtle,
but it doesn't matter.
France has banned owning
German war memorabilia like
Sony and the coolest thing
I ever saw at the
Smithsonian when I was a kid,
so proud of us beating the Nazis was they
had a German helmet with a bullet hole
at the Smithsonian's not Nazi.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm not Nazi for having a Nazi metal
and a bunch of other war paraphernalia I
thought was cool.
You're not a Nazi for
a Nazi bayonet boats,
a helmet and a bayonet.
What does the gentleman's name that
makes that Shit Shane Martin does.
Can we show it please?
What is his,
yeah,
we showed it.
He also made me a
fucking super dope skull.
He's got to read and not that
I'm saying is that artist,
the German helmets.
Interesting.
When I was going to say is,
hey you,
you could have a Nazi helmet 20
year look about Hogan's heroes.
Hogan's heroes was Goddamn
Sitcom about Nazis.
It's a sitcom about Nazis
and prisoners of war.
I mean that was Mexican directness
that I literally had a family member.
This was like 18 years ago.
Go.
I'm really upset about what I
found Shane against the machine,
right?
Yeah.
Is that there in the garage and it's like
British metals USA metal's a couple of
dads.
Of course.
I wanted the Japanese
thing that I even had it.
I remarried car.
Been for Vietnam.
That's not as cool as World War II yet.
Go to Shane against the
machine on Instagram.
He's not a Nazi.
That's fricking cool,
man.
He sells those folks.
If you want one about I'm to do a product,
plug us be plugging up.
Dude.
He made me a another sculpture
too that I bought from him.
He says,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm not saying you're a Nazi,
but I had family think because
I had one Nazi party member.
Metal.
Yeah.
It'll be on the news today.
Joan's admits she has not changed.
Tough.
No,
it's fricking interesting,
man.
It is.
This is from a battlefield
dug up of dead people.
It couldn't be it more interesting and
you take darkness and light comes out of
it.
You make evil become good.
I bet.
Have you talked to the artists?
God,
I'm doing it.
Here's a plug for them like,
oh,
this guy doesn't know shit.
Look at this guy's stuff.
Look at that Eagle.
Go back to that.
A bird with the fucking
cylinders with the cars.
Is that what it is for [inaudible] or
the band at the top of his shoulders.
The top of his shoulders
is a car cylinder.
That's a car cylinder.
Yeah.
That's a Polish town car cylinder and
then bayonets for the wedding in product
placement because they're trying to
shut me down in front of store icon of a
product.
Artists.
Ben,
he's a great art.
I brought this up because I walked
in here and I shed God stope.
That is amazing.
And,
and it took,
you told him the story,
like they dig up,
I know these battlefields
and France stuff with,
and then people get this stuff
that is rotting German helmet.
You put light and it makes it beautiful
and it takes the evil of Hitler and
makes it beautiful.
Not Hitler takes humanity
and makes it beautiful.
Yeah,
it's a,
but,
but it is interesting that you can't own,
like you could never own a Nazi flag or,
uh,
any like you could
[inaudible] here's the thing.
Both my grandfathers and
not brag about family,
but remember Tom Landry,
my grandfather was a ut football,
won state championships and
track all at my mom's dad.
And he went in the army
air corps with Tom Landry.
Remember being over there on Sundays,
he,
before he played for the Dallas cowboys,
he'd like Tom,
I recall.
And they pray for five minutes,
both my grandfathers
about Jerry Jones and,
and,
and I,
you know,
my mother's father,
Mr. Hammond,
we almost died in a crash landing.
And another deal,
I almost died.
I don't almost exist because my
family America fought Hitler.
And then now I'm a Nazi because I believe
in the second amendment and I believe
in America.
That's not fair.
Well that's not what they're saying.
They're saying because you had
a Nazi piece of memorabilia,
but it still doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense.
Look,
if I saw some cool Nazi thing at
a some place where I could buy it,
I might buy it and frame it cause
it's just a piece of history.
Just like I would buy a,
a Gingiss con dagger or a helmet.
Oh my God.
Eddie Bravo's here.
Jesus Christ.
We're having a great time talking
about a two dimensional beans,
bro.
Choke you out with this shirt.
Nassa I'm gonna make you regret wearing
this fucking shirt and listened to high
school.
We used to choke each other out.
That's like a thing of teacher.
Go ahead and drop me off on it.
No,
no,
no.
Please don't.
I'm not scared.
Let's go ahead.
No,
no,
no.
Eddie don't.
Please don't choke them unconscious.
So now let's go.
He can't do it.
You know,
you think I'm afraid of this.
Let's,
no,
I definitely don't think
you're afraid of this,
which is why I don't want them to do it.
Choked me up.
You know what?
Let me tell you a story first.
Back when I used to
work at the Strip club,
you're the one,
hold on Alex.
Sit down please.
Come on please.
We have to work together here.
Let's work together.
Come sit down.
I'm not getting good luck and yeah,
have a seat.
Have a seat or choke me out.
Alex,
please have weak high school.
I know you did.
You told me he grabbed each other
and you fall down and hit your heads.
It only takes like 20 seconds.
We'll you're going to
say about strip club.
Back when I was a blue belt,
1995,
I worked at a strip club and,
and um,
there was this girl I was dating.
She never had any of those
know she was a bartender.
She was seriously four foot 10.
And why are the bartenders and waitresses
is always the best way to go to strip
clubs?
I don't know how you got to let them.
I will.
She was,
she was 92 pounds bartender,
the smallest girl.
And I showed her how to
do a rear naked choke.
She was tiny.
Her name was Kimmy.
And the Strip club manager
was your size.
Big like used to be BOF butt fat ass.
Yeah,
but used to be,
but you can tell you used to
be buff football player type,
big manager.
You know,
you want those guys
that manage strip clubs,
you know,
intimidating looking big dudes.
And he had a corvette and he
didn't believe in Jujitsu at all.
And she said,
uh,
he said if she could choke
me out with one of them,
Jujitsu moves out,
give her the keys to my car.
So she had to literally get on a bar
stool and she was standing on a bar stool
and had to go around them.
And she went like this
and he was just like this.
And then he went out,
lights out,
he dropped like a sack of potatoes.
He hit his head on the fucking floor and
impact the impact of his head hitting
the floor.
Woke his ass up and so we hit the
ground and then he pops back up
and he didn't know,
look happened and was just sitting there.
I thought he faked it.
That's what I'm getting.
I'm like,
people usually don't kick
the ground pop back up.
Usually they hit the ground,
they're done and they need an ambulance,
but he popped right back up and he's like,
what happened?
Like bitch,
you need to give her your core value.
I'll pop right back up.
It was a,
it was a corvette.
Oh,
this was a thing I know about this,
about in seventh grade.
During lunch,
kids would choke each other out.
You put your hands up on her neck.
Kids don't do this.
I'm not teaching like
Tom died box doing this,
but then it'd be like the cheerleader
is wanting to be choked up and then they
would show us out.
I probably did it about three.
Did you go to school?
Go to school where the bill hooks go to?
He's not bill Hicks,
but right now we already went over this,
that this guy's talking about this,
you know the crazy him is you can put
together a case where you fucking,
you can wave.
Bill Hicks live known Alex since
just a few years after bullies.
All you got to see his old way differs
a bunch of old for a separation because
you and I worked with
somebody that worked with him.
When you work with thousands of people,
suddenly it's like,
oh,
we do the same person.
It's such overrode all you gotta do is
just show those pictures of you like at
10 only this off.
I'm like,
Bill Hicks is never 20 and yoke.
You are jacked.
You were like a bodybuilder
and I used to run like,
I think it's,
I wish I get in that zone again.
You can have gotten this young where
I ran six miles every other day and I
lifted weights.
Should people go,
dude,
you'd be bigger if you
can work out three hours.
I was addicted and then I got on radio
and TV and like try to drinking and just
stopped and it didn't work
out for like 10 years,
getting like a hundred pounds.
Alex,
let's,
let's get you on something where we
actually like put it online and to talk
about what you're doing.
If you commit to something
online like that,
you'll do it.
All you have to do is
like set a realistic goal.
I used to do 40 pull ups and I can do
like two 40 in a row like crossfit type
bullets or use your whole
body and everything where you,
that's amazing.
You're like doing the
worm when she amazing.
But the problem was I used to go to all
you can eat buffets that's amazing to
Chinese and uh,
I don't believe and and regular and
the problem was I would literally like
order.
I go,
no,
I don't want the two of
you think about this.
What do you think about a self
improvement thing that you do online?
We do it online.
I need to do it.
The problem is every
time I tried to work out,
the phone's ringing and it's like,
Oh shit,
let's listen.
You just get up earlier.
Get up an hour and a half for,
for my torn bicep.
Well,
once you have surgery for your
bicep and everything gets fixed,
I think once you get your bicep torn,
you're probably going to be
a little bit out of action.
But that's only six months.
No,
you know what?
I'm Novitsky had it done.
It's fucking amazing.
I had my bicep done,
but to the shoulder or
to the bicentennial,
like this,
to the elbow to the shoulder.
Different.
No,
no,
no.
You have to do,
we're talking fricking autozone of years.
Number one.
No,
no,
no.
There's no need to choke you
or tried to sue me and shit.
This is one of the first things.
Once we,
once we made up on the phone,
one of the first things
he wanted me to do,
his choke him out on the air.
You might need to go to them.
SMM,
those,
uh,
those SNM pain dungeon choked out.
You'd like go somewhere and I've got a
little dream and then you come around
back.
DMT.
You hate that shit.
James is on point as well.
Let's get serious.
Let's get Siri just share a few
things before he goes down this road.
Okay.
These are the,
what are the rope but
going down I'll roll.
We just talking about we
know what the road is.
They're talking about George Soros.
No,
no,
no.
We past that.
What we just talked to him about,
uh,
you were talking about the Strip club.
The guy choke at the girl,
the girl truck with the guy out,
the guy falling and hitting his head
and then what happened after that?
Any ideas?
Jamie?
No one.
Everyone's stupid for that.
I got choked out.
I remember watching the babies.
I remember what it was.
It was cool.
I don't think I've ever been choked
completely out of 40 for a second.
The first time I got chucked out was like
this 17 year old super hot chick and I
was like 13 tied up and
she lived down the street.
No,
no.
She goes,
I already,
I got permission.
I was pretty young like 12 and she goes,
I'll have sex with you.
It was a true story.
I'll have sex with you if you let me put
makeup on it so I'm not in the gates.
Everything show the girl puts the makeup
on it and have sex with her and she's
super hot and then like
a week later she goes,
now I'm going to choke you out.
And that relationship went really well
until I'm like 30 year old boyfriend
caught me at her place once
cause her mom was hers working.
Oh my tried to kill me in the parking lot.
Oh my God,
I have sex with him.
I can put makeup on you.
I let her deal.
Listen,
you're a wise man.
She can.
That bitch can dress me up like a clown.
Anyway,
here's some of the things I have
and then we'd get to go forever.
Here he goes.
Not conspiracies,
but real world programs.
Developing a breakaway civilization.
What does a breakaway civilization?
You understand that it's
the key to everything.
Uh,
standardized.
Total surveillance.
Control Grid,
the power.
Despise the power control.
Human animal hybrids.
We recover that mass
farming of humanoid tissue.
Transhuman endgame.
We covered multilayered binary
weapon delivery systems.
That's when we haven't had,
oh what's that?
Well we'll get into some of that.
The pain is five g
behavioral modifications.
We hit that Trojan horse delivery system,
cell phones,
vaccines.
Gmos have been tested
and designed to hurt you.
Again,
vaccines are real.
You can give somebody something that gives
them the cure to another disease that
didn't look yet,
but they're jacking it like a cell phone.
They're adding stuff in
your ticket to immortality.
We think so.
Let's cover that.
What do you think is
happening with vaccines?
I know,
okay,
tell me what's going on.
I always use this cause
everyone's heard of it.
Everyone heard about 1947 to 1983 and
only came public because the program was
exposed in Peru and promote
close in West Virginia.
But the media picked up
cause it was white on black,
not all the white people that happened to,
I don't care if you're black or white,
injecting over a million people with
live syphilis in the name of vaccines.
You know about Tuskegee.
Do know about that,
but you only know about Alabama and
over 40 something years only injecting
blacks,
but it happened all the
world search engine.
Hillary Clinton apologizes for
syphilis experiments in Tuskegee.
There was this Gig,
it was,
it was in Peru.
Can I ask you,
this was the Tuskegee was the,
um,
the conventional story that they had
syphilis but they weren't really curing
them.
That's a cover.
No,
but it's not what they say
if you actually read it.
No,
they were giving him selfless.
Okay.
I understand what you're saying.
But was the,
the,
the conventional explanation
of what happened was that,
that they knew that they had
it and they allowed them to,
that was the [inaudible] came out.
Okay.
Have you heard about
hearing his right there?
US apologizes for Guatemala,
STD experiences.
They did all of the different ones.
Just type her ruin medic.
Hold on.
Gift in this.
What do you make that a little
go scroll up so I can read it.
A US government,
medical researchers intentionally
infected hundreds of people in Guatemala,
including institutionalized
mental patients with
gonorrhea and syphilis without
their knowledge or permission.
More than 60 years ago.
Jesus Christ.
Show Joe again.
Um,
when you've read,
cause what I do is,
oh Jesus Christ,
look at this.
Many of those infected,
we're encouraged to pass the infection
is usually managers as part of the study.
Where does this end?
What is QMS is NBC News.
Imagine finding how you have syphilis,
but you've never had sex before.
Let me stop.
Let me,
Shaw's is gone.
You imagine how confusing you ready for
another ultra secret since this 46 to
what?
46 to,
sorry,
it says it at the bottom.
46 to 1948 God damn.
946 months.
That's all I watched.
That's not okay.
It's not two years.
Okay,
so,
so let me expand
then.
Imagine Joe,
here's what's happened.
Okay.
We
had a real liberal media in this country.
They weren't left us.
That's,
that's a cultic.
That's different.
We had a real liberal media in
this country that had problems,
but they really cared.
They were open minded.
Like I said,
Delta has done information.
A few years after I proved Delta force
was in Seattle on and on and 99 and
proved it.
They all said,
Alex Jones is ride.
It's incredible.
That's the WTO tape that I always
cite that tight that we showed.
The agent provocateurs went into a
peaceful protest and started smashing
windows,
and I'm not against the army,
but Delta force ran it
because I always go,
oh,
do the army's terrorist.
Like you said,
don't call it the whole garden in a
select group of the army did that.
They staged it.
Show.
Imagine used to the Ma.
The press would get a lot of stuff right,
but they would get demoted or whatever.
What happened once Trump got in,
which I don't think Trump's pad
and it got level things are good,
but I almost think light,
it's more sophisticated.
They put him in on it,
piss everybody off to get the liberals
who traditionally have been the real
watchdogs for free speech and it gets
human experimentation and suddenly they're
like in Gallup polls,
we love war.
We love experimentation.
We love everything.
I'm getting chills right now.
And so imagine Joe,
I've been on air for 23
years and I'm a news hound.
I spend four,
five hours a day reading news leave
NBC News that there are government gave
people.
Notice I said Peru because
that was a big document,
a case you just found Guatemala.
Keep track of this.
We'll just stop it everywhere it went
under the age it's still going on.
So imagine,
imagine I have literally by
the time Sandy Hook happens,
I've literally seen 10,000 articles
and documents are more where they're
admitting.
In 1962 the joint chiefs of staff under
LLM answer came to president at Kennedy.
This is on PBS and said,
we're going to blow up buildings,
shoot up schools and movie theaters
and bomb army bases and marine basis.
We're going to have people with their
kids with name change their CIA get on a
jumbo jet,
the texts off.
It gets blown up over the Caribbean.
We blame Cuba,
but that plane really lands and
there's another plane that's a drone.
We blow up and then Kennedy says,
no,
but his brother says,
I'll do.
It's why they killed Kennedy
because Bobby said he would,
but then he got pissed when they
killed his brother sold the classified.
He wanted to bomb the Honduran embassy
and blow up stuff and go to war with
Moscow.
Bobby was bad.
You could actually,
this is pull this up,
pull up.
Bobby Kennedy wanted to bomb
the u s embassy in Honduras.
This is declassified.
And so imagine you see hundreds of these
and then a sandy hook happens and your
listeners don't buy it and then
it just psychosis where then,
well,
because every,
every man I knew,
this is hypothetical it.
That was great.
Every man I knew when I was a kid
backhanded me and beat the crap out of me.
So men are bad or a woman has been raped.
She thinks all men are bad.
She'll eat.
I get like the psychosis and I'm not
trying to put myself down like I'm a
victim.
I'm being honest.
Retrospectively,
that got to where when I learned
that so much stuff was false.
Then later I experienced
where I had the guest.
I did the thing,
I knew it was true and then people made
up a whole story because they don't
believe anything anymore.
So that's all I'm trying to say.
Do you think part of it is that
even though this stuff does exist,
it's almost like there's too many
things happening for one person to pay
attention to all of them.
And if you're only focusing
on national overload.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or if you're only,
but hold on,
if you're only focusing
on that aspect of life,
it can be incredibly overwhelming cause
you start thinking that's the whole
world that the whole world is these
conspiracies because these are the things
you're concentrating on primarily.
But this,
this is what I'm saying.
That's it is he just talked
about operation Northwoods,
that whole thing.
That was operation Northwoods.
Yeah.
That is some,
that's about as high ABC.
That's about as that's true.
Clear as day.
But if you break it
down and you look at it,
you look at operation Northwoods,
you look at that shit that is about as
gangster and sinister and evil as you.
Yeah.
We,
we went over just a little while ago.
We were going into.
Totally.
My point is if you believe that
no other conspiracy theory,
whether they're right or wrong,
like government conspiracy
should be ridiculed.
You shouldn't,
there's no,
there should be no ridicule.
You're right.
You should,
instead of looking at them with riveter,
cool,
you should look at him.
Objective Lee and,
and exactly.
And the only,
the only people that have a right to
ridicule a conspiracy theories are people
that don't believe in
any conspiracy theories.
If you don't believe in any of them,
yes,
I understand why you're
ridiculing it all the time.
Even some of them,
if you believe in some of them,
the other ones you don't believe in,
I think you should be more.
Uh,
I don't believe in that shit,
but I understand why.
But to me,
my defense almost now almost,
we could probably get a store on a cord.
I'm most looking forward
to trial in Texas and,
and Connecticut because I want to
and the Lord has already agreed.
I'm going to sit there and I'm going to
show them history and all these things
that say like,
I mean,
I watched the,
uh,
it's already been out
for like a year or two,
but I watched the minions three
or four and it's like in the 60s.
And they break down to the
set of Hollywood and the
moon landings being staged
now.
Now astronauts died doing that.
So how traumatic is that for their family?
But I,
I believe that
we're going to get to in a minute.
Wait,
wait.
Astronauts done which ones?
Oh,
space shuttle.
When we're going to talk about,
no,
the Apollo launchpad
was talking to one.
We're not
practicing.
We're practicing.
Okay.
So we're going to get to this next and I,
I respect you.
I want you guys to yell at each other
for three minutes while I go pee.
I gotta pee two.
Okay.
As you don't talk to yourself,
just hold,
we'll do it and shit.
Shit.
I'll go first.
Okay.
Anyways.
And know what I'm saying.
This and you're bad.
I get
it.
No,
you do get it.
You know why?
Because,
you know.
No,
of course.
Of course.
Alex,
you,
you are someone that I could talk to
about the flat earth conspiracy and you
believe in so many crazy
things about the government.
You don't,
you don't,
uh,
you don't believe in flat earth,
but you can kind of understand
where I'm coming from,
right?
Yeah.
GPS is real.
I know airline pilots that
fly from California to,
uh,
you'll places like Australia and they've
got another wing over to Hong Kong and
then they go to mosque and you
can fly anywhere in the world.
If it was flat,
it was flat.
It has,
you could go from east to west
just like you could on a ball.
You just don't understand what,
uh,
like a,
like a pizza is,
you could just go anywhere.
Like if you're on a flat or do you
want a flatter is what I'm talking.
Travel anywhere.
Give two cities.
He pointed to cities and
you can just go to so much.
I get what you cost you.
Nothing to do with the pouch.
I'm not that.
No,
no,
no.
Listen,
I have the money.
I'm not trying to convince you.
I'm not trying to convince you,
Alex.
My point is my point.
It takes you got to,
you got to find it on your fucking own.
There's no way you're
going to be convinced.
No,
no one has ever been convinced or they
have to really find it within themselves
and and do some deep,
deep,
what I'm telling you,
this soul searching.
If I finance a research ship,
large ship and make a documentary,
I can't go away for three months.
I will pay for you three months.
I'm not,
you know,
there's,
to me having,
money's not a big deal except
we can do cool things with it.
One of them.
What's one of the,
can you race
to go to the South Wall?
We're going to need,
we're going to need a,
you guys go into the food or in orbit.
Just try not to go on a cruise ship.
This is what I'm going to do.
Okay?
You raised the money for a trip.
You
do this the deal.
Go Pee,
Go pee,
man.
You're going to go see
the plan.
He's the ambassador.
He's the Ambassador
to just go pee,
man.
Big Ice Fields.
That guy's going to be,
and this is what this
one we're going to do.
Alex,
can you give me times 27 a tire crew
who are going to the edge of the flat
earth,
but it's not going to be me.
I'm going to,
I'm going to designate somebody.
It's not just scared,
so I'm,
we're going to do this.
We're going to do this.
Try Joe Rogan.
Yeah,
no,
no.
We're going to do this job and the sand.
Awesome.
You're going to find
the edge of the world.
They ice caps,
caps.
They're knocking things off
the drop off with my iPhone.
Yes.
Go Pee,
man.
Hopi.
Don't you have to go?
We're going to send someone else.
Alex [inaudible].
We're going to do you know what?
We're going to do this.
I don't want to be the one
that goes here in a minute now.
Now I came here and I please or keeping
babies alive and taking their organs.
How does it prove that
Jamie pulled some shit?
They admitted that.
Normalizing it.
No,
the fuck the governor.
You really think,
do you really think there's people
out there campaigning for late term
abortions?
You think that Shit's real.
You have to say six
routed Monday to keep it.
Who would campaign for it that they look,
they're fucking Kelly already.
Marquette's saw.
You're telling me it isn't real when
I had a fucking Goddamn fucking it.
That's a conspiracy theory.
We met your fucking top.
You're about to get it
already born babies.
Stop fucking lying.
God fucking damn.
I'm getting pissed now.
Don't get pissed.
No,
I mean you saw the dude is fucking
fucking Senate voted to kill babies.
I'm fucking bars.
Of course.
I believe that
course.
I believe Eddie,
let me explain to you when,
let me explain to you.
We went into a long
conversation that I heard it.
I heard it.
You heard it.
I heard the whole podcast years chasing,
playing with this psychosis is so crazy
that always thought I was so tough
anymore.
I gotta Piss a little bit.
There's the point is,
is that the point is,
is that dude,
I'm not the reality.
So crazy.
Why are we debating
whether the earth is flat?
Dude,
they're keeping,
they have human animal hybrids.
There's,
there's the fricking,
I have been there when people that
work for the Pentagon say that they,
we go to the laboratory and
we meet with the ambassador.
We have to take higher and higher doses
to meet with them and they're giving us
technology and the technology work.
I've been,
this is going on Duke.
You want to know this?
Listen,
rely or think about how this isn't real
man.
The aliens.
Alex,
think about what I said I said to,
do you think there's actually people
out there did believe that our campaign
telescope
this into what?
I sucks.
He's functioning you.
When I said fucking with you and said,
do you think there's actually people
out there that are campaigning for late
term abortions?
Of course there are,
but I'm making it seem like I don't
believe they are hugging it down.
Know I'm being the ultimate skeptic.
Ultimate skeptic worlds
does that all the time.
He says [inaudible] right there.
I'm threatened about Mr. Goody two shoes.
Buy them,
keeping babies alive and killing
them and that nobody cares.
I fundamentally,
that's what I'm saying and I'm being
honest here is I'm not like certified but
crazy,
but I deal with this all day long.
I get what job?
Tried to shy away and people go crazy.
He's doing know.
Why didn't I never saw that clip of that
guy saying that they would resuscitate
the babies and then they would make a
decision and heard about that New York,
a bill that they're trying to pass
and then there's some big shit.
It's like,
it's like a
city.
Well,
worsening cough.
They're giving a bunch of Goddamn
fucking organ harvesting doctors control
outside of law.
You heard that piece of shit.
Fucking KKK guy fucking governor say we're
going to keep alive after the fucking
bored.
He's like,
they want to fucking take their organs.
It's incredible.
He's a KKK guy.
Fuck.
It's so incredible.
Then I did a picture with a guy,
the KKK outfit in blackface.
They elected him because he's black males.
They had that shit and
when he messed up and said,
we keep them alive to
get their fucking organs.
They used that to deactivate him.
Me.
Why do you think fraternities have you
screw sheep and all this and you know,
give guys blowjobs.
That's why I never joined that
fraternity.
Okay.
I'm so happy as I do this podcast.
So happy I turned down
this fucking amazing.
It's fucking amazing.
It was good.
We got to Paris,
new fucking world order.
Oh my God.
Eddie.
I got you.
Did you got so pissed off?
I'm so glad I fucked it too.
We got some dude.
How many jre clips they're gonna do?
They're gonna.
They're gonna put you to music.
Yeah.
Jesus pulled up MIT
saying they got an animal.
Human pig.
Yeah,
we did it.
Let's just not forget.
We did listen to it.
Go take a leak.
I'm with you.
Listen,
man.
He just kind of freaked me
out about several subjects.
No,
no,
no.
Bullshit.
Yeah.
He freaked me out about several subjects.
There's people out there
campaigning for the record.
That article says that
there was no written,
uh,
deep data on that.
It,
that came from three interviews they had.
So this is the human pig one.
People were saying that to them.
Of course they tried it.
Why wouldn't they try it?
If you were a,
if you were the leader of the free world,
like didn't,
wasn't there some,
God damn it was it the Nazis that were,
they were trying to theorize how to
combine humans with animals to make a
stronger human.
Wasn't there some of that
they were for sure into that.
Was there something like that?
If there's a youtube blink that's uh,
you know,
that's for sure,
right?
Like for sure.
They,
they,
they've,
they definitely,
I mean,
I think all governments definitely
give their soldier steroids.
They definitely give them an fet amines.
They give them,
definitely give them chemicals
to make them crazy shit.
I would,
are you kidding?
That's where they started doing
that and these fucking army,
the Nazis,
Nazis rather the,
uh,
the,
um,
kamikazes the kamikazes
do with meth them up.
That's it.
I mean,
I'm pretty sure that's true.
Read that 100% up on youtube.
Yeah.
That,
that was one of the ways they would get
them not just like nationalism and pride
for the country.
They would do,
they would jack them up on crystal
and that's why they'd fly that
plane right into that fucking boat.
They knew and boom.
I mean,
that is a nutty thing to do,
man.
You gotta be,
you gotta be in a weird state of mind
and you've got to have such a horrible
life that you're like,
fuck it.
Let me just crash into this fucking boat.
Right.
For the Gen,
they're like happy about,
they're like,
I can't wait to escape this shit.
What an insane choice.
It's the only PC has,
is when he's in that plane killing people.
What a fucking crazy choice that
you're going to do that for you,
Alex,
welcome back.
We're talking about kamikazes.
We're saying that we
think kamikaze is where,
uh,
there was,
they gave him crystal Meth,
right?
Wasn't that a part of the program?
Yeah,
no,
I mean,
warfare's always drugs and
[inaudible] the Japanese,
the Japanese learned about in World War
One when they're actually on our side
against Russia.
I went back and forth.
They it in World War One,
the Japanese learn about
MSG because you haven't,
he's like good food.
And they're like,
well the military wouldn't complain.
They would just lose
weight and starve to death.
So they learn they were fighting
the Russians in world war one to uh,
just go ahead and give them Msg,
which you have a,
she tells you your brand,
everything.
It's super toxic.
And so yeah,
monosodium glutamate,
like the stuff from Chinese food,
is that what you're saying?
Super fricking toxic.
Yeah.
But the business really.
But beyond that,
yes.
They would give them,
well the Germans were big on
steroids and methamphetamine.
It's were,
we were just saying that.
Yeah.
Well that's all record.
I mean it's not what this is
like in mainline history stuff.
By the way.
I said I'll give you
the secrets of Hitler.
Oh,
there's secrets.
Yup.
What other,
but this is not the BS.
This is the real thing.
Okay.
How do you know though,
who's telling you this stuff?
GTE classified at a
beyond classified Eddie.
No,
I mean Alex,
seriously d overthink.
Okay.
Cause you're father?
Grandfather was German in
Dallas and he worked for a,
the inventor of indoor air conditioning.
It was a billionaire.
And uh,
what's the rich area?
Dallas,
where the Republicans all live?
Uh,
God,
what's the name of that place?
Arlington.
No,
it's not hard.
Like tenants.
That's the thing right there
in the middle of Dallas.
That's awesome.
You think Dallas just like all buildings,
there's a huge park and
like all these big mansions.
Hmm.
Anyway,
he lived up there and
it wasn't just from him.
You know,
I,
I'm not going to get into it.
The point is is that Hitler was on the
cover of Time magazine and he was true.
Unless that's a photo shot.
You want it twice.
Well Trump was under the
cover of Time magazine too,
but exactly.
No,
really the problem is
give you guys the fake.
He made his own war.
Should I or should I just give it gestalt?
Like a boil down.
Here's the thing.
It wasn't just my grandfather
was his other people.
My grandfather said it was
really confusing for him
because he worked for this
guy that was in refrigeration and air
conditioning when he was in high school
and his dad owned the car
dealerships from Dallas and stuff.
They lived there,
the rich area.
Dallas.
And what did they tell you?
Well through one reason he wanted in the,
by the time World War Two started to
drop out of ut and you know all that and
getting to go join the army air corps.
She tells you to tell me all this stuff.
I'm going to go your,
your grandfather is a little eccentric.
And now like he,
my grandfather did Verner von Braun.
He came to Austin at events.
Yeah.
So anyways,
you grandpa knew Warner von Braun.
Well not just some of
those events and yeah,
he came to,
you know what,
at ut events we'll probably,
the next point is I'm getting too
well cause there were like German,
no wonder you believe in the moon landing.
I get it now.
Didn't make sense to say
let's let him finish.
His story was what they
called High German.
And so the high,
yeah,
that's what that is luber mentioned.
So they only would talk to
people that were in the club.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
so anyways,
uh,
my grandfather and the thing was like
an Uber mentioned and so you'll high Iq,
the whole nine yards show.
He was working with this German guy and
he would just go over there after school
and work with,
he was apprentice and my
grandfather watched him get
more and more depressed and
more and more crazy by the end of the,
of the 30s and the guy could find it.
And he said,
he said,
uh,
Clyde was my grandfather's name.
He said,
you had the Nazis had
my family in Germany,
they're going to kill them all about it.
I'm having to give them everything.
I got all my money and I'm having to
sell the patents and work like that was
working like 20 hours a day,
giving everything he had because
they were gonna kill his family.
And Nazi Germany,
he was German.
And so my grandfather wouldn't enlisted
in the Army Air Corps to fight Hitler
because he had that
experience and he was so mad.
And I was a kid who was like,
when I was a kid in Dallas,
WBAP had Hitler speeches on
because Germans are a big
part of the u s and there
was the boom,
everybody was supposed to join it and
Hitler was good and we never really bought
into it.
And then I found out that
this a mentor of mine,
uh,
and Ms. Guy be like,
Bill Gates today had everything he
had sucked out of him by the Nazis.
So that's what the Nazis would
do was extort and control.
So I kind of heard about that.
They're not gonna have a look.
Oh.
Cause they'd send me down there
like a week during the summer,
you know,
I was like eight years old.
I'm hearing this and he's like von
Braun as the plan for the orbital space
craft.
We've landed and we're going to
have real artificial gravity.
So Simpson Audit,
I'm hearing all this stuff.
He's not like markers,
the table like talking about it.
And I'm sitting there and listening
to this and he was talking about,
yeah,
then I was at least hound for Texaco and
the only place you get a chicken fried
steak out in New Mexico or west Texas was
a military base and all these God damn
Nazis.
And you know,
one time I didn't want to do it,
but that guy is smart it off about how
have they had more better at shooting our
planes down.
So I want to add,
just rammed his head right to the wall.
And I never knew what happened after that,
but sorry,
you just got to kill Nazis.
And those son of a bitch is our
government brought in thousands of those
assholes.
And I'm like,
listen to this.
I'm like,
I'm going to read about Nazis.
So it's how about 10 I started buying
books and I was like 12 to walk into a
bookstore and I want my cop.
They go,
are you a Nazi?
Like reading Hitler's my struggle?
No,
I'm not a Nazi.
My both my grandfathers told me
how bad Nazis and both almost
died fighting Nazis.
So I wanted to know about Nazis.
He was was this whole ethos and so that's
just the whole story of understanding
that and that my dad's angle and my
grandfather's angle and all these other
operation paperclip,
they didn't call it paper clip.
He said our government brought those.
He you think he would
always say what's yeah,
but that's the,
I think there was several waves.
There was like 34,000 of them.
Yeah.
There was a lot of fucking Nazi
scientists brought over like Youtube.
It says the operation paperclip was uh,
anywhere from like 1200 to 1500 searches.
The total number of admitted
congressional hearings
in the 1970s paperclip Frank Church
committee in the 70s released it and I
believe the number is 34,000,
207 look it up.
There's a,
like I told you,
they give people samples.
You pulled it up.
But it is fascinating.
They brought those people over
here and that's where the,
the space program came from.
Came from,
not tore the shirt,
not as a sick joke.
They already had the CIA.
That was LSS.
Okay.
The CIA's Oss.
That's all on record.
Okay.
I'm glad you questioned me now,
but I don't know what that means.
What is oss again?
Uh,
officers.
Special plans are off.
That was before the CIA and
the CIA clause of strategics,
so to like the office
of strategic services,
like what was before the seals would Jesse
Ventura was the frogs even terocin in
that he was an auxiliary of the navy.
He was never in combat.
Anyways,
let me expand on that.
The uh,
the o s s t,
the office of what is the
sheet on them refills.
The,
Oh,
ash ash was British intelligence
are the most powerful British,
the most powerful
intelligence agency ever.
They set up proud house at 22 after
World War II to anglicize the u s with
British intelligence,
not a British intelligence take over.
Our marriage was dissolved.
This just like on PBS.
Okay.
This just stuff that's true.
They've meant say they only
academics are watching it,
so it'll tell the truth.
The general pop culture is all crap meant
to be dumbed down and to turn you off.
But when you go to the real
academic stuff in the old days,
a frontline and stuff like I've
watched that to Novus true.
Literally have the documents,
it's all,
it's all real.
That's like,
those shows were like really accurate.
Like Bobby Kennedy plan to blow
up the embassy and under Richard.
So like,
God,
what was I getting to?
I don't Nazis Nazis.
Well one of them Ron and weird cliff.
Isn't it weird that the one man who
directed all six moon missions was a Nazi
and he was?
Isn't that one?
Isn't that crazy?
Smoke weed.
And one guy's having a problem.
His memory two guys did.
And why you want to defend worn,
not defending him.
It's fine.
35 Nazis and I've seen dogs
were some reason rant about it.
He sketched for Hitler,
this plan to drop atomic bombs
that they hadn't developed yet.
So when you see red skull marvel comic,
they've got a big bomber to love New York.
It wasn't a bomber,
it was a space plane and
it was about half the size,
but it looks just like this.
And the Germans actually of their
scientists went to the Russians
or the Russians tried to
build their space shuttle.
It was half the size.
That was actually the German plan show.
So you look it up.
I'm not kidding.
Because the Russians took
a lot of Germans as well.
Correct.
About a third of them.
Yeah.
So look,
the reason I'm wearing this is to explain,
this is a gateway to all of it.
So you have British intelligence
did a one world war one,
Germany had way more advanced technology.
They then take over British intelligence,
basically merges with the u s and
then the Germans and others say,
we've got to go way ahead in technology.
It was all theoretical and labs,
but they couldn't mass deploy it.
They didn't have enough machine
shops and systems to build it.
And US special forces went on suicide
missions and blew up the underground
mountains.
How about the Nazis were the
first to build flying saucer.
Oh it.
But let me tell you,
that's crazy.
Quinto British,
British intelligence flying saucers.
The CIA,
the CIA in 47
so now the Nazis are
over here and they go,
listen,
you don't want them running everything.
And they go to Eisenhower and they say,
we want to launch a off breakaway
civilization where you compartmentalize
things,
forget empires and you'd have a new
ruling class of technological elites and
then the elites are all in charge of
the public's watching TV and we'll give
them widgets and foundation
series type things at the verb.
This is all the documents and
let them try to run an empire.
We'll build a whole new empire.
And so Eisenhower gives a speech,
worry about,
he doesn't just say military
initial accomplished,
he says the technological elite
watch the full 21 minutes speech,
his farewell address and 62 he
says [inaudible] 60 61 he says,
you need to watch out about
the scientists because,
because he said no to the NASA
plan when he found out what it was.
But is it's a breakaway civilization
where you don't try to run the whole
planet,
you siphon off resources and
build a whole new advanced system,
and then you play or body off
against each other and collapse it.
So when I say,
what is an asset,
if we could take NASA back over,
it's bigger than the CIA.
It's the real government,
the spaceships and the
stuff that's all PR.
NASA is the real government.
NASA,
there were two breakaway
governments to shadow governments.
Brad talked about Saturday got,
but 20 years ago,
it's in the documents.
And so you had one that was British
run and the Germans came to the,
our own us elites and said,
hey,
you always need a couple of plants.
They said,
we've got all this on the drawing board,
the EU,
a plan to poison the food water
to get rid of the dumb people,
a plan for Offworld basis.
We've got,
by the way,
we're taking hardcore drugs and
we're in contact with aliens.
How has it given us technique?
It was the Germans first got in touch.
Well,
how'd they do it?
They were really a cult Briggs,
right?
Yeah.
Really ended the it all the Indiana,
which is the shit around him at all times.
You know,
human sacrifices as legal shit.
Yeah.
The society.
What I Alan you Joe,
this is not me.
You go to the real deep
phd level history books.
Okay.
NASA is the German breakaway government.
It's just always the Germans and
the Brits fighting for dominance.
So what you're saying is when operation
paper clip acquired all those Nazi
scientists,
they essentially started running NASA.
So Nasa became like almost like an
offshoot of the German government.
This offshoot government.
Yeah.
The Germans had piled all the wealth away.
They had everything.
So they made,
does that really make sense though?
That in 2019 that's still going on?
No,
no,
no.
The British intelligence,
does it run the CIA today?
The British empire was under attack and
just bankrupted itself and World War One
it said,
we'll give you the keys of the kingdom.
Churchill wrote three bucks.
Uh,
the history of the
English speaking peoples,
he was half American and
this is officially in books.
We merge with the British
empire and like 1930 covertly.
Okay.
That's what the CFR is,
is British intelligence
that US intelligence.
So the u s runs the show.
Okay,
so you've got,
you've got German intelligence
came to Eisenhower and said,
listen,
you don't need to do all this year.
We haven't given them a real technology.
We're in contact with aliens
and they've dealt with it.
The whole plan.
Where are you getting this from?
The stadium so confidently
it's in the literature man.
Hitler like would go literature,
mainline historical books
about as mainstream as castles,
where they go,
the aliens want bloods.
So they'd killed like 20 kids and
everything's aliens would like,
she'll come in and kill,
they taking the blood,
brings him in like sharks and then
they want to give them technology.
They go,
this is how it works.
She built the atomic weapons this way.
He built it and they would like show
him bombers and like the aliens are like
telepathic.
I don't even believe this.
This is what the Nazis bleed and the and
the aliens with MindMeld and give them
the technology.
They're bad aliens.
So they are you surprised the
Nazis were influenced by demons?
Know if demons are real,
definitely think they'd be
on the side of the Nazis.
But Joe,
what I'm telling you,
if the aliens will be no media,
no media is going to attack this.
I'm giving you want to
know where I can read it.
Where can I read that?
Those statements,
because they were in
contact with the aliens.
Obviously your pocket
real society,
the l group,
the chick aliens.
That's the only lens
right up there with them.
Like doing for three hours.
If acting fly here with
a report the day before,
I'll send it all to you
with mainline books.
I'll see.
I'll mail the books with the tabs in them.
Okay.
And I'll mail documents.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
I'll listen.
I think that they are absolutely
obsessed with the occult.
That's been pretty well documented.
They made flying saucers and I think,
yeah,
and I think government Zay developed
a more advanced form of nuclear fuel,
heavy water.
And we had to sit in special forces on
suicide missions back when was really
special for us to blow it up.
And,
and,
and I'm telling you,
the Germans had all
sorts of advanced shit.
They just couldn't ever keep the plants
from getting blown up because they were
a few behind.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and by the light.
Okay.
Uh,
Churchill wrote about this in his memoirs
and said the Germans were way ahead.
It wasn't the Germans were path,
if it's not super bad,
but it wasn't that,
it wasn't the Germans that first
bomb civilian targets in 1941,
the Brits were losing the war.
Hitler was bombing their for
their medical facilities,
military facilities,
and,
and so they went and bombed
German towns and German shit.
He's like,
uh,
I was a famous German city,
Dresden.
What was the designated
a safe city for kids.
Half a million people died in one night
to trick Hitler to turn his bombers on
the general population.
And they tricked him
psychologically to do it.
But,
but,
but Churchill,
this has been declassified.
It's,
it's,
it's an esoteric books.
It's admitted.
So Hitler was set up.
Well,
it was bad.
But here's what happened.
Albert Speer was his chief armaments
and architects administered at British
double agent.
Rudolf Hess was the deputy fuhrer.
The got Hitler.
Totally love you.
Never hear about him since 1941 because
they had a peace treaty with Edward the
eighth,
who was the king of England,
who was a Nazi and who was
German parish family German.
And they had a deal to stage the attack.
The French stood down
Vichy French didn't fight.
They put,
they put Nazi occupiers in the,
the,
the Dunkirk operation
was allowed to evacuate.
Edward the eight was supposed to then sue
for peace through Neville Chamberlain.
But it's come out that it was all
set up by Churchill and others.
Now that they ran Hitler.
Now they weren't bad.
They were pretty good,
but they master manipulated
him and never Chamberlain,
all of them and bet on the British
people in America to come in.
They had deals with,
uh,
with,
with the Roosevelt to then
bring us into the war.
And that was the whole master plan.
And you can actually go to
the history and see all that.
And that's what's so incredible.
Joe,
when you,
when you have all this info,
and so Rudolf Hess in 1941 or
42 he flies a one man bomber.
He was a world war one fighter
race like the number three,
eight a hundred and some aircraft.
Look it up Rudolph,
as he flies in,
parachutes into the castle.
The king was in at the time
in like northern England,
I forget the name of it.
He parachutes in with the peace
treaty shined by the King of England.
They lock him up in the tower for
the rest of his life in London
and ever.
The aide had to advocate type in Edward
d eight Hitler and you'll see him in
videos or films and photos.
He was in Spain when World War II started.
Where do you think the contact
with the aliens came from?
When did that start?
All right.
This is the most important thing.
We're not aliens landing.
Hold on.
Interdimensional dimensional aliens.
Alien means anything.
Not of this world.
What?
When was,
when did that happen?
Sketched that motherfucking fuck code.
No,
no big block.
Look,
it's fake.
I need to hear about aliens,
but I don't smoke marijuana.
Yeah,
this is just a cigar.
You know what's crazy about aliens?
Is it a youtube made a big announcement
that they're going to go after at nine
11 videos?
Anything.
I don't know if this is true.
I don't know.
But is it true that they're demonetizing
any videos that have truth or liberty
in them?
Is that true?
Yes,
that's true.
But I heard that.
Well that sounds crazy.
Hold on,
hold on,
let me finish.
Let me finish real quick.
It's crazy how they're going
after nine 11 miracle Cure.
They're blowing up alien videos.
It's wonderful.
He'll get the strongest
monetize videos out there.
I Dunno,
but none of it's true.
The stronger it is.
Well,
there's a lot of videos out there.
[inaudible] the best deals at the top,
top of the line spot.
I'll tell you when Eddie's right.
I actually know the numbers
that blowing up alien videos.
It was a little kid who makes $22
million a year reviewing toys.
No,
no.
That's like the number one.
Isn't he like one of the
number one guys on Youtube.
He's like eight.
I'm saying alien videos get
monetized by high level sponsors.
The high level one cause that's what I,
they're not,
they're not offensive.
People get drawn into them,
but they send me the
governments covering this up.
Why ain't they shutting that shit down?
Cause they're talking about
that the government is lying
and covering it because
it's funny,
but it's hysterical.
Right.
How did the connection with aliens start?
You said this is the most important
thing you'd discuss on the podcast and I
love you to death if you're awesome.
That's why I asked for you to be here.
If you want to believe in aliens,
I'm cool with that.
I still love you.
I don't care.
I don't care about that.
I said I'm,
this is not what I believe.
Okay.
I love you for who you ought to do.
I'm trying to tell you something.
Listen man,
let me tell you shot.
Let me tell you something.
Okay?
I'm not making this stuff up.
I believe you believe it.
No,
I mean there's stuff I told
you earlier about my dad.
At the table being offered half $1
million in 1980 Shirley that build cyborgs
and apparel.
No,
he wasn't here for that part.
Okay.
He came in later.
But tell me how the connection
with aliens cuts started
with who connection aliens and unnatural.
When people started becoming obsessed
with contact with the aliens,
he was saying in 1947 still
have some sort of a connection,
you know Eddie's right.
They flood youtube and mainstream media
like they always thought it was safe.
I thought about the private Federal
Reserve that the world order,
if I went on some big show,
as long as it makes
the aliens and with it.
And it was never the alien guy.
Right.
I've never been the big alien.
He never had a few years ago with you.
And you know what I that's right.
I remember when I was balls deep in
aliens cause I believed all that shit.
I believe it used to be that you'd be a
conspiracy theorist if you believe that
aliens but an hour anymore.
But now if you believe in aliens,
verticals,
Paris right now.
Okay,
but let,
let's tell me how the connection
between aliens and the Nazis took place.
When did all this start?
Let me,
let me begin
this.
Just really,
I'm telling you,
Joe,
this is a real deal.
I believe you.
This is you asked,
who are they?
It's people who are psychically,
genetically available to interface in
this incredibly diverse universe with all
these dimensions above and below and all
around us with consciousnesses and the
truth has no energies ever destroyed.
It all continues on.
The truth is our bodies.
This is a fact or a communal hive organism
of all of our ancestors and all of
their race memories,
but not in just some
compressed epigenetic system.
It's beyond that.
It's an electro chemical antenna.
They've proven this,
that connects to higher and lower
dimensions show our body shoot cause our
cause,
our our,
our,
our predecessors.
What Buddhists the position
without giving us a bodysuit.
That is them.
Our families are loving us.
They're holding us.
They're wrapped all around us.
Their strength or we'll,
they're bad.
They're good,
their sins,
the good things they did,
the battles,
they won,
the battles they lost.
The woman,
they love the the man they love.
It's all in us.
All these people.
It's while we're able to look into so
many things and have so many different
experiences and so all the Shaman,
all the ancient religions,
everybody says there are the good ones
and there are the bad ones and the,
and people are interfacing.
So you say,
where does it begin?
From the Tibetans to the Mezzo Americans,
to the Egyptians,
to the drew edge to every ancient
society describes the same thing.
There are bad things that looked like els
that have horns when they show you who
they really are and there are good things,
but they don't contact you unless
you contact them and then they,
they're almost not even
concerned with what you're doing.
I never bought into this look to do it,
but then I'm beginning to think
about what I hear when I was a kid.
What did I see?
What was coming on?
Government documents,
what was being admitted when I read all
these books about World War II and the
Nazis and Hitler obsessed with the Dalai
Lama and the Tibetans and what they
were able to do without drugs to interface
with this and all the rituals they
would do and how they were
believed that beyond the ether,
like at skull and bones,
it's a German death coat.
They do rituals and take drugs
to talk to the goddesses.
Well,
there's just appearing as you know,
sexy,
beautiful women.
It's whatever you want as the spirit
guides because lower entities will come in
and violate your free will,
God and his angels,
which are below him will not get
involved in your everyday life.
They will not manipulate your
freewill unless you asked them in.
But then the devil masquerades
as an angel of light.
So we're on this planet.
The third dimension,
which is a launchpad,
all the other dimensions below and above.
The third dimension all
about that it shows is,
is the primal she of where
all this happens in the earth,
like an egg and we've got all this
potentiality and God will send out a
transmission for a larger plan but is
willing to come in and what does it say?
Demoralize,
get rid of children,
don't have kids.
He owns her bad.
You will be will be better
once you're all gone.
And it's because it's their mission for
whatever reason that will understand
later what's going on.
So the Nazis,
if you get the deep literature,
they believed,
they were basically say on seeing and,
and,
and being possessed by entities that,
I mean it was before the
Nazis for whatever reason,
it was the Germans that this
happened to and the Swiss light,
they didn't discover Lsd
in the thirties these,
these people were running
the psychology departments.
They were interfacing with the occult.
They were involved in all this crazy
stuff and that was all about their power
and how great they were going to be.
The Germans were seduced and they were
seduced because they had high iqs.
But more than that,
they were psychically connected to
each other and would work like robots.
The this Chinese and the EU want robots
replaces cause they'll follow orders and
the Chinese are very conscious
when they're conscious.
They're also very robotic.
But the Germans are just as robotics.
So this entity system pick Germans
as its attempt even in World War One,
World War II.
And it was been to putting the bricks
as well and offering them technologies,
but two different paths.
One was social control and also
their stuff with the Brits.
The other was high tech weapons systems
interdimensional with the Germans.
And so whoever these players are,
and you can dial into it,
it's very dangerous.
They're manipulating the British
arm versus the German arm.
And then they've got the Chinese arm
that's almost seen as like their robot
army.
And,
and,
and so when you study it,
the globalist go to these events and they
take bigger and bigger doses of drugs.
They do electroshock.
Uh,
if you go back,
the owners of time,
life books didn't work just in the
twenties and thirties and LSD and other
hallucinogens and apothecary.
They weren't dealing electro shock.
They were,
they were,
they were having people turn their heart
off to like try to communicate with
these sayings,
to try to be dominant and get that.
So you go back thousands of years,
Merlin,
you know,
the archetypal or or,
or,
or these magicians or these,
these wizards are taking drugs in these
temples and interfacing with these
Palentier is these crystal balls,
which aren't really crystal balls.
It's their psychic focus
of an interdimensional
connection while they're on
drugs,
looking into glass to then be able to
see the future and understand what's
happening to give them temporal
power over this planet.
But like the Bible tells you any Pharma
key or any of that always leads to
destruction because only evil is
going to come through that way.
So we're basically have
these light sockets.
We can't Jack into the higher,
let's start freewill.
And that takes time.
We Jack in to the evil so
you can Jackie and to evil,
you can't Jack into good right away.
So it's quicker.
It's easier.
Like Yoda says about Darth Vader,
quicker,
easier,
more seductive.
And so then I'm going to be in a kid and,
and and my parents,
they don't really get mad about this.
It's whatever they even know what
they were hearing at the time.
But they had friends that they knew
at ut that we're involved in research
projects and then,
and then they were nine times out of 10
I wrote about research projects in San
Francisco.
Ut has some,
MIT has a lot and shop anytime you want,
but this was in like
the 60s they had virtual
reality gloves where you'd put them on
and put goggles on and you'd go into
stuff that looked like the
holodeck from star Trek.
20 years.
Word existed and they were doing
surgeries and all this and they would do
empathy loads where they'd say,
we need the public because we're so
weak because the west is so strong.
People haven't had trauma.
So they sold them low level.
Oh,
we're going to create trauma.
Like when you go to Mars,
you're not getting any gravity.
So your heart don't get,
when you get there.
Who was organizing all this?
Well,
they don't tell you.
They go,
oh,
it's a special class.
You've been.
Gotcha.
So in the 60s,
they had closed a special class of
people that are organizing all this shit.
It's Elias scores.
But is it for,
for,
for what purpose?
You don't know.
Financial gain.
Social Jack Parsons,
uh,
was the jet propulsion laboratory.
Alisha Crowley.
Devil worship.
Exactly.
So you're still the chat alley
over a hundred years ago,
the aliens get the point.
The founder of j p Arrow.
Jack Parsons.
Have you heard this before?
No.
I just can't believe I didn't
want to have Alex on the partner,
but did not let me finish this.
Let me say this.
I'm trying to take over,
but I'm not bullshitting you.
Okay?
I'm telling you this stuff.
I don't believe in this.
Okay.
There it is right there.
This is patented in 1957 SVR machine.
Exactly.
No,
exactly.
Show.
I've talked to people,
not just family.
Holy Shit.
Keeps you wind,
vibration,
aromas,
stereo,
sound,
power,
motion,
wide vision and three d three dimensional.
But let me tell you,
they wore a mask in the
sixties and seventies that
was already like you see like
paper,
thin TV screens and it was all ready.
I talk at all.
They said there's no way
this was human technology.
So you've seen these foldable phones?
Yeah.
I think the aliens have already
taken over Samsung and Huawei.
Yeah.
Cornish.
Do you think the aliens
are taking over Samsung?
Do you have any something,
something to do with Samsung
will obviously that's what
I'm telling you is the,
the Pentagon isn't worried
about as long as Jamie,
this is the patent.
Wow.
I notice that's the week
of the sixties I believe.
1957 notice.
That's exactly what you're buying.
That's what my dad told me.
That's what our HTC Vive looks like today.
She'll just eat y'all.
This is big.
My Dad didn't tell me this
chill.
He saw you in game and he said,
no son.
We had virtual reality goggles and we
had shitty rom and we had things and then
something else happened.
And I,
I'm not at liberty to get into it,
but I was shown three years ago what
the University of Washington was doing
under Bill Gates and this was
in the 90s what were they doing?
What do you do?
They,
they don't even know
what they're being given.
It's intervening ish.
So you think it's some sort of
alien intervention type shit,
dude,
they,
they to get even deeper.
They turn your heart off for five minutes
and they pump oxygen into your blog
and you're in the meetings.
I've talked to people that are involved,
I mean top scientist and you're in
the meetings with fricken aliens.
Elvis is the main group,
but they're like,
by shutting your heart off,
it makes you have that
psychedelic experience by
keeping blood in your oxygen.
It's keeps you alive.
But we'll,
we'll,
let's explain.
Okay.
The heart goes out.
The body thinks it's dead.
Right?
So you can stay in longer.
I don't know all the science behind it.
I understand.
But let's explain this lung at
eight and DMT or Iowasca 200 times.
My mom,
like most of our astronauts to
test pilots are flying planes.
Those are robots count.
It's all mind war shall
these dudes are like,
it stops working once you've
taken in hundreds of times.
So then they start taking their most
psychic people who are able to do this and
they turned her heart off and
then they put them into these,
these events and it's like the
things the aliens tell them,
they come out and they tell scientists
and it works show like we're going to
shit.
They didn't tell you get
killed for this stuff,
Joe.
This is not the only thing
they want me off the air.
Because when I finally figured this out,
cause I never touch aliens,
I kind of knew the whole thing already.
Here's what I'm talking about.
When I was a kid,
wait nine,
whenever it was this one,
this lady would come over that had known
my parents since ut and it was involved
and she talked about,
yeah,
we call it the psychedelic research
should or whatever the name was,
but it's really a CIA deal and you know,
we just can't find people
that can handle it.
They're going in the hills want this.
And he yells,
want us to basically reduce population
and agree to these certain plans.
And it's all the humanization.
And they call him the L's.
It's clockwork hills.
And they're like,
yeah,
this is,
my parents were like seven,
eight years old.
Like they don't think you're listening,
talking about,
well this is what the elves want
and this is what they're gonna do.
And the thing is,
he's not a parent's aren't
that special either.
A to San Francisco
that it's all there is dude.
It's a cult man.
You all these guys,
you know from San Francisco,
dude,
you look at,
look at the head of Google
or youtube or fricking apple.
He's on TV.
Tim Cook and his eyes are
this big under lights.
Man,
these guys are on stuff
that like nobody even knows.
What do you think they're on?
Stuff they've been given.
I mean,
I know people at ut,
they won't tell me specifically,
but I will tell you to
do two owns youtube.
Who's that guy?
What's his name again?
It's a girl.
You sexist pig.
It's alphabet.
Alphabet is the parent company.
This is their take.
Take.
Take the child already,
dude.
There's not like a Jack Dorsey of youtube.
Take,
take,
take.
Sundar.
Pichai.
Sorry.
He goes in Congress.
I'm there.
He's the CEO of Youtube.
He's a CEO of Google.
Google,
sorry.
And he's literally on TV going,
we never fixed the result.
We don't spout anybody.
There is no surveillance and you've got
all these old white men and I want to
say it,
I'm white men to be trendy.
It's all a bunch of old dumb ass white
man and a couple of dumb ass old Mexican
and black ladies.
They're all dumb and I will call.
They are going show you
don't spout it or control it.
Meanwhile,
their own perspectives to their
shareholders is how they control it all.
Now they're going to
deliver maximum profit.
And
Sundar is like,
yes,
it is true.
We have never controlled the
search result and it's just,
I'm just listening to pure lies.
Meanwhile,
this guy's only the front guy of Eric
Schmidt and God knows what they're into.
They're,
I mean,
it hasn't been proven that
Google does something to,
to alter search results.
Uh,
I'm asking cause I don't know,
not asking to fuck with you.
Uh,
what did they do?
Who will itself is about if you pay them,
they put your results at the top.
Just like Facebook.
Okay,
well that's definitely
altering search results.
So what he said was not true.
If they,
if you can pay,
it's like sand water,
a wet Joe.
I know you know all this stuff.
No,
no,
no.
I don't know that.
Now listen,
I'm honest about what I don't know.
I know some things,
but I,
there's a lot of fucking
holes in my knowledge base.
That's a fact.
Well,
you know that they try to block my name
and directed toward negative stuff.
I'm sure they do manipulate.
All they do is all they
do is the negative.
You attack me.
It's like it's digital currency.
You go to the top and they pay you money.
Some of your body,
a little tip watching a cap me lie about
and you go to the top but you lose your
soul,
your soul,
but I don't want to burn this out.
There's important stuff to cover.
Alien I think as well.
This is a good podcast.
Fuck.
Let's don't end.
This jogs autonomous.
My vomit,
Martin,
miss my flight.
Look at this right here.
What is the end game?
I mean,
here's the example.
Earlier we already talked
about human animal hybrids,
mass farming of humanoid tissue
transhuman in game and we,
and we talked about aliens and you
looked it up and it's all right there.
That's for the aliens creating animal
hammered isn't alien like grades and stuff
like that.
Do you think grades are
like a like a robot?
Yeah,
I think I've heard that
theory that it's not a real,
there's no pro.
The idea is that a certain point in time
you can interface with that robot so
that you could see it in
realtime through its eyes,
grows a read.
I don't know.
This is what I'm saying.
If if one day in biological androids,
hold on a second,
if one day in the future they figured
out a way to take a thing that looks like
a humanoid avatars.
Yeah,
and and transport it through a spaceship
onto another planet and you could look
through its eyes because you're
somehow or another connected to it.
The same way they're
connected to the lights.
No,
no.
You're all being prepared clothes where
your bow hunting and you're all that.
You just saw the 1950s
diagram of the VR goggles.
Can we pull that famous photo of
you don't believe in any aliens,
Eddie.
I don't believe they come from up there.
Hold up your inner dimensional.
I think there
we're in this vast plain was a point
where they got us in closed in this little
thing or deal.
Eddie,
you learn.
Here's the thing.
You learn what the plan is by the attack.
They don't want us having kids.
They want us to moralized.
They want to break us down and they don't
want us to think maybe they expand and
they don't want us to
believe that their space,
and I'm not trying to attack you,
but they don't want third
dimensional resource expansion.
I don't even know what that is.
Well,
they don't want us
third dimensional resource expenditure.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
Well,
I don't know if I wanted this guy or not.
That's a 1950s diagram.
No,
I never saw that.
I'm glad he found the pattern.
Yeah,
Dad told me,
oh,
we had virtual reality and then I talked
to the scientist and he put me in touch
with somebody else and then
I found out other stuff.
Let's just say this.
I'm not in the CIA.
Me Neither.
I'm not in the NSA.
But they've been tracking
me my whole life.
You think they give you
disinformation sometimes?
You're absolutely,
for sure.
It was the CIA.
It was the former deputy director.
Basically the CIA section,
chief founder of Delta Force who got
me to like a two weeks ago is Alex,
you're not saying sandy hook stage.
You need to go say sandy silk stage.
He goes,
oh,
we have the people were there and just
because he was famous MIT scientists and
stuff,
I went with that.
So do you think they
already had computers?
Probably.
I'm speculating,
looking way out to set me.
I mean,
I dunno.
I'm sure there's people
setting everybody up.
If you think I told you about this,
I don't know if it told you about,
I've told people that
have listened as podcast,
but this woman Renee to Resta and she
had a podcast with Sam Harris where they
went into detail about the operation
that people would use to troll Facebook
pages and Instagram
pages and create these,
the where the Russians had created these
troll bots and these meme pages where
the hundreds of thousands of
Polaroids are all doing it.
Everyone's doing it.
Everyone's doing just Russians are.
Everyone's doing.
But the thing that was fascinating was
she was saying that they organized a
Muslim event across the
street from a pro Texas event.
Yeah,
I want,
they want explosion.
They would have black lives
matter next to blue lives matter.
They'd set everybody up with every
bit as a blue lives matter is a lot.
What is Dan Morrison at film
school here in California,
trained on by the CIA.
What was he trained?
He was trained on,
can I,
can I hear this when I get [inaudible]
has said this before and I've said that's
donating the podcasts.
I gotta pee.
I gotta be,
I'm not going to have to
work you gotta pee again.
Bless.
[inaudible] go first.
Let me go for it.
All we got as a Cleveland browns will
go off about fucking Baker Mayfield for
like 10 minutes.
Let me just say this job,
they got that new guy
for Kansas City stand.
The only way they get what I'm actually
saying is infowars.com and there's
worse.com you have to,
I mean,
we had 26 million subscribers
between my three shows on iTunes.
All they were doing was like into my feet.
They do listed that and it
killed us and I was always like,
Oh God,
I hope that care about being
deleted off of youtube or Facebook.
God,
don't figure out the iTunes.
Don't,
don't do it.
That was like devastating cause people
are like habitualized listen to you.
They don't anymore,
but I want to be 100% clear.
You have to go to infowars.com you have
to go to news wars.com if you want to.
Actually what I have to say,
in fact,
I'm not telling you guys what to play Joe,
I'm not mad at you,
but he heard me say that
Jimmy Chevelle would
go have sex with dead kids and also
cut out their pituitaries that has
adrenochrome in it and eat it.
And I know that sounds completely insane.
He was a famous child molester.
It's admitted.
And so Joe's like,
oh that's crap.
That's crazy.
Alice has gone schizophrenia.
Well yeah,
I probably gone crazy looking
at all this and actually caring.
Most people don't
because they'll go crazy,
but the adrenochrome thing is real.
So if you go to,
what's the exact name of the video?
This is a three minute video that
I really think people should see.
It doesn't defame anybody.
It doesn't name names,
it doesn't do any of that stuff.
But if you go to infowars.com
and Trina Chromo,
she wrote her,
what's a junior chrome?
Oh man,
dude.
It's just,
you've heard about all these
rich startup companies that like,
well,
the parents agree.
The kid has a right to live that live
with 10 year olds and below his blood.
What?
We're rich people taking kids blood,
right?
Yeah.
It seems like a team.
Blood is a works well for
people in their elderly years.
Is this true?
Absolutely.
No,
it's,
it's all true and that's what I'm saying.
It's a fan prism.
It doesn't mean vampires are real.
It means that attitude.
I don't know if we can find this a
three minute video on my reporters did
adrenochrome Oh yeah,
you sent it to me,
right?
Can you tell them the
name is on your phone?
You got it.
Okay.
This is,
it's only three minutes
and it will name anything.
I'm telling you.
This was real.
Play it.
Here's the thing.
That one stop stop right here.
Youtube just released a bunch of
total new guidelines where if you play
anybody's content,
you get a strike against you.
You're pulled for 90 days,
you can't stream,
you can't do shit.
Yeah.
Now they're saying you can't
have comments that are bad.
Yes.
Guilty for what your neighbor does.
Well,
not just the making of the youtube.
They're not gonna do that to you.
Well,
I dunno who the fuck's gonna do
it to who but after this podcast,
I think all bets.
No,
but I'm saying this is our own content.
It's totally fair use.
It's not true that youtube is really
demonetizing any videos that have truth.
And here's what I liberty is that not
everybody gets paid on Twitter and
Facebook.
We all advertise on our businesses and
our radio shows and our TV shows this big
diversified media worldwide said,
hey,
here's where you can get our material.
It's a great system.
So for 10 years we built it up so
that the web was 90% decentralized.
Now it's 90% centralized,
and so once the big tech
goddess all centralized,
they went,
oh yeah,
just like when you're cashless,
we'll take her bank account away.
If you don't support us,
boom,
you're all gone.
So now we have to fight back against that.
There's something to that.
You know,
there,
there's something to this idea that
one giant corporation can decide,
especially based on their own personal
ideology,
what gets put on and what
doesn't get put on because Joe,
they're control freaks
flagger in the fight now.
Thank you.
Is there like
what does that mean?
Japanese is I,
Hey,
listen,
it's my video chart.
It's totally legal.
It just talks about Google
searches for a drain of chrome.
No,
I authorize you to air my video.
Okay.
The only issue I had to
just right at the beginning,
I see it has a part of a fear and
loathing in Las Vegas town to get us the,
let's tell people the link so
they can go to it themselves.
Show it.
This is essentially about people
that are putting old people.
Is it people are putting young people's
blood into old people's bodies?
Is that what it is that you were
and I know what your question is.
You're not a psychotic Damon.
Damon Parson.
Thanks you [inaudible] Bro.
Leave that.
Alex says that some babies she broadcaster
would go have sex with dead kid's
bodies at the morgue and need to branch.
That's someone that said what?
I said,
I didn't believe Bill
Maher was a pedophile.
That's all I said.
I said that his thing,
his name,
I don't think Spotify,
which everybody I know
says he likes women,
which is fine.
I think he likes women.
You know what we're
talking about him earlier,
and I can say this from the
perspective of a standup comedian.
We say a lot of shit that we don't
entirely mean because we think it's funny.
Eddie and I do it all the time.
That's why Eddie said that to you earlier.
You really think that
someone's going to hurt.
They're going to legislate
to harvest babies.
He's,
he's doing that to fuck with,
you know,
Robert 100 for his style of comedy.
But like Eddie's been doing that
style comedy since I met him.
Like he loves to do that.
He loves to pretend and fuck with you
and they get you upset and he's like,
[inaudible] show your nursing that drank.
Let's slam.
Okay,
so look my friend.
Hey,
can I have one of them
whiskeys over there?
Yeah,
we got another beverage.
Oh,
Bravo is about to turn loose.
Nah,
just a little.
Hey,
I get you're busy.
But last time you had a comedy show where
you get to stay safe for this or no?
Yeah,
let's do it.
Let's do it.
You want um,
a CVN it,
no.
Could you imagine if we
announced we're going to get sex?
No,
we can't tell.
That's a Joe.
Hey Joe,
let me get real serious all the
time and everything and everything.
I appreciate you listening.
I appreciate you.
So real quick,
glad.
I'm really glad we did this topic.
I just want to say this one to be clear.
Um,
I have literally been trying
to find out what's going on.
And as you get older you
figure out more stuff.
I am not the one shank.
There's all these aliens,
the entire government and
all of these advanced groups.
That's why they've given up on space
is they're all about inner dimensional.
So I didn't finish up about,
I don't want to get any check then I'll
get into in your tank is that I've got a
pretty good understanding by
interviewing a bunch of people involved
about what the master plan is and exactly
who we're dealing with because there's
not just one group of aliens.
What's the different groups and
what are you basing this on?
Like what,
when you say it,
you're saying like really
like you're really sure.
What do you base this on?
You know about general struggle buying,
right?
No,
don't.
Okay.
Well he was a major general,
was that a three star general and he
was the head of all class clandestined
operations for the US
government for like 15 years.
And he said on my show before
he died at like 98 or whatever.
But also in private discussions,
and this is like six,
seven years ago,
and I was everything like 15 years ago.
I mean,
this is the guy that ran the whole show.
You know men who stare at goats.
Yes.
That's a joke about that.
It kind of whitewash whitewashes at all,
but they broke through and got
contact and they had volunteers,
really serious people who,
who,
who were taking huge
doses of drugs do this.
Then I'll,
or NASA was doing it and that's why
they got to the point of saying,
well,
why should we try to go to other places?
The third dimension,
it's just as empty wasteland above it
and below it is all this incredibly
complex stuff,
but our brains tune all of it
out because we can't handle it.
Okay.
That's why I like young people before
they hit puberty are known to be psychic
because for whatever reason they're
able to see through the veil and all
religions are based
about scenes of the veil.
Well,
that's what intense
meditation does for you,
right?
The holotropic breathing,
a lot of it couldn't Delini stuff.
What they're doing is a allowing your
brain to relax its boundaries and
interface with all the other dimensions
that are around us all the time.
Exactly.
But usually can only get
through psychedelic drugs,
but dark forces,
dark form generally are
the ones that are willing,
good forces are not willing
to get involved in freewill.
Um,
so you think that they are actual
entities that are in these dimensions that
you're in contact.
Okay.
There are,
have you exposed to
any of this personally?
Might get to that a minute.
There are,
there are hundreds and they're discovering
new ones all the time of parasites,
bacteria,
worms that control life
forms of everybody want.
Yes.
You ever seen the Zombie ants?
Or A,
this is Zombie Wasp.
What does Ami was the boss.
Yeah.
They,
yeah,
there's so many of them.
They keep finding it was
particularly in the insect world,
which is really interesting.
So the lowest level is able to infect
you with something that controls your
brain down to exact activities.
Yeah.
Exact activities.
Have you personally had any experience
with interdimensional beings?
Well because it's all taboo and people,
let me tell you,
I have my hundred
percent tell us about it.
Doing DMT.
I've 100% communicated with something.
The question is whether that's something
was actually in my imagination or in my
mind or that something was something
that takes place in another dimension.
I don't know.
I can't be sure.
There's no way to put it on a scale.
There's no way that you
run it through a task,
but what I do know is that
it's the same experience.
I can be sure.
Okay.
I mentioned Eric Muller who,
you know,
I'm Mahler because he's the one
guy willing to let me tell a story.
I've literally talked to,
I see a hundred people.
It's probably more than that because
I've known about this for a long time.
He is a Christian,
but he heard about all this,
so he went down to a couple places in
central and South America and did it
twice.
Both Times.
It was 30 to 40 people in
the group and he's like,
well,
Alex,
I just don't believe in demons.
But I did see basically aliens coming to
the edge of the forest and we were all
sharing it and come on and
we're all seeing the same thing.
But I think it was a chemical reaction.
You don't have,
if you,
everybody gets drunk.
We all think about what happened to us
in high school or college or what's good
or what's bad.
We all have different experiences.
When you're taking on a hallucinogen
and suddenly you're all seeing the same
thing,
it just means it clicked off.
The part of your brain is a filter.
It's you go crazy because
a lot of schizophrenia is,
people just see more and
then they see everything.
It doesn't mean they're right.
It just means that the filter is off.
Well,
I,
he said he'll give her,
run your hand over an
insect that can't see.
They have no idea you're there.
They like certain insects.
They just don't see anything.
Whether it's a Senate,
Pete or whatever.
And how do,
how do we know what they see?
We don't know.
You're right.
We we by dissecting dead ones,
we have an understanding of what sensors
they possess and we can we think a B,
a,
B or a fly sees like in a
bunch of little like a hexagon
on different,
yeah.
We don't know what the
exact experience was.
I,
I told you the whole story got
computers hooked up to the damn bugs.
They've got everything
hooked up to the bugs.
The differences,
let me tell you.
Yeah,
they've got roped up 35 years ago.
They had remote control
ratchet with microchips.
They could send 500 yards bombed out
building with a camera on their top.
They 30 years get to dolphins too,
right?
Yes.
Trapped.
They've gotten this
whole choose oftens head,
main line,
scientific American roaches with a
chip on their head that run around.
The difference is the where the reason
it's dangerous is that once you open that
gate,
it's all bad.
They asked it all bad.
Why?
Why can't you experience
that interdimensional being
in learn something from it
and be a better person
because for whatever reason,
at first it's all beautiful
and show you're an Aztec base.
Catnapping all the local tribes and and
killing whoever's the tallest or the
smartest.
Every time it gets control,
it starts murdering everybody
and it always starts beautiful.
It always starts crying.
So you're talking about
ancient civilizations where
the ritualized psychedelic
drugs and they wind up killing
everybody on every case and every case,
the priest,
Shay,
we have to pro babies should the fires.
We have to cut their hearts out.
Hmm.
We have to buy congenital.
True or false.
Supposedly the mushrooms were used by
the Aztecs so that they wouldn't resist.
They'd get them all high on mushrooms.
It was beyond that.
We had a cocktail at a cocktail.
They don't resist.
Dozens of illusive is intox was
they would give him an enema.
True or false though.
They didn't use mushrooms just to
keep him sedated and they ground us.
It makes sense.
If you get it,
they killed the pull this up.
I think the temple,
I,
I forget how you said t to Ucon Teal Con,
but in this one temple,
I think they killed some insane amount
of people after it was constructed as
after the construction's
tens of thousands.
They sacrifice tens of
thousands of people that,
the ones that we're actually
working to build the temple.
Once they realize that
killed everybody in real,
real university hedge who I pay,
I want to hear from them.
These are the Mayans.
And they said,
yeah,
no,
we're opening here.
Dimensional gate.
The gods want blood and they didn't
take it internally through the mouth.
They would take,
enemas have dozens of hallucinogens and
alcohol and show the priests will take a
couple of drugs and then the preach
wanted to communicate with the aliens and
the aliens wanted blood and they also
show it was more like we're chopping
hearts out.
Yes sir.
Okay.
We did a thousand.
The gates open,
they tell from here it goes,
Jamie says,
it says they between,
wow,
between 10,040,
80,400 persons.
We're sacrificing the ceremony
in 1487 when the Aztecs,
uh,
completed the temple.
And how do you say the
temple named pull up the,
the,
the top of,
or is it,
how do you say I'm rich.
Good.
It's uh,
it's all over.
How did he say the temple name?
Oh,
didn't say that's matching your city.
Tila con,
I think I'm saying that shit go shit
each where they think they killed about 5
billion people flushing.
This is one day fucking insane.
They killed 80,000 people
and a couple of days.
That's banana that's come out of the way.
You go down there and you're walking
around in the woods and the Mayan God goes
the bones and they pick
up and you're like,
it's not graveled.
It's petrified.
Bones are everywhere.
Oh my God.
Let me go further.
The priesthood were meet sellers.
This happened in Europe as well.
They would hang people
up and the the stores,
the market is below the temples and
show you would eat the meat and the most
valuable meet was warriors.
Like when you won the ball throwing
game that went on for days,
they would kill you.
They killed you.
The ones who won were murdered.
This is the thing they used to think
that they sacrificed the losing team.
Now they realize the sacrifice.
The winning team.
I had a bit about for
awhile where I was like,
that must have been the
longest fucking game ever.
Dropping the ball fucking up.
They were all fighting
because they wanted to fund.
They believe they were.
Yeah.
They wanted to shed quick Kotler
postal in the flying serpent.
Quinto Quarto Quisha quality.
Yeah.
It's going to,
you're going to interface and upload
the itch brain and you look at their
paintings.
It's all like spaceships and dials and
they have perfect in the Spanish museum
for 200 years previous on
a hoax because there's,
there's,
there's drawings haven't
a 200 year old Spanish,
uh,
textbooks.
But you know,
she had a a,
it's about like a half foot long.
It's a,
it looks like a jumbo jet with
the windows and the engines.
True or false?
The Mayans smoked penis blood.
They did.
What they did was I,
that shit,
you're just being silly.
That's true.
Selves that they took.
They took long lines of leather Shag wore
leather and it had it had it had nails
on it and an and or had like spiky things
that glass and they would put it in
their genitals.
Oh,
the most skill.
He's a priest.
The high priest,
when we're sacrificing people for
hours taking hallucinogens would,
would like not try to
cut his testicles off,
but all of the most skilled would sit
there and draw them through there and they
would smoke the blood,
the lower proxy to their ancestors.
The lower the lower priest would
then pull it up to their answers.
They would put it on sacred leaves and
then they would smoke the genital blood
of the high priest and they
would talk to the ancestors.
I believe it's just people are so goofy.
Look,
if you see those African ladies
with a giant plates in their lips,
if you believed that he the next,
the next,
yeah.
How about that?
This tries to her next out to the point
where if they take those things off,
your head will fall off.
People are willing to do all kinds
of crazy things to their body.
I am not surprised they
they'd smoke Joe blood.
The Bible says the Old
Testament New Testament,
which is pretty powerful.
I know people misinterpret itself,
but it's ancient text.
The people that are there like,
like you read the,
Oh like three burning wheels land.
There's a blue from and overjet.
It gives me something to take.
I take it,
I'll give him the full
data of the plan that that,
that,
that the genetics has been infested in.
God must destroy everyone.
That's an alien story.
Oh,
it's 100% but that's what
they always talk about.
There was talking about
that being an alien story.
That's why one of the primary stories
when they talk about the Bible,
Ezekiel's vision,
a wheel within a wheel that they
always thought of your rate it,
it says floating off the ground and
the Hebrew and the King James is pretty
clear to floating comes a thing
with a crystal from it over his head
and then the face of
shifting different creatures.
It's like a video screen.
Well,
if you think about how long it
would take for an alien to get here,
it really only makes sense that unless
they have a constant basis and a robot
they visit,
or if they,
if they came by themselves,
they came by themselves
a long fucking time ago.
Like if they were able to make
interstellar travel like two,
3000 years ago,
which is not that big of a leap.
If you think about us 3000 years from now,
we probably can do something like that,
right?
So if they were doing that 3000 years
ago and they found human beings,
and these are the stories that we have,
these stories like a Zeke,
you'll and like,
uh,
there's a bunch of different ancient
stories about contact with the skies.
You know,
the,
uh,
the only changing to tabulation.
Yeah,
there's a world government.
The beach is 50 feet tall.
It shifts.
Everyone can see at the same time,
it's a hologram.
And you've got these digital systems.
If you don't go along with,
you can't buy her shell.
People say,
oh,
that's not real,
but it's manifesting.
And then go 2000 years in the future.
They have advanced technology.
They don't send people anymore.
Now they send aliens.
If you go back to the old days,
it was actually some sort of humanoid
or a large thing like all the Zachariae
Cichon Shit.
The covers Sumerian texts.
Exactly what I'm,
I make sense.
That's what all those
guys are telling you.
Like Avatar,
James Camera's definitely dialed in.
It's like,
no,
we're there jack.
They're jacking him.
Well,
it makes sense that if there was a visitor
to this planet five 10 15,000 years
ago,
if there was maybe more,
maybe if there was a visitor hundreds
of thousands of years ago that actually
did genetic experiments on lower hominids.
If that was really the case,
it makes sense that
their technology would,
it increased far more rapid,
but let's go pass that.
Obviously scientists like to plant things.
Gardeners like to plant things and,
but that's Joe.
That's exactly what the global us believe
is that maybe they're just aware of
what the fuck's going on.
There was powerless as we are,
if they're really are more and more,
they only put soldiers,
people in charge who
are compartmentalized.
Nobody else knows who
will carry the shell,
but we're able,
because we're advanced,
look at this because let,
let's just get down to brass tax tax.
I love tax.
Let no,
Joe,
you just said it instead of
some weird dumb preacher,
you know in,
in Alabama.
I'm bashing Alabama sang stuff.
You get mad at this.
Don't look at watch.
So demonized.
Look at why it's demonized.
Think about that,
right?
Think about how it says,
okay,
that there's no reality and god
creates a whole new virtual reality,
gives light,
does all of it,
and then his genetic experiment
by rogue elements gets involved.
It's all right there.
When you actually look at it and
you expand on it and you're like,
oh my God,
this is like beyond a
science fiction book,
and so it's the obvious thing.
That's why they keep telling us,
oh look,
Piltdown man,
all this fake stuff.
No,
Joe,
they did an accelerated immunogenic.
They're doing it too much now.
Something new.
They did an accelerated immunogenic
program on this planet and humanity.
What,
what does the Bible start with?
Pick Shas.
We are made in the image of God.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
We don't have God's knowledge
would have God's advancement.
We're the image.
Well,
what does an image,
it's a scan.
It's numbers.
It's the genetics.
It's the potential.
So we are the aliens.
Joe and everybody already knows this.
We are the aliens.
Do you think that we are a
product of alien intervention?
They took these lower hominids and they
accelerated their evolution by applying
their genetics.
Do you know,
here's the deal.
They say we're 97% chimpanzee,
but then they actually get
into the deeper genetics.
We're closer to pigs are Rach show.
I think that this was an
environment built for us.
We're the master genetic program
and they are all subsets of us.
Just for a backstory.
Uh,
and that's what the global his thing.
Yeah.
But do you think that
the aliens created us?
Like this is like one of the primary,
here's what the elite beliefs.
Right,
okay.
The elder,
biological,
Android's the grayish.
Yeah.
And then there's other systems going
on and no one knows because it's all
warfare,
psychological stuff.
No one knows the true cause.
It's,
it's virtual reality once
you get to that level.
So no one knows.
We just don't,
we're advanced.
But we are,
and I'm not just answering a rifle.
Powerful.
The globalist are obsessed.
The elites are obsessed
because she reportedly,
obviously humans are pretty fricking cool.
We've got some big giant mission
and maybe that's a program,
I don't know that we're
like pretty super advanced,
but you can't put something out like
the Spartans were when their kids were
seven,
they throw them out for
two years in the woods.
You can't just put something out like,
like,
like liberals.
You give her very everything.
They're a little assholes.
So this is like bootcamp
and training and they,
and so they had the
testis and do all this.
And basically this planet
is what the people say.
It's a big testing ground for other
things that are going to come.
And we are it.
We are God.
And I don't mean I'm God,
I'm already God.
I've achieved godhood.
Cause you could see that
potential in yourself and and the,
and the,
and the lower level ELLs will tell you
that because they already know you're bad
ass,
but if they can trick a tadpole,
it's going to grow into
Godzilla to go kill itself.
They're winning.
So you say,
so the animals are on a test,
the ELLs or a test on us to attack us
and and and see the survival of the
fittest,
but they're nothing.
They're like w by,
by the time we've achieved
conscious and we look back and go,
we're not going to look at it that
because I think when you jump to the next
level,
there's even a bigger war going on.
What's the biggest war?
Consciousness in the universe is
an interdimensional spacecraft.
Beyond that then looks like a
comment from my research and it has,
it has its head,
it has its corona.
That's consciousness consciousness.
He carries evil in the tail end.
The consciousness has a location.
No,
there is this giant consciousness.
God,
okay.
Swimming in a giant system of survival
of the fittest that God has created a
test God self.
Okay.
It looks like a comment,
so you got God's consciousness
and all the good things,
the knowledge going forward,
but God knows that everybody has to be
tested so the tail goes out and at the
end of the tail is basically evil.
That's why Christ says
get behind me Satan,
and it's always trying to test God
and infiltrate up into it to sabotage.
Damn.
If they do pull the plug on this podcast
is a good way to end this motherfucker.
I have your burnout.
One is fit.
Oh,
it's not.
I'm just saying it 1,300 and something.
If the fucking governments come in,
but shell,
they love [inaudible].
You guys have been talking
about aliens so much,
dude.
Trust me.
This is one of the biggest youtube videos
of all is that the move to talk about
aliens as much as possible.
They allow to shut up,
let me call over children's program,
bs alien stuff or were
they come out of space?
It's interdimensional Eddie.
Well,
when you say alien to tell you
that you're talking to the alley,
the gradient,
that's what it sounds like.
Delete.
Literally believe they're in
contact with these things.
Well maybe they are helping to describe
what you saw DMT and you tell us you
have these experiences,
thoughts become patterns.
They become like geometric patterns
that are moving through space and they
change and shift,
but they're letting you know
that they know all your bullshit.
They see right through you and they want,
they want you to relax.
Yes,
there is a lot of that.
There's a lot of thought as creation.
Yes,
but with the only,
oh relax.
Just he don't struggle.
No one would call them aliens though.
What I saw,
I never referred to him as a leader.
That's the term everyone knows,
but not of this world.
None of our average thing.
I would listen,
I would think it was aliens.
If it woke me up in the middle
of the night and took me a board,
a ship,
and that's what I experienced.
I would be 100% convinced that I went
to an alien spaceship and I talked to
these things,
the differences,
how it was like to to smoke it and
then laid back and then experience.
That is like I expected
that progression of events,
but if I woke up in the
middle of the night,
I was going to take a leak and a a light
shone down to the bathroom and they
stuck me through the window.
It took me a board,
a space ship,
and I saw the exact same thing
that I saw when I was high on DMT,
had to be 100% convinced that
I was in contact with aliens.
The different,
the only difference is how I got there.
Like I got there through a drug.
I got there through smoking,
something that's produced by the human
brain so that I knew it was pretty safe.
No one's ever died of it.
I'm like,
let's see what happens.
And all that goes back to everyone I'm
been talked to in mash groups taking
particularly Iowasca yeah,
they have group events
and see the same things.
I hear the same thing.
Yes,
which is the psychic connection,
but it's beyond that.
You could argue a one
person's a psychic leader.
They projected everybody else's mind.
Yeah,
but who is projecting that into them?
So that's the only way it's out this,
this is one of the Pentagon.
It will.
It might not be someone projecting
anything into your mind.
It might be your new found ability
to perceive things that you could.
The way I look at it,
it's like,
no,
I agree,
but why are they all 43 people?
You know in Costa Rica,
all she aliens,
this is a bad example.
This is a bad example,
but it's not a bad one.
If you fart and you didn't have a nose,
no one would know.
If we didn't have a sense of smell,
we didn't have a sense of smell.
We could still get along in this slide.
I agree.
It was a way to visually see if
food was one individual elucidation.
There's all saying,
but what I,
what I'm saying is it's entirely possible
that there's multiple dimensions are
multiple things that we can't
perceive that we haven't,
we don't have the census for
that are around us all the time.
Great.
Just briefly and you jump in there,
Eddie.
Let me tell you what my deep
recharge and basically vision is.
Okay?
It just means you're
things crystallize epiphany
to talk about 12 dimensions,
11 known,
1218 omnipresence.
So we don't say it actually exists.
Okay.
To say that is arrogant.
So I won't say that,
but I have had dreams my
whole life that come true.
And the weirdest thing like,
Oh lady drops a thing of pickles at the
store or for five years I have the dream
and then one day I'm there and it's
the woman in the pickles break or,
or corn or when was this
Kevin?
When I was a kid it was more intense ties.
Fucking crazy.
So you,
for five years he had the same
dream that one day it happened.
Yes.
Was it how you drempt ish.
Fuck for about six months.
I had a dream of a guy in a purple
and green striped shirt and I'm like,
why am I walking?
Cause it's not like normal dreams.
Just like you're been taken over.
You always get vomit after like
a lucid dream is the dream.
And I'm walking around like Lala behind
a building and all of a sudden there's
some dude in a purple
and green stripe shirt.
He attacks me and six months later
it happens.
And I mean it happens.
Exactly.
So what do you think is going on?
If you mean all thoughts
of yourself aside,
just,
just look at it objectively.
What do you think that is?
You could say that it's human programming
and basic programming and the brain.
Do you think you're tapping
into a timeline that maybe
you can't access all the
time?
That's what I know.
What you can rent.
One of the reasons why
you can rant and rave and,
and when you spew out
information that way you do,
which is at very impressive,
the way you can talk about the
three hours straight and six hours.
You do the majority of your
programs entirely by yourself.
No television.
I agree with you.
It's not like I'm going to tell you a
little bit is doing something unusual.
Do you understand that?
I'm not even doing it.
It's like a river's going by.
There's a turtle,
there's a fish,
there's a log.
I,
that's why it's like random,
like what is this?
What does that exactly right,
but that's how you communicate.
That's like in the beginning of the
thing we were talking about Sandy Hook.
I kept trying to slow you down.
I was like,
I'm not following you down this river.
You just hit this one rock.
I want to talk about this rock.
I want to talk about the next rock,
but you just keep going the way
you think about things this year.
You're changing one
thing to the next thing,
to the next thing,
and for people who are not
thinking the way you're thinking,
it can be exhausting.
Like you're trying to follow
Sam write about it at all.
I'm only seeing that like the code,
but I'm wondering because of the fact
you're telling me that you had these
dreams that came true.
Exactly the way you dreamt them.
I know you're not full of shit.
I've,
you're not a liar.
I've known you for a long time.
If that really did happen to you,
if this is your real life experience,
I want to know what the fuck that is.
You are you.
Are you on the periphery?
Do you have your finger on a membrane
that maybe other people can't totally
touch where occasionally just occasionally
you get a little peek through and you
get to see the other side,
even if it's only once
or twice in your life.
Who's to say that what you're experiencing
by being able to see these things
that manifest themselves
realistically in the future,
that this isn't what human beings will
have five years from now or a hundred
years from now?
Well,
sure.
Exactly.
We think of like a cell phone.
The magic honors.
We think we're all the same.
That's the thing.
We're not all the same.
We're not all the same
in our ability to talk.
You can talk for a lot longer days,
and I do.
Eddie Bravo could talk about
Jujitsu better than both of us.
He needs a musician.
Sorry.
You and I both suck at music,
right?
So there's certain things that people
can do that you can't let me try to
describe it and they'll use it against me.
But no to say don't touch it
cause it's their whole religion.
And again,
it's 10 I'm talking about it.
By the time I was like three years old,
I would have this dream that God has,
cause God knows everything
is just super intelligent,
omnipresent,
unlimited dementias.
But God doesn't know where God came from.
So just like we're trying to
find out where we came from,
God is like a virtual
reality simulation as well.
And God is constantly
running every program,
every operation,
turning evil,
loose,
good,
everything.
Show I would have these dreams,
okay.
But earliest memories,
like two,
three years old where I would fly
out to the edge of infinity and
okay.
It was uh,
it was continual message.
Find out where we came from,
find out what it is.
And it would just be this big
giant spinning black vortex,
like a black hole.
And then I would have to go into that
trying to figure out what was going on and
it never in a,
it was the same thing.
And so it's just incredible frustration
show then growing up and dealing with
things,
using questioning politics and
questioning all these other areas.
Then having dreams that come true.
Exactly.
And like knowing what's going to happen
before it happens and then questioning
and,
and then it never being wrong.
Um,
be like weird like crazy stuff man.
Like,
like just so much tough where it becomes
like you can't even deal with it.
You like dial it out and then
you just reached that point where
you don't even know what's real
anymore because it's so crazy.
But then you,
she like the mathematics of the whole
system and you know how it works.
It's not like you're some schizophrenia,
you talk about it,
you deal with it and actually works.
Like now when you fight the system,
you automatically know what to do.
Like when you talk about something,
the president word for word repeats me.
Trump is what freaks them out.
Word for word,
whole speeches,
like whole things.
And I'm on a power trip.
That's what they flipped out about it,
the CIA and everywhere
else and they're like,
well,
Jones is like connected to trumpet.
I think Trump's like an idiot savant.
What does that have to
do with this speech?
Explain that Trump's speech.
Um,
I,
I'm trying to follow it.
I don't even know.
I don't even know if the thing,
it's hard to follow you sometimes
because we were talking about,
you were talking about teams trumps
even before that he was talking about God.
Oh yeah.
Oh God.
God knows everything
except where God came from.
Okay.
That's a good soundbite right there.
Do you think that God is just like every
other system that we see like think of
this.
There's no
one God is the motion.
Cause no one yard,
there's no one bird that's
running all the birds.
There's no one person that's
running all the people does it.
It's all chaos.
Even if we elect someone,
if they have the fuck of people hate him,
everybody's in chaos.
There's con they're trying concept power,
struggle.
Are you still on?
Do you think that God has decentralized?
Do you think that the idea of God is
decentralized and maybe God is a real
thing,
but God is not one person.
God is literally of organisms.
God is not just free will.
God is consciousness.
It's all of the organisms.
It's every fucking
technological innovation.
Tell the thing.
No,
I agree with you.
New agents,
a counterfeit Joe,
I agree with counterfeit.
No,
I'm saying a confident what's real?
Cause they'll say,
oh God is everything
that the movie was true.
God is experiencing
consciousness or all of us.
There's there's,
you know one of my where I have a
hard time saying that I know this.
I could say God might be decentralized.
I could say God might just be just like
every other organism on the planet.
It's just some thing that's moving in a
certain direction and trying to protect
itself and trying to procreate and trying
to advance and trying to innovate and
trying to be better than it was yesterday.
That's when everything is doing.
Every fucking animal that started out
as a single celled organism is trying to
survive.
Can we say create themselves?
Well,
it's not necessarily that
it didn't create itself.
It's something created.
It's slowly but surely say this through
the process of evolution and mutation.
This is the,
he'd go on and keep going for hours.
We should do an epic podcast,
but the point is we should not give up.
Let's don't give up.
The point is there is a pro human
future and a pro freewill future and the
globalist or an or an anti
human anti freewill future.
So all I know is just
swim towards the light.
This is pro human future.
This is the point and this is one of
the reasons why I wanted to discuss this
with you and this is one of the things
that I talked about with Tim Pool
recently and one of the things that
when we have a revised podcasts,
which is coming up very
soon with Jack from Twitter,
we all need to talk about open
communication that this is,
it's very bad for all people involved
to shut people down from communicating.
As long as they're not doing anything
to actively try to harm somebody.
And they said those that make
people peaceful action or whatever.
We said the people that make peaceful
action illegal make violence inevitable
and I'm butchering the closet.
That's a PR.
You might have paraphrased it,
but that's a perfect quote.
People don't like being
left on the outside.
And that's what I came.
One of the things about you and I having
this conversation and we had our blowup
is coming to understand that you felt
like you were left on the outside and me
as a person who was constantly busy
and wasn't paying attention to that,
it was selfish of me to not pay attention
to how you must have felt to be stuck
on the outside.
Well,
I just felt regardless of what you did,
what w w we you wish you
didn't do or didn't do.
What I like about you
is what we saw today.
I mean,
one of the best things
about this podcast to be,
I got to show people what I
really love about Alex Jones.
You're fucking fun.
This is hilarious.
And you say a lot of shit that turns out
to be real and turns out to be of real
concern and you make some really good
points about all the shit that has the,
I hear you.
I don't want to be right
about them killing babies.
I know you don't want to
be right about a human.
You don't have to be.
You don't.
It means it doesn't matter
whether you want to be right here.
Oh,
Jesus.
What's your longest podcasts?
We're going,
no,
don't do that.
That was like six hours or something.
What would your lawmaker,
I think,
uh,
Kevin Smith was the longest.
He was like five and a half.
Fuck that dude.
Oh,
he's a great guy.
I'm just kidding.
I love them.
Okay,
30 more minutes to go.
You're going to be stacked up to,
and I'm fine,
man.
Hours.
Look,
here's
the fine.
Listen,
I'll be honest with you.
I'm kind of retarded.
No,
no,
no.
That's going to be a soundbite.
They're going to put
that to Mariachi music.
No,
I might have to use it.
You'll must be flame thrower
to light the next choice.
Tobacco.
No,
no.
Seriously when it comes to regular life,
regular tobacco with no marijuana at all.
Would you like some yes.
Belbin I know.
Lead for alibi.
My guts never wrong.
That's
your points.
Cause here's the deal.
What points I got points
100% Hundred percent.
I ain't got no points.
I've got some great points.
No,
no.
Eddie,
Eddie big UFC is ambassador
of the flat Earth Society.
No,
he's not.
Eddie barely listened to it.
He doesn't believe more
than he believes this
became a universal truth.
He would fucking start
believing the earth is round.
No Flat Earth Society contraries
the Flat Earth Society is controlled
opposition.
Nobody gets in flatter.
Okay,
listen,
I know there's a lot of bullshit,
so I really had her society.
It's not real.
I respect you.
I do.
I love you.
The point is,
is that I'm asking you
a real question here.
Okay.
It'd be the biggest
documentary in history.
It only costs like $1 million.
Okay.
Let's take it a 50,000 ton big ship and
to have its circumnavigate the planet.
Okay?
You will be there with GP.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not going to be there.
No,
we're going to get someone
to represent me there.
Okay.
Good drugs
doing no,
no,
no.
We're launching the discovery
of flat earth project.
Well,
that rocky man dude's already
shooting himself in the space.
Isn't he like make this really easy.
You know,
you know,
you prove the earth that
we really live on a ball.
How when you,
when they supposedly make
those missions to the ISS,
when they shoot up,
just have that one of the astronauts,
it's going to go to the ISS.
Just have a GoPro camera on his head,
on his helmet and just go uncut.
No cuts,
no cuts from the tongue.
You get in on that ship to the tongue.
You Doc.
And I want you to duck.
We
and Fred.
Fred.
No,
I'm fricking technology.
My cell phone is awesome.
What does that,
any of the songs be combative here.
But if this is how we talk,
I know,
but you're talking over each other.
If that did happened,
would you,
uh,
you want some more tobacco Alex Jones,
dude,
sure.
If that happened the first
time I'm saying this,
I've been saying if that
happened that happened,
you let it go.
There's no footage of the construction
of the international space station.
There's no footage.
You just appear cause there's
not a spender as payers.
No footage of the modules
of the internationals.
I you sure about that?
100% there's no footage
of the construction.
That shit.
People that worried me
in the space station,
I've known astronauts.
They're real people,
man.
They were the real real people.
I didn't say they weren't real peaceful.
You don't think it's really constructed
or you would like to see the footage
first?
Listen,
listen.
If you know there's a,
there's a debate.
Let me finish,
dude.
Let me just,
there's a debate out there whether you
believe we went to the moon or not.
You have.
Everyone needs to acknowledge it.
There was the debate.
There's people that will meet the laser.
Hold on.
There's people that believe we went to
the moon and there's people believe that
we faked it.
You have to understand both receive.
We'll have a message.
Exactly.
So when you talk about,
uh,
the people that don't
believe we went to the moon,
when they also say they're
faking other space shit too,
you'd have to kind of understand
where they're coming from.
They believe whether they win or not.
Maybe we were,
maybe we didn't.
I don't know.
But there's people that don't believe it,
so when they don't,
you should understand it.
They have no trust for any of that.
How many times you got to fake
going to the moon before you go,
okay,
well before that bullshit
meter just fucking explodes.
No,
I agree.
Let's do,
oh,
we got mad about Sandy Hook,
which I think happened.
I have a Roger question.
I one I was watching minions three or
four where they go to us and they run
through the many hands,
you know,
run through Hollywood and their,
and their staging of the moon landing.
People have a right to do that.
The truth is nobody
wants to send people up.
There's a bunch of die,
a bunch of test Polish die.
We fly on jumbo jets around the country,
our cell phones work.
Do you think that we
definitely went to the moon?
Absolutely.
100% absolutely.
Beg Your Life on it.
That my live on.
But the difference is,
is that they say,
I say it didn't happen.
The truth is that we have a type
of Alex Jones and i's moon landing.
I've denied it a bunch of times.
They,
you know,
they say Alex Jones says that there are
a you human slaves on Mars ever said it.
But all I'm saying is I know
the real NASA people and
Warner von Braun,
the guy who directed all 6
million missions was a Nazi,
correct?
Yes.
He hung out with uh,
a Walt Disney,
correct?
Yeah.
Yup.
And who in the 50s just made up space?
They never,
no one went.
Ever went to space.
How a space Ellison,
I'm Walt had space.
Why was on the phone with you
for 45 minutes this morning?
I told you I have a 12 inch telescope.
12 inch diameter opening.
Aperture.
Yes.
We talked about it's a fricking
Moja take him 35 millimeter.
It's there.
All the shit you see when you look up,
it's there.
You get the telescope,
you can closer to what's going on.
We're not going to have a
space as fake conversation.
You told me the fucking lie.
I can't do this.
I didn't say the lights or [inaudible].
I don't know.
Well,
I don't know what they are.
I,
the way I described this is the
same way I talk about Jujitsu.
You,
you should never talk about
how effective martial arts,
you can't prove that shit.
You can't do all this thing 3
million miles away like are we even
put a real people that have souls and
freewill because you could say maybe we
don't even exist.
You don't exist.
Joe Doesn't exist and nobody exists.
So because we can't be kind
of a space is fucking head.
We'll break.
Not Ready.
Let's not do it.
The only,
my point of all that was I don't want
to have it space discussion either,
but my point is that if there's people
out there that believe we faked going to
the moon six times,
you have to understand their skepticism.
That's yes.
No,
hold on.
You know what I mean?
We talked about before when
he was talking us down.
This is what we talked about before when
he was talking about the reason why he
questions anything.
It's cause he's,
he's seen so many different things.
It turned out to be exactly understanding
earlier and he was actually saying
that sometimes you can get fucking crazy
with it and you think that everything's
fake and you call bullshit
on things that really aren't.
But assuming next generation is real.
Yes.
We can do some stuff like what
we've done,
man.
Um,
what like what like fight
wars and shut like what?
Like electricity.
That's awesome.
Tesla,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
Where's Tesla now?
Just how about all the technology
that you enjoy and make your life?
I love it.
I love them.
Signs.
Of course.
I'm talking to that's the same science.
No,
no.
Allows people to understand the
distance between earth and Mars.
That's kind of stuff.
Then you get into science.
But by the way,
you've taught me a lot.
You're a really smart guy and
entrepreneur and a bad ass shit.
I think it's healthy
to be where you're at.
Questioning everything first,
just buying everything.
All I'm telling you is
is the stuff we have now.
A hundred years ago it would be
considered magic and we humans could way.
I agree with that fucking iPhone
hospital and it has nothing to do.
It's taste on the main line in the
videos running NASA and I'm like,
where were there?
Guess I ran the RCA cameras.
We fake the photos because
of the radiation belt headed.
They called him up,
but when we shouldn't have done that,
I fucking know what happened.
That makes way more sense to me and it's
one of the things that Jamie and I have
actually discussed when we
talked about the Gemini 15 photo,
the famous photo of Michael Collins.
That turns out to be just a reverse of
a photo of him on a training mission
where he's in the hardest one in PR.
They use the,
that's what I said is PR agents.
I didn't go to too.
I went to three
beds of NASA engineers.
One of them was Raymond tick that
allowed me to talk about this.
Raymond was there running this fricking,
he ran the lasers on the moon.
He ran the deals.
He said what was weird is they had
another group of ships and I'm not,
you know what pretty much
I just shouldn't do it.
Another group of ships,
well they had another group of sheriffs,
but basically he wouldn't have
Chad and this is not drama.
I was going to meet with him.
I met with him at the
former Norad Command base.
There's the Hilton outside.
Awesome.
And he wouldn't tell me and then
like a week later his heart blow,
but he was ready to tell me.
He said,
no,
it's real,
but there's more advanced and I mean he
had like presidential letters as house.
You look at him,
he's like the main guy
like running the camera.
It's like number three in NASA,
like for engineers to fricking gee.
He was in Vietnam Rant,
black ops and Cambodia and he said,
he said,
well we lost a lot of people,
but those were clandestine operations.
I wasn't part of them.
It's all compartment launched.
But he said,
you're right that there were a bunch of
missions beforehand because the US was
willing to kill 50 people that do
that just to see if they can get some,
until no one else will be tragic
thing because people think the US.
Is that great Joe?
No,
we were willing to,
we hadn't met already to die.
Oh yeah.
Over and over again for
the one time at work.
And that's what pisses me off.
Well Gus Grisham and those,
the original blew up on them life I blew
up on the launchpad will be incredibly
tragic if is if they
actually did go to the moon,
but they fake the footage
because of the radiation.
So they released this
bullshit beliefs and you know,
but do you know how,
how horrific that would be if you were
a guy like Neil Armstrong and you knew
that the footage was bullshit,
but you actually had gone to
the moon and you're like fuck.
And this whole thing was like,
people were starting to look at why are
these wise or whether they're on wires.
There's that Isley,
we were there on trampolines like,
yeah.
By the way,
they all got radiated because it's true.
Like he says going through that.
So I got a thousand chest
x rays or something,
you know,
even full nude,
you know it's like 10 texts,
chestnut tress,
right?
I thought it was only one.
Notice how they know what's more.
It's notice how the international
flights are all now at night.
Why is that?
Because there's fricking
know radiate dude.
No,
no,
no.
Solar radiation from 35,000 feet to two
two c level on average is 10 feet of
water and about six inches of stone.
There's dirt.
Why?
Why is the sun so big on the on on the,
explain that again.
What are you saying?
Imagine that the atmosphere is a lynch.
Okay,
so when you,
why do you think the sun or the moon
looks so much bigger on the horizon?
Why is that?
You ever thought about that?
I always thought it was just,
it's a refraction Harrison,
cause it's on there.
That
why is it red?
The atmosphere.
You're looking hair and yeah,
you're looking through a thousand
miles instead of 20 miles.
Okay.
Show the moon gets smaller and you're
just totally white as it goes up.
Right?
So this is,
this is like astronomy.
I'm on it because you're looking
at it on the plane and I forget,
uh,
we were talking,
there's no flights.
Yeah.
Radiation years,
whatever it is.
You get a bunch of chest x rays when
you fly during the day because the sun
solar radiation,
because you're above,
everybody knows you're in the mountains.
You get a worst sunburn.
Why isn't less oxygen less dropping the V,
the UV show when you're at 30,000 feet,
that's above.
There's The Himalayan.
Yeah.
You,
you are up there and there's no,
there's,
there's on average 35,000 feet.
This is NASA statistics.
Probably not true at the end,
the feet of water and six inches of stone,
because there's,
if you condensed 35,000 feet of dust,
the filter,
oh wow.
Why wouldn't you hit a
filter on your iPhone?
Is it turn another color?
Put a filter over it.
Right?
So think about,
think about the atmosphere when you're
looking straight up the boons fucking
white.
Looking at this angle,
it's yellow,
right?
It's big and orange on the like,
damn,
that's big.
It's not just where it's coming up.
That's part of it,
right?
It's the itch.
It's bubbled,
it's deformed.
It's like looking through a
pair of glasses on the edge.
So you're looking through
all that atmosphere.
You look at through pollution,
you'll look through dirt,
everything.
Yeah.
My Dad told me all that.
That's fucking amazing.
Know.
So that's why moons are red,
that they're red when they rise and
they're white when they go to the top.
So all the shit we're
looking at it through.
Yeah,
we've got a weird situation,
Huh?
A big ass one quarter
size planet just floating.
Just floating above us.
We stare at it.
Well it's a full moon tonight.
That is fucking weird.
Is a planet.
It's right there.
I fell asleep at like 10 o'clock last
night and miss your call and I woke up at
like three 30 and I had to
get up and I looked out,
it looked fake news show,
sometimes half moon,
and I was looking out the
hotel like 500 yards Shamir,
and I'm looking at beautiful that has,
he's just like,
hey,
it's okay to say it's made out of cheese.
Did you probably isn't.
Did you ever see that movie dark city Gal?
Yeah.
I love the way fucking
movie Kiefer Sutherland.
Fucking great movie.
Sometimes I would move,
it was like a twilight zone.
It's like a twilight zone.
It's a classic.
I watch that motherfucker again,
but it makes me feel
sometimes like reality,
like,
like that movie was so strange because
it was like this weird scripted reality
that these people would show.
They'd have to find a way to
the surface and shit is real.
Yes.
Your consciousness is,
no,
no.
I'm not saying no,
no,
no.
I agree.
It's almost saying it's
fascinating and great times,
so sure.
You're right.
That movie I'm saying,
you're right.
He is virtual,
but Uriel,
yes,
you're real too.
You've been put in,
all of us were put into a simulation
to basically test us and that's the big
thing I'm trying to get across to people.
Damn.
Alex Jones.
Let's wrap this motherfucker up.
Let's eat,
man,
let me ask this question.
Okay,
go ahead.
You can helicopter in.
It's South Africa or wherever I can you
imagine the film Siki searching flat
earth and he brought up was
sending a representative.
We see.
No,
no,
no.
You should be on Chicago
and was a representative.
Do you have a guy?
I'll have it like a contest.
You really believe him.
Oh that's a good move but contest.
Yeah.
And then we'll just have a camera
man and the whole camera man.
You paid for the camera man's flight gps,
those hundreds of these satellites.
It was Amy can fill 64 GPS.
So there's this whole gps and a,
you can like leave la on a,
on a ship and you can go all
the way over to Japan and she,
everybody and go down around India and
around Africa and he'd go land in New
York.
We can do it.
If it's all a flat plane,
that's like,
you're just not thinking right.
You could do need to go anywhere you want.
If it's flat,
you just go anywhere.
You want people to think like,
how did you travel around me today?
You circumnavigate.
You told me this morning that drove us,
get off this.
You told me this morning,
not this morning,
yesterday or this morning.
You said you shed basically didn't,
there was no way to prove any of this.
Approve any of what?
What he's on about this.
What's this meeting space you're,
you're saying you're generalizing?
No,
I'm not mad.
You questioning.
I think it's great.
I'm not go to jail or be shipped.
You just said that.
I said something and I don't
even know what you think.
This whole problem is.
I got Alzheimer's.
What do you think this all this.
I'm shit with people thinking the earth
is flat or people thinking spaces fake.
What do you think that's coming from?
I'll tell you,
it might be able to get any food here.
View.
Oh my God.
I'm going to have to
set the spectrum show.
You've got people that don't even know
if they're human or of life exist.
It's just all hallucination because
they'd been lied to so much for so long.
They don't know what's true.
And then over here you've got people that
just believe whatever they see on CNN
and me,
I'm just trying to look at everything on,
well,
they've lot a lot,
but sometimes there's not.
That oftentimes isn't competence.
What's real?
And so I don't blame it any that's like
way over here or other people that are
like way over here because they're
trying to find some solace and believe
there's order of the universe.
The truth is there's not
order in the universe.
There's people trying to bring order to
the universe and that's why they stage
events so they can try to
bring order within that event.
That's all I'm running an been and you're
talking about no Northwoods or Gulf of
Tonkin or false,
whatever the thing is or,
or taking a real event and making a big,
but it's not bad to question that.
And so how do we get convinced to say,
well,
you know,
I asked questions and I didn't get to
be shut down as long as I'm legitimately
asking questions.
So there's going to judge that.
I have that right.
So that's where we're all going.
Just what is the system
won't get rid of free speech,
right?
To self defense,
the family to fend those
things and ask yourselves,
what are we about to men?
I believe in that.
You can say that shit again.
What was it right to
bear arms free speech.
And what was the third one?
Family.
What were the big amazing,
John Asks you a question.
Who was the big three?
Say that again.
I think mystery is
what's having mysteries.
What's key
now you get wine.
And I appreciate you having me on guys.
I don't want to be like,
my life is not sandy hook.
I'm [inaudible] tell me,
you're telling me earlier
that you were actually,
you,
even before all this happened,
you were planning your exit strategy.
Like you get weary of this.
Yeah.
And it's not like I'm afraid of the fight,
but I'm 45 and I've had a long adventurous
life so I'd probably like 60 and I
was already like,
I wasn't sure about Trump or whatever
has really bad feeling when he got
elected.
Not that he was bad,
just like other wars about it start and
then I was already planning to kind of
face tanks out just cause I don't know,
like down when I'm 55 of a heart attack
and the fact that they attack me so much
makes me have to battle and fight
and never give up and and and,
and so it's not like they even
wore me down before they ever,
they kept me in the game.
I want to explain it.
They kept me in the game attacking
me in lying about me because now I'm,
well I've now become,
when I was worried about,
now I dream about this stuff.
Yeah.
That was what you were
worried about initially.
Yeah,
because I realized about the four year,
five years ago,
it's obsessive that I was
already totally obsessed.
You were,
you were telling me that it fucks with
your head that this certain amount of it
after a while it just
fucks with your head.
Yeah,
the negativity.
Yeah.
And I like to have dreams.
I have like dreams are like 20 years long,
like you said about DMT where
I'm a farmer and like it's a,
it's like 500 years ago and I'm just
like planning things and eating food and
like put my kids to sleep and like,
you know,
cutting trees down and
like walking around.
I have dreams just like normal
and just being a normal person.
And so I,
I never,
I didn't like the global state.
Like they have like all these shows,
homeland,
all,
he showed her on this big demon.
I didn't like calculate what I was going
to do and then I was already not ready
to give up.
I was ready to move on and innovate and
now it's almost like it's God doing it.
God's like,
no,
it's not that easy.
You're going to be pinned against the
wall by your enemies and you're going to
fight to the death.
And then I don't believe God's a say this,
but I realize it's God's planned.
I'm not going to be turned loose.
I wasn't just going to do a couple tours
in this fight and be be turned loose.
And so it shows each bin it's been framed
realize that this is all big stage and
God wants to see some people dance.
But I tell you the global is take,
they're like running me out or
they think they've gotten me.
It's the difference.
It's like it's,
it's,
it's the opposite now they've
turned me into this maniac.
Well there's a,
there's definitely some sort of a
struggle going on right now and there's a,
it's a seems to be like a universal
struggle for figuring out what people are
and how we should behave
and who gets to decide that.
And there's certain universal truths are
ignored and there are certain ones that
are emphasis over emphasized and there's
certain ones that you know that are in
the goldilocks spot and
we were working it out.
I think that's part of what's
going on with human beings.
But will we have to be really,
really careful of is that by silencing
some people and never giving them any
path to retribution,
we create eternal enemies.
And this is,
this is what easily could be happening
right now when someone doesn't have
ability to express themselves
because an evil force once conflict and
what you say is totally know if it's an
evil force,
but it's an archetypal form there.
They're listening to
all those around them.
And there's a hive hive mind sort
of thinking to a lot of this.
There's not a lot of debate about it.
So I,
let's just say this Joe and,
and to,
um,
10th planet,
everybody else,
you didn't give into the
pressuring of the threat.
It was more than nagging like a siren,
like a bitching woman,
not against women.
But I mean,
I get it.
Why us?
And so that's why you didn't have me on.
But then you realize I was just a symbol
of you just trying to live the life and
put out good ideas and talk to people.
But folks,
you're going to make you choose a side.
And that's what's happening
in this quickening ish.
I don't want to choose a side.
Ryan Seacrest has got it nailed.
Nobody's coming to Ryan Seacrest
for like political advice.
He's got it nailed.
He hosts a bunch of shows.
A real nice guys.
Got a great smile.
He's figured it out.
But you understand,
understands you have in that sweet spot,
man.
You're looking at you going dummy,
we are talking about
anything and everything.
Oh my God,
just them sunlight.
Entropy is stagnant water.
Oh,
it's still nothing's going on.
It's all clear.
It's dead and rotting.
What's alive?
Ocean.
Big crashing waves.
Yes,
it's Jersey.
I,
I've seen beyond that.
Everybody has,
but I've,
I've seen way beyond cause you
want to be in the conflict.
You want to be in the fight.
You want to take all your,
you're not successful Joe.
Cause you played along with the system.
You're successful because you did it
organically and real doesn't mean it's
perfect.
Doesn't mean it's bad.
It was real.
That's why your success and
then they come in and you think,
oh I'm not saying you're bad.
I'm the same way.
Oh,
all these people are telling me how
great I am up play ball with them because
I've got,
you know,
this thing.
But they want you
because they're soulless.
And so all I'm saying is
you've made the right decision.
And I'm not just saying having beyond
because I'm not perfect is deciding no
America,
sell America the world,
still the world.
We're allowed to talk about real things
and heroic things because they want to
shut other voices down so they
can lie about those voices.
And,
and any idea that fears,
exposure or fears,
debate is a failed idea.
Well,
you know,
I have a unique perspective and my
perspective is less and less inclined to
pursue it in the idea that it's a fight
and more to be able to pursue reason and
to have everybody
communicate with each other.
Because I think part of what the fuck
is wrong with all of us today is that
people
are so willing to take sides,
so willing to join teams and so willing
to fight about shit that they really
don't have to fight about.
I wanted to say this,
I'm a sad cause.
It's just so powerful.
I don't dislike Donald Trump and I
think he's done some good things.
I'm trying to do piece and trying
to get jobs back to America,
but I hate Donald Trump
because I got behind him because I knew
Hillary was bad and then he became my
identity.
He is not a bad guy,
but the truth is I hate him more than
Hillary Clinton because he's who I am now
and whatever he does is who I am.
Mcdonald's from.
I'm with America and
freedom and everything else,
and I'm not throwing under the bus to
get towards soils on my back though.
They already asked me for the,
for the reasons I'm a with them.
I'm not against even Trump,
but I get in a fight like this that's so
dumbed down that then no matter what I
do,
they take my radical and this
my weirdness to hurt Trump,
but then all it does is
like radio attack me.
I don't,
I don't know how to describe it,
but it's like I,
it's like Trump is breaking my legs every
day and it's not like I'm not willing
to go through the pain except a lot of
he says I don't agree with and he's not
my identity.
Shanti Hooks,
not mine.
This is just from talking from your own
personal perspective and I appreciate
that,
that he's not your dad.
I don't know how many people actually
think that he's your identity,
but I think that what we're getting at
that's important is that we don't know
when they're shooting at me,
they're going to Trump.
I'm sure.
I'm sure there's a lot of,
don't mind the shooting yet,
Joe.
It's that I'm not Donald Trump.
I understand that from you,
but what I'm talking about is
just the human race in general.
If we could just do one thing,
be reasonable,
just be reasonable and understand that
emotions cloud judgment and that when
people start screaming and yelling at
each other and you take one side and
you're the left and this guy takes
another side and he's the right and you're
going back and forth,
he just,
he phones to mindless,
it's nonsense and you don't ever get
anything solved and you never get to
understand how that other person thinks
and feels and we're constantly trying to
mock people.
And what you were talking about about
the bill Maher thing about him cracking a
joke and I dismissed it as a joke because
it was a joke was talking about how
the red states wish they were the
blue states and all that shit.
That's that's exactly the type of
thing we're talking about though.
That,
that,
that US versus them that me versus like
you're generalizing for entire swaths of
the country as if they're one.
Yeah.
I feel bad every time I
say California has lost.
This is a beautiful state
and a lot of great people,
but this is a lot of people here.
A lot of them were fucking lost.
That's a fact.
You know this like who
knows how many minutes?
It's like 30 something million.
38 million.
It's crazy.
That's a giant country.
And it was the population of California.
It's fucking giant.
That's too many people to,
there's no way you could
say Californians do this,
this fucking California that are ranchers.
40 million.
Can we fit the whole population?
So when you look at,
isn't that,
isn't that true?
We are overpopulated in some
ways though with our technology,
but let me just make this point.
Then we got to end this.
I gotta pee so bad.
What?
Go
Go pee,
pee and come back on first.
Five more minutes because I want to,
I want to get into the topic.
Let's talk some sense and know how to
pitch to tell him about Bazalgette.
Tell me about boy buzz Aldrin.
You know,
I'll tell you about buzz Aldrin.
He told me.
I know.
Okay,
it's going to be Brown,
Cleveland browns.com I'm going to lie.
I can't both leaf Jamie.
Eddie,
how you doing?
I'm doing good.
So,
um,
what do you,
what do you think about the wide receiver
of the browns?
I don't think we can turn the
talk to brown sand right now.
No,
unfortunately is okay.
Is there any conspiracy theory
that you kind of are suspicious of?
There's gotta be at least one,
like which one?
Like nine 11,
nine 11.
You think?
You know,
are you familiar with tower seven?
Yeah,
I would say from a,
almost every story.
Even the stuff we've talked
about before in the past,
I,
I don't believe the official
and quotes.
So,
you know,
the tower seven was the
third tower that went down.
You're aware of that,
right?
Yeah.
I'm,
I look more when he,
when that comes up,
all of the surrounding information about,
uh,
what it,
what was it in the buildings,
not,
not the actual event.
I know the event happened.
I'm not,
I'm not sure.
I'm curious about that.
Did you see the video of tower seven disco
ball speed?
That's gotta be a little suspicious,
right?
Red Flag got to come up at least,
right.
If you're trying to,
if you're really trying
to get to the truth,
you're like,
wait a minute.
I would say there's more of a
suspicious that a third building fell.
It wasn't,
it wasn't going to hit exactly.
That's what the whole story is with tower
seven and not only was it not touched
by a plane,
it went down at free fall speed and
it's caught on video like five different
angles,
right?
There's five different names.
No one's saying that it's fake footage.
That's tower seven to 47 storey,
skyscraper fucking fallen
at free fall speed.
Some people are saying and got
hit with a direct energy weapon.
Some people are saying that it was uh,
brought down like a,
a controlled demo like in Vegas,
like one of those buildings,
you know.
But regardless of how it was brought down,
you got to look at that
video footage to go,
wait a minute.
And why is youtube telling you
now I'm building seven footage.
Yeah,
I mean here,
here's one footage was
on syndicated radio.
I'm like 50 stations in
2001 and I'm sitting there,
that's actually 120 stations.
So I lost like 70% of them were
saying that it was an inside job.
I don't mean the firemen blow it up.
I'm watching Fox News,
CNN at my studio,
and then I go get a pizza at four o'clock
with CBS radio back then and they go
Solomon brothers building seven there's
going to be brought down in a controlled
demolition of the of the buildings.
So I go back
on here and announce building seven
being brought down to see what their
buildings and for five,
five years everyone goes,
I'm crazy.
Then CNN and all of them archive it on
the Internet and everyone's watching
building seven
BBC,
ABC.
Let me ask CNN,
do you think happened with tower seven
she and in ABC and CBS has told me the
government blow it up.
The government play the clips.
They go,
because I want to get back.
We're blowing it up and the media,
he goes,
oh,
you mean the cops blow it up?
No,
the cops are told,
get back on the countdown.
I interviewed with Toms like Gen nine
five four three they explain it to me.
Do you think that they had detonation set
up already in the buildings and that's
where it goes next.
Joe,
which I used to always
like try to follow it down.
What it means.
I don't know.
I've learned to go,
Hey,
I've got five different
newscast when it happened.
And before it's saying they blew it up.
I don't know what happened.
Is it possible that it collapsed
because of those gigantic diesel fires?
Right.
And then the way our one to two
sevens is on building seven,
seven had a deer diesel,
bigger tanks in the basement caught
fire and they said it was an inferno and
they said it cooked through the nose.
Hold on a second.
He's always,
but I want to ask you
this cause I don't know.
Oh yeah.
Right.
But it,
they said that what happened was,
this is whoever the fuck explained it,
that was making these youtube videos
that the fire had burned through the
internal structure of the building.
It's such a high temperature
that all of these floors,
how lax they pancaked and then it came.
But it never happened before,
since right.
Never hasn't happened before.
Since that's a fact.
Here's,
here's the thing about this.
Shawn's 18 years ago would
argue every point and say,
I knew what happened.
Okay.
The Alex Jones in 2019 is honest.
Well,
I'm glad you're,
I'm going to say I've seen him say they
blew it up and nobody gonna describe
him.
I don't know Joe,
what happened,
right.
Well,
when you look at it,
the way it falls,
it falls exactly what I can control.
Demolition.
Exactly.
So it falls from the top down.
But if you actually watch false peak,
right?
But if you watch the full video,
the center of it collapses.
Like there's a full video where you're
looking at the top of the building and
the center of it collapses
far before the outside does.
That's how they take,
they take out the elevator should
take some central thing first.
So do light up the music.
Do they do this with,
did they have it all set in advance?
So they knew that nine 11
was going to come in today.
She answered my question,
please don't know.
Right.
And what they do is they take like some
clip of me from 20 years ago or 18 years
ago going,
here's CBS News and they don't show it.
I mean I've got Slippy,
yes,
I've got easy possible that even though
operation Northwoods happened and Gulf
of Tonkin was a conspiracy,
is it possible that the internal fires
in that building were so unbelievably hot
that it fucked up every floor and they
really did pancake on top of each other
and then the exterior
structure just collapsed?
Is that possible?
Because I'm not an engineer though.
The engineers say it's not.
It's not possible at all and it,
here's the problem with Joe.
They announce it fell on its own
footprint 27 minutes before it did on five
channels to him.
Baby world.
That's true baby.
She Shanahan,
CNN and CBS.
Joe,
I'm a,
I keep food.
I do too.
It was four o'clock.
I've been on air since that
morning on syndicated radio.
I drove down to the local pizza place
at four o'clock got my page that was
eating in the car and our
CBS radio driving home and
they shed a little sooner.
A little bit mood or say whether our
buildings too controlled demolition.
The Solomon Brothers bouldering.
Bouldering seven.
By the way,
we have these clubs now,
but no one archive stuff then.
So I go on there and I go,
yeah,
they just blow up a building.
Everybody started freaking out.
But here's the thing.
And then they blew it up.
How long does it take to set up explosives
to the point where you could paint?
It normally takes a week.
A week.
That was the next story.
But then I interviewed,
yeah,
the head of emergency
management for new work.
Yeah.
And the loose change people
got him on and he says,
no,
I was there.
They had bombs.
The CIA,
you know what was patient
Bullock seven right?
Villa,
the CIA,
the FBI,
all of it wasn't an NSA as well.
Everything.
See,
he always says,
oh no.
He goes,
I'm not just kissing his ass.
He's beyond that.
He's no,
it's bullshit,
man.
Every fucking thing.
Just fucking say to yourself.
No,
explain it to everybody.
Oh,
you're on.
You do a better job than any fucking
stories are fucking government.
Right.
So there's 40 with a diesel tank and
pre rigged explosives in case shit.
Dude,
man,
he didn't believe I married and even
though I heard CBS say they blow it up and
even though,
and I can do is we go,
Joe says firefighters blow it up
because the government's anything point.
You made a good point.
Like I'm setting the government.
No,
I don't mean my grandpa was in the army.
If it really did pancake from the,
from the fire.
What a shit design.
Yeah.
What a terrible design.
Me So mad at that.
Architects were the debates
from underwriting laboratories.
Most everyone.
I went and looked at the blueprints
into New York and I'm not defending what
you're saying because seven was built.
Well,
it was looked at by lawsuits.
They were sued tower one and two though
they were built with like bubblegum and
like bandaids.
Really?
Oh,
all those buildings are already leaning.
Oh No.
It was a big mob scam.
They were,
no,
they already had,
they already had buckling in the wind.
Oh No.
Mathematicians gas.
That was in like five years.
One building would collapse.
Oh fuck.
Oh my God.
There goes your argument,
it's New York.
These buildings are built
for shit and that's when he,
as you get older,
you know,
some of them were built for shit.
Right.
For sure.
I don't,
yeah,
I mean,
especially back then when,
what does inside your
back heel more tobacco.
I do have more tobacco,
but I'm just,
Kevin was a little bit more tobacco.
Yes,
for sure.
100% you know who Dr. Judy Wood is a no,
I do know she's,
she's got Dr. Judy Woods
wrote a book called,
where did the towers go?
Yeah.
Part of her story,
her theory is,
this is just,
this is just some lady scientist lady.
She said based on the fact that there was,
this is what she claims based on the
video and the pictures that she has of,
uh,
where the towers collapsed.
She or speaking for me,
I'm sorry,
she's saying that there was no rubble.
The book,
the name of the book is called,
where did the towers go?
She said that direct energy weapons,
some kind of direct energy weapons.
Dustin by the buildings turn the buildings
to dusk because there was no rubble.
A dude gave me a book on that,
that this,
he's like,
no,
he's in America at this.
He was in la.
He told me,
uh,
they use Tesla technology.
I was like,
what?
He can say you're wrong
to ask that question.
You know what?
For me,
it doesn't matter if it was justified
or they buttering them up in Las Vegas,
style matters.
Here's those buildings,
in my opinion
and in the world trade centers I've been
accused of covering up and I don't like
that.
You'd be what is,
he's been accused of
covering things up of,
uh,
being a bullshitter like I'm covering.
I'm like,
Oh,
you know,
man,
the judge says,
people think.
A lot of people think you're
designing this hologram plates.
A lot of people think
you're a Zionist shill.
You know that.
That's the biggest one.
That's the biggest one about Alex Jones.
You know,
I'll be honest with you is the
biggest one people always be,
and you know what?
I always have your back always,
always.
I said,
you know what?
If I didn't know him,
I would prob probably
think that shows this.
Just so I know you,
you are honestly,
uh,
making it a mission in your
life to search for the truth to,
uh,
you're all about liberty.
You're for real.
You want the best for people.
You're looking out for the people's best.
So whether you're right or wrong,
it doesn't matter your,
you know,
sometimes you're wrong.
But we only want to say old,
so it's hard for me when I'm like
I'm saying I always have your back.
It's hard for me to,
to think you're like some sign to show.
I'm like,
I know that this wasn't planned.
People make up rumors
about all kinds of people.
They,
they,
they'd come up with ideas
that they want to push.
They decide,
you know,
accuse someone of doing
something really stupid,
like being a part of
something that they're not.
Here's the [inaudible]
Robert [inaudible] back.
Alex,
you know,
you see a lot of heat for it.
We just think I'm a shell.
They think I'm a Zionist.
But when you,
when you say conspiracies,
when you see conspiracies
against you that you know aren't true,
does that make you distrust conspiracies?
Well,
I told you that's the part of it.
That's the evolution of you between you
now and you under the laws of his lies.
But to people that just
say everything's bs,
you got to check it.
There's a lot of that going on.
Right,
exactly.
So let me try to answer it
and he's question because
your question is excellent
as well.
And the two go together.
I,
Eh,
I mean,
I grew up in Dallas,
Texas in the eighties and nineties when
it was like the murder capital of the
country.
I lived in a middle class area,
but it was still like,
and you know,
I got in a fight.
We're rednecks.
I,
you know,
I got in a fight with,
with racist Mexicans,
there were racist white
people attacking Mexicans.
But I,
I mean,
I had a big black guys attacking me.
They were like Flint,
three grades in school.
And my black friends will say,
man,
you're so cool.
You're not raising.
And even though,
you know my cousin who's 18 or if you're
like 14 he's attacked you and you know,
that was all just part of a development.
People do tags.
It doesn't care what color their
skin on is or where they came from.
There's good black people,
there's bad black people,
there's good white people,
there's bad white people,
there's good Mexicans,
there's bad Mexicans,
there's good Asians,
there's bad Asians,
there's good North Koreans.
There's bad with Greens.
And I'm standing really simple
stuff for everybody knows.
But I'll go to a restaurant
if they've got good food.
I don't care if it's Ethiopian or
if it's Mexican or if it's chairman.
If the food's good,
the people are nice.
I love it.
Like a women,
like I love black women or white women.
Love Hispanic woman.
I Love Mall.
Like if the woman's cool,
I don't know a bunch of
black women that are bitches,
black woman that are cool.
What about Swedish bitches?
All I'm all,
the point is let's just say I'm,
I'm Super Gay,
but the point is what I'm
getting at here though?
No,
I don't like Swedish.
no,
no.
Let's wrap this up.
No,
we need to wrap it up,
but I'm going to make this point.
I don't know what it is.
How is that getting into that?
Oh,
the racism thing.
it's not about,
and I want to say something so similar,
but it's like,
yeah,
you just told me grass is green.
Martin Luther King.
Like it doesn't matter
what color someone is.
It matters what they stand for,
what they do.
I go to restaurants that can be owned
by Koreans or black people or white
people,
whatever.
If the food's good music.
I love Jimmy Henry.
He's a black man.
If the food sucks,
did I hate it?
But it's not because they're
white or because they're Hispanic.
Of course,
Joe,
next to a Mexican for three hours.
Okay,
100% believe you totally love Mexicans.
I do too.
Mexican food.
Yeah.
Well,
we,
we've had a big epic interview.
It's been pretty God damn good people.
The end is you've,
let's just,
this is not your record.
Six hour though.
Uh,
no,
but it's pretty damn good.
We're at for like four hours or something.
Something like that.
All right.
This,
I think you guys talked to him about
aliens to fucking really boost your search
engine results.
I need to know will be,
will be eliminated from
all search engine results,
but I really,
there's no doubt that you'll be penalized
for this and show you should say
something about that.
Like you're an American,
you're allowed to talk to me.
Here's are going to say Joe Rogan Jones on
to say no one died at
sandy hook be as well.
I don't think anyone's going to say that,
but people probably will say some things,
but I think also,
you know the idea that like anybody
should be able to tell you that you can't
talk anymore ever.
If you said one thing that people
don't like or if you do talk,
it has to be only on your side and you
have to be trapped out of all of the
different platforms.
For social media,
it's a slippery,
slippery slope,
you know,
and other training OT.
But here's the thing,
I,
you're not a hateful person.
I know you're not a hateful person.
You may have said things that are angry
in the past about certain people or been
angry about a certain event in the news,
but you're not a hurtful,
angry person.
If there's things that
you say that they can say,
hey,
this violates some sort
of a pattern of behavior.
You're attacking someone,
you're giving out someone's address,
that kind of shit,
they should be able to take
it down because that's not,
that's not speech I'm not doing,
that's what I was going to get to.
There should be a clear like set of rules
and you could look at these rules the
way a lawyer would look at him and say,
is this in violation?
Is My client arrested?
Well know your client didn't
have anything illegal on him.
And we did a search and we found no
drugs and we found no illegal weapons.
So,
but we suspected that he was up to
something like the way he was talking,
just in closing to say this,
I don't want to make
myself the center of this.
At the end of the day,
Info wars went from really successful and
huge to light zeitgeisty and Shane and
to take any responsibility
for any of that.
Do you think there's a human,
I'm not perfect.
Right?
Do you think that maybe made it easy for
some of the people that were going to
attack you and I've been guilty of this
myself by providing fuel saying stupid
shit.
Context.
Yes,
but that's what I'm saying
is actually they say it,
it's,
it's global.
It's fun at a big corporation.
This is what I'm a say in closing.
It's come out,
we're going to release this shit.
The thing is it's all left wing.
That's where it's weird,
but yeah,
it's a problem because you
have one ideology that's
overwhelmingly in control of
tech and I agree with them on a lot of
things on social programs and a lot of it
on welfare and universal basic income
and and civil rights and women's rights.
I agree with them on a lot of stuff,
but it's an ideology like any idea
how you have to just agree with,
they were wrong,
but it doesn't have free speech in it.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of y'all.
I just learned all this two weeks ago,
but I got documents.
I'll come back if you want,
but you just let,
right?
I've been attacking the left for doing
it and they're the instrumental group
that's carrying it out.
He would take with defense.
If you're right wing fascist,
who you get to go after each patient,
who do you get the left and he trick you,
trick them and I'm not criticizing.
The right wing is tricking the left
wing and the shutting down free speech.
I'll have confirmed,
oh Jesus Christ.
I have confirmed it's Goddamn conundrum.
Let the Republican Party,
not the average,
you know,
tea party people.
The Republican Party is
blueblood.
It thinks it runs the Democrats
and it learned what was happening and
then come back for a whole shovey one went
on this.
Oh,
come on my show about it.
No,
seriously.
I'll come on your show.
I'm going to be in and that I'm going to
be at a Cap City Comedy Club in Austin.
Promise you're coming home.
I'm coming on are good.
Oh,
come on.
Sit Up.
Fragile.
I'm not just saying this.
I swear to God,
Dude.
I'll bring it back to about me.
I'll tell you the bad stuff about me.
I'm telling you the truth here.
I believe you that tobacco was amazing,
but it was pretty good stuff
you could do.
You could transition.
My problem is to be standing up.
Sure you could crush show.
I'm not trying to lie.
Show you the truth.
I'm not trying to like
bullshit like everybody else.
I'm telling you man.
I,
the problem is it's so real.
Like every time I forget
what I was gonna say,
what was I talking about?
You being a comic.
Yeah,
man.
I don't know how to
transition out of this.
What else I've got planned.
We will hear the plane.
We were just talking about social media
and Youtube and people would be able to
able to being able to silence people and
push their leftist ideology or hands,
right wing ideology.
He was saying that the Republicans
were manipulating the Democrats,
cause I know your Shaker it,
you are empathetic real guy.
That's why I love you.
And you were kind of like
couldn't handle it anymore,
which I actually want to be like that.
So then you kind of dolled out.
So I was aggressive
because you look at it,
I have looked at all this stuff and I
have seen with their own perspectives and
their own plans are,
and they go to Congress and
they lie about all of it.
They're not liberal,
they're not conservative.
It's big corporations
lining up with China,
as you said earlier,
to unify the propaganda
to quote influence China.
No Dude,
they get all the technology.
We,
they've used our open
society to totally take over.
And so that's what I'm trying to get
through to you is that is that they're
coming after everybody.
Like you said earlier,
when we first met you today
that you walk into the office,
I was here two minutes for you to go.
I want to talk about the thing you
shed about the censorship and how it,
once they get us to submit,
we're broken.
No,
it's what you said was it that it was a
slippery slope that if you give it in 1%
it's 1% I'd still have this other
other 99% and then you start moving the
boundaries and they start moving in
closer and closer and it 100% makes sense.
People exist in these,
these control patterns.
It's really common.
They keep asking me like,
oh,
when are you going to give up?
Everything's okay.
As soon as you do like wondering
everything's gonna be okay.
What does that mean?
What does it,
what does give up mean?
You stopped talking.
So people enjoy watching.
This is what your,
where it gets weird that people enjoy
watching you talk and other people don't.
Why can't the people who
don't just not watch you talk?
What is going on here?
He's promoting truth.
He is promoted truth.
But I think what they've done is they've
found these little pockets of things,
compliance head.
Well that too,
but things you shouldn't
threaten everybody you like.
I don't want to put
down this route this up.
I Make Jack Dorsey,
this villain know that like
we had pool and I was true.
They had millions of people harassing
the stock and attacking him lying on.
He's currently attacking children.
He's trying to attack children at their
houses and so it wasn't the fact that I
got in a CNN guy's face and I get
as a shareholder in a company owner,
I'm not defending Jack Dorsey
or whatever his name is.
Yeah.
What's the guy?
The other guy told him to know who?
The other Guy Jack Dorsey's.
The Twitter guys?
Yeah,
the Gen and Oliver.
Darcy.
Yeah,
and it's all admitted is what I'm
saying is I'm not even that guy's enemy.
I just,
I understand.
Like he had millions of people
attacking the shareholders.
Did you hear about?
There's a chef that makes pastries,
which he's worked there 10
years it Trump's hotel in
Florida and buzzfeed found
out who she was and doctor and said,
she's a cult member fire.
You're like,
what does that even mean?
Like why would anybody
harass a pastry chef?
That's a very good question.
People feel like they're a war,
you know?
That's part of the problem
with all this shit.
That's why I was saying be reasonable.
People feel like they're at war,
the right versus the left.
Instead of just being a bunch
of people talking about ideas,
trying to figure it out.
At least take on Hillary or Alex shows
or or or Bill Clinton or Donald Trump.
Well,
shits when is looking in pastry chef.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
By the way.
You think on both.
Not going to be a solution at all.
Type in a buzzfeed targets.
Trump pastry chef.
I don't think you're bullshitting at all.
Let me ask you this because
I've been talking way too much.
Any closing here at the
end of this transmission?
We should talk about
a lot of things along those I have here.
Let me just tell you,
this is a fun fucking podcast.
It was fun.
I go with this is what
I wanted people to see.
Well then there's nothing to worry about.
What I wanted people to see
is why I like counting stones.
Like why I enjoy hanging out with you.
I wanted to people to be able to see
it because I have had to defend that
because of this narrative that Joe
got disagree with Alex and whatever.
You don't need to let the
left dislike make you bad.
If I was Charlie Manson,
I should be able to come on your show.
I want you to call him.
I show.
All right,
we don't have to do this
Charlie Manson type thing,
but I would interview that.
Here's the thing I was saying,
if the devil in a big blue smoke,
you would interview him.
Would you want to stay a certain
distance wife from the devil?
The devil is very sexually seductive.
You know the devil
appeared to be standing up.
Well,
he just pleased as go to an open mind.
Seen the devil.
It's,
yes,
I have hotter now.
You know,
I have to buy the desk open Mike night.
A devil is pure sexual so that
you know the [inaudible] Joe,
how sexy is the Dell?
Um,
I wouldn't say sexy.
I don't think I could get
it up in front of a demon.
No,
no,
no demon.
This is Lucifer.
Oh,
the big one.
The Big Daddy.
You know,
you never know until he's kissing you.
I guess you could be the
next Sam Kinison now.
But it's a thing like,
you know what I mean?
Remember Sam Kinison was like a preacher
in a yelling about the baby's preaches
Christ.
He was at the top and he
jokes about this when I was a little kid
and I was having one of these visions
when I was asleep.
I hadn't seen Conan the destroyer yet.
Or Conan the barbarian was
the first one kind of story.
Remember,
I like the demons like laying on its side.
So just good looking guy.
It turns into this big fucking Goblin tax.
Everybody.
And when I was a kid
that was like a thing.
Like,
I would like try to,
and these dreams,
these I go way back as a university,
but like I was like,
it's a gay dude like sitting
there on his side like this.
And then a few years later I saw Conan.
So the shorter and I'm like,
that's the thing from the drain did show
what I'm saying is they know shorten.
Okay.
You seen like the hobbit remake?
Yeah,
yeah.
Where Gandalf goes to the castle and
sore on not made his body yet and he,
he looked looks like that
and he'd like that fire.
I've seen exactly that.
So you want to talk about what that
real controllers of the grays are?
It looks like,
sorry,
have you ever had a
significant head injury?
What happened to
what happened to,
you know,
they're going to NPR piece coming out
next week that I apologize to the guy that
never did that.
What happened?
What happened to your head?
I've been called rock you,
somebody's pile drive to you.
What happened?
How old were you?
Uh,
was about 13,
13,
14.
So many pile drives you and you
had to change your personality.
I got up and punched him in the
throat and the head dragging anatomy,
I was dead.
Wow.
So was it a friend of yours?
It was like the state wrestling champion,
middle light and he his
cousin or something.
And The Dallas was like this,
like,
you know,
got me down.
I was never starting five man.
These people,
here's the thing,
I'm out of victim of racial attacks.
I'm not like Jeffrey or Jessie smaller
as I fought rednecks and I got my leg
broken,
you know by,
so this guy pile drive you and your head,
you knew 13
yeah.
And then what did it do
to your personality then?
I had to fight his whole family.
Most his family.
It was a gamechanger.
Did it change?
But did you have any significant
change from that head injury?
Sometimes when people have hand injuries,
especially,
it seems like,
you know,
stuff's just got better.
Real.
Oh,
go
serious.
It's like,
dude,
we got to get to the root timing.
That's good timing.
No,
no,
no.
I mean that's happened to a lot of,
there's no doubt.
My friend Dave Foley was just on here
and he was talking about how he got drunk
and he fell down and cracked his head.
It,
it's crazy.
But he cured his depression that little,
it looks like playing this any given time.
If somebody is a regular guy and,
and I would never start a fight.
They kicked my ass like the
average hundred 50 pound guy,
you're probably getting my ass.
But when like a bunch of
people are coming after me,
it's like Darth Vader and
I was a kid.
I mean I learned,
I bash somebody shouting into
the concrete when they attack me.
I got hired now.
And when the kid dropped you on your head,
what effect did it have on you physically?
It was by the field house because his
cousin had attacked me and I beat him up.
And so the state wrestling champ,
it was like a senior comes.
He goes,
oh yeah.
He came around and he caught up when on
my head was bleeding like he'd won and I
punched him in the neck and brokers,
it had a tracheotomy.
He almost died.
It was like,
yeah,
you almost killed me.
He was like,
he couldn't,
like,
he slammed me in the ground,
my head's bleeding,
all these stitches right here.
And then he couldn't believe
when I got up and said,
well,
you die.
He couldn't understand like
the energetic of equivalents.
He couldn't understand being the nail.
You don't want to
understand being the hammer.
He didn't understand that.
And then they,
you know,
they took me to jail and they let me go.
I'm on some tough guy.
The point is,
I'm getting killed.
I'm going to fight back.
And,
and so Dallas was like,
what happened to your head after that?
I mean,
I,
uh,
I never even got knocked out in that one,
that you slammed my head in the ground.
And I remember like,
everybody made a joke
because the concrete cracked.
Oh,
Jay was like on the edge of the congress.
He,
he called rob me right into the concrete.
I'm like,
split my head way over.
Let's just write a story.
And I remember just getting up.
It was like slow motion puts you
right in the neck and the ambulances.
The police came.
That was that story.
Did you,
did you go to the hospital?
Yeah.
No,
they told me to jail for that,
but then they'd let me go.
They didn't check your head.
Did you tell them you got piled try?
I don't know.
They soaked it up.
They sewed it up in the,
in the jail.
They didn't like check to see if you
had a severe concussion or a sham dermal
hematoma.
No.
Wow.
Go ahead.
Joseph had been the one you think that
he's a conspiracy theorist cause it got
dropped on his head.
Uh,
I think,
I think there's something,
there's something to people that have
had head trauma that become brilliant at
speaking things.
That's true.
The blast.
Like his name was John,
his name was Cory strange.
The only reason he won,
he was battered or power for the me.
Is He fucking,
he had six packs because like
Arnold Schwarzenegger black dude,
he waited and gloated while
blood was coming out of my head.
Oh Shit.
Reason he lost was he
loaded and there's way more.
But you're,
you broke the concrete with your head.
That's big.
No you didn't.
The concrete didn't actually break in it.
Maybe it did,
but they made the job.
Okay.
So either a dinner as I knocked out,
he's still got spiked on it.
Call me.
No.
Do getting spiked on your
head on the concrete.
Shogun myself with other people for fun.
I've never been knocked out.
Okay.
So I don't think one time I got here and
then you've got drove to hold daggers.
Correct?
You're incorrect.
So you,
you absolutely can't
barely tapped his head.
He would have been knocked out.
Maybe not you.
It doesn't matter.
Like sometimes people get knocked
out through severe head injury.
Sometimes they don't.
Sometimes they're heads cracked.
My Dad,
hold on.
Sometimes they never lose consciousness.
You can't think that they
always lose consciousness.
Sometimes it's cracked out.
I would see like numbers,
like I was a robot and
then red I would she like,
remember she's random.
She's like,
no,
it's your story.
That's your story,
Dude.
Man.
When when you get dinged there's something
about getting dinged with a punch and
you see that flash and you realize that
you let your central nervous system is
like 30% functional like whoa
variable but very weird feeling.
[inaudible] Joe's done it.
That's what the people say.
She stars.
Yeah,
that's what it was a very
said oh Hollywood stars
because they'd seen the stars.
Like each star is like a whole data bank.
And I remember like some dude
choking me and like guys are like,
somebody was like pulling a knife
out and you see that knife point out,
you're like,
and like
at that point you are she everything
for only those minutes when everything's
clear it's like survival emotions.
But then you see like,
like the wars and the attacks,
the submarines of the
space craft and like,
it's like when you dial into
that it's like total war.
It's like,
didn't you say that when your
friends would choke you out,
you'd have with these long dreams?
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
no.
It'd be out for a couple
of centers in junior high.
Sixth,
seventh,
eighth grade.
Cause we,
I got choked out a couple of times.
I finally stopped and
there'd always be like,
guys like it's incredible.
We do this during lunch and we'd go
back and like someone press on their
arteries like the bad times when you hit
your habit and be like one time like I
remember this one time I,
they choke me out.
And also it was like a black knight with
a sword goes and like a tax me on this
horse and then why it was and then I was
like in England thousands of years ago
and I had this wife for these kids and
it was a whole lifetime like taking care
of them and like growing food,
like a kid starved to death or died.
It was like just those moments
where like whole lives,
dead kids,
everything.
That's what I'm saying.
Like you dial in to all those ancestors
and it was like my kids and kids
starving to death and
like people attacking us.
And so you think all that information
from your ancestors somehow or another
encoded somewhere and
get buying coated Joe.
That makes sense.
If you think about what
reincarnation must feel like,
you know when,
when people have that feeling,
they felt this feeling that they live
before our whole bodies are everybody
before us.
Right.
Well it's not quite exactly.
So people,
they underestimate like,
oh I live before.
No,
they all live before they
would also explain certain
fears that people just have
his children,
like children have a fear of animals.
Like you see an animal with big teeth.
Children have a natch ever been attacked
by k but their ancestors got killed by
them.
They probably got attacked by
some bear somewhere and you know,
and somehow or another they got
through and they survived and
there.
Yup.
It makes sense how animals learn things.
I mean animals just know things.
My dog would epigenics they have stone.
Yeah.
Or they can take 10
generation chickens enclosed.
Ut did a study on this like 20
years ago and fly a hawk over.
They all ran scared.
They fly triangle.
Nobody hears the exact shape of a hawk.
Makes all the chickens
run because they've,
it's programming.
Exactly.
It's why if you have a puppy
and you take it for walks,
even when it's like six weeks old,
it'll never be around another dog again.
It knows exactly what to do and knows
how to sniff things and Piss on trees,
knows a check for other dogs,
pis and knows what to do.
They know what to do.
There's a,
there's a certain,
they know what animals to chase.
They see a squirrel.
They want to go ask to
show what I've lined up is,
but then when you know,
is it looks like our species is super old.
How old?
I don't know cause I can't even
interpret the stuff I've seen.
I mean I saw like you've seen like a,
what's that stupid Tom Cruise movie
where stupid Tom Cruise movie.
How dare you,
how dare you Jack reacher
check Ruthie to oblivion.
They've got the guy at
landers shelling up.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
In stuck in the ocean of I was a dope
movie and outside and he doesn't even know
he's working for the system.
And so that's what I'm telling
you is literally whatever it is,
just like a joke,
like whatever created us,
he's like super bad ash,
but is it possible that there's not a
thing that created us but that we are just
like every other organism and every
other system on this planet with this
constantly evolving thing that doesn't
really have a leader and it's trying to
get better constantly at everything?
It does and I agree with you,
but this is just,
this is where the stops three 60 Joe,
you're right,
but there wasn't a worm learned how
to crawl up the ass of a grasshopper
programming and do that.
That there was some prime essence that
was put into things that did that that
said free will and we're
the top of the food chain.
Or was it thousands and thousands
of generations of failures,
thousands of generations of bugs that
got into this grasshopper just was just
killed it and then wind up
suffocating to death inside of it.
Even though they were a parasite,
they never figured out
a way to get in filing.
One figure it out and finally one of
them through some sort of weird mutation,
figured out a way to interact with the
brain of the grasshopper and actually
guide it to the lake,
get it to jump into the water and drown.
That's a burst from its body
and then swim away officers.
But I think it's one of the most unlikely.
But if you talking about things,
learning from things,
if things learn from things and they
keep getting better over thousands and
thousands of generations,
but these same things keep procreating,
wouldn't it eventually get to some
state where it figures out how to do
something if it is still a parasite and
it gets inside the body would have it
figured out,
oh,
if I just like grow these things off
the top of my head and connect it to the
brand,
this dumb little motherfucker
and get them to drowning deaths.
Mutated a ride.
Yeah,
they just make the connection and all
the sales go up and eaten by birds shit
down.
It's more,
more animals eat it and that's the thing.
I think we're dealing with an unfathomable
number of creatures that are being
born and dying and new ones
are being born and dying.
I think our puny little
brains can't really calculate
the exact amount of cycles
that it takes a single celled
organism to free speech then yes,
that's just big open 100% so is it the
whole modern leftist Dang a denial,
the leftest ate toast that we're
going to let things be free.
Well,
the problem is the leftists ethos is also
the idea of inclusiveness and kindness
and caring.
I like the idea is that they're
promoting all the kindness.
No,
I get promoted.
Go had a fall once a day
and my five year olds,
okay,
but what I'm saying is kindness.
Unless you're a right wing person.
Now,
if you think on the right,
then they want to attack you,
then they want a,
they want to demonize you and if they
could shut you down and silence you and
find some sort of a
bullshit excuse to do so.
And a lot of cases it seems like some
folks lean in that direction and this is
where it gets dangerous because you can't,
it's like if someone says,
Hey,
if I knew how to fight,
I'd run in front of Pizza.
I just fuck everybody up.
Well,
you'd be dead in a year because eventually
people are going to kick your ass and
kill you.
You can't just beat people up.
Well,
yeah,
a one on one basis,
but it's that everybody gangs up an issue.
It's that childish,
childish mentality.
I'll just knock this person out
and nothing else will happen.
Like that's not,
you know,
you're setting a whole thing in motion.
When you silence someone,
you're setting a whole thing in motion
and this is something that we're all
learning.
This is what we have
to come to grips with.
Social media has only been around
for a really short amount of time.
It's only been around in this kind
of form for 10 plus years and we're,
we're figuring it out and these people
that think that they can just silence
people and shut people down without
it having a bad effect on all of us.
It's not right.
Well,
I appreciate it shouldn't be a
path toward your empty spaces.
Good.
Eddie,
what do you think it should be done about
the denial of the reign of terror of
censorship,
which admittedly going on,
I don't know.
Shit.
You know,
all I know is that it seems that the
right is being censored a lot and when you
look at the left and
how they've been acting,
I mean they're acting like psychopaths,
like pick,
you know,
putting signs up for late term
abortions and all that shit.
They're pushing that.
There's people pushing that AOC there.
It's,
it's like someone who's
trying to get fired.
You know,
when you're,
you have a job when you want to get fired,
who runs whole CIA squad and he said,
what do you think Alex?
It's like they want to lose.
What's the cyop?
I don't know.
It seems like they're trying to,
it's so bad,
it's so bad.
How much of that is influenced by people
that are trying to fuck with the whole
system?
Imagine if this is like
stage five Russian influence.
Just get to support
later,
like figure out a way to get people
to support super late term abortions.
Figuring out a way to get
people to Support Trans
Women competing as women with
no hormones on one high school.
We're like some 25 year old
dude's like 18 year old girls.
He takes all the,
all the titles like now guys haven't,
you know,
it's hilarious.
It's hilarious.
Imagine if your daughter was up for a
scholarship and she had to compete against
some six foot five man who identified as
a woman and wanted to play basketball.
I feel a,
if you've,
if you've committed a crime,
if you're a felon,
you can't chop your dick off.
You know what I mean?
I like the Japanese model.
They said,
hey,
cause I don't care if you're
a trans or you're dude,
once people,
and I don't literally
I'll have a libertarian,
don't act like I'm trying to suppress you.
But the Japanese said,
Hey,
uh,
you don't get the Trans destination
unless you chop the Johnson and the way it
goes off.
And it's like,
hey,
you get,
taxpayers will pay for it.
You get to a vagina bill and
then you sit there and do it.
Leave like,
you know,
I think there's a lot of people
that are legitimately trance.
That's not the problem.
The problem is them wanting
to compete as women.
And Martina Navratilova just caught a
rash of shit cause she was talking about
it,
you know,
to the famous tennis star.
She's talking about it that women are
breaking all these records and right after
she said that these kids,
number one and two were transgender.
That one,
the girls high school
track meet and it's just,
you know,
at a certain time you gotta go,
you gotta stop doing this.
This is,
we're talking about competition.
Somebody because they think
they're another sex that,
but like same timeline,
I watched like bike races and
running races and soccer and,
and high jumping.
It's a dude.
Like he thought just like this is,
you're bigger than me.
They're like these six foot $4 whose
shoulders when we kicked my ass.
Oh,
was a girl or like what?
I mean that's,
that's been a little less man.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's some nonsense going on.
There's some people that are legit and
then there's some people that are just
legitimately crazy.
I mean there's,
but like with everything in life is
people that are legitimately trans and
there's people that have to,
a man wants to see himself as a woman,
a lodger neck shows the
Kimball's that happens,
that's their issue,
whatever.
Or vice versa.
But like,
I'm going to watch NFL and
like we're supposed to like,
you know,
like had a women's NFL and it's all
guys and they say they're women.
It was like a thing in England last year
where the guy comes in with tattoos,
a big beard and it was
in the police report.
That guy had like a foot long
cup and he goes do a cervix jam.
What kind of police
reported this and up pull?
The nurse said,
oh sure,
I don't see a vagina and
it was in the report.
The man had a foot long dick,
so she's supposed to mental yoga.
Okay,
well let me check all this and
to show that you've got all this.
I mean it's just like
it's mental illness man.
It's not that I hate somebody that
feels like they're a woman or a man or
whatever.
That's the lie that like,
Oh,
you need to accept this
or you hate everything.
Imagine if all this ridiculous
propaganda really was like the very,
very highest level Russian
meme farm propaganda and
this is why the people that,
it could totally be a saying this
the most posthumously leftist,
like even things like these babies being
resuscitated and then kill like that.
People wouldn't freak out when they
heard a guy talk about that kind of shit.
Imagine if this is all just designed
to make everybody go fucking crazy.
That was y'all.
I wish the governor sang
it and I am doing it.
And there's just one point we're going,
this transmission,
what is the end game?
What is the end game?
Alex cameras we're told as humanities
bad who manage wrecking things,
but the very environmentalist groups
that are doing this are all like weird
transhumanist,
anti human.
I'm all transhumanists if I
really get life extension.
But it's all like,
Oh,
you die,
your upload do have machine.
I'm just saying anything you,
she the big corporate media promoting,
they don't know what they're doing.
I've been around them.
I've talked to them.
They don't know.
I don't think I know.
I don't think Joe knows.
I don't think Eddie knows.
But I think in the spectrum
of like one to a hundred,
we're in the 95th percentile
of really being woke.
And we care about,
look,
I don't like to shake.
Well,
I mean,
I'll never forget like
three or four years ago,
remember that black home was
drive around the capitol.
They had military drill going and she
shot him and ran and they shot her.
Oh yeah.
And,
and it was,
you're in black lives matter like four
years ago I had like this outpouring of
black listers and I'm not,
don't judge thinks about money,
but like $1 million came in like a week
and it was all black people Shang we
thought you were against black people,
but when you shuck,
cared about that woman being shot by the,
by the police had a checkpoint DC.
We knew you were good.
No one knew who she was
till the day letter.
How did,
was it thinking,
is it a black woman?
Is it a white woman?
Is it a Hispanic woman?
I was taking the report.
She went through a checkpoint and got
scared and then the police shot her.
I'm not against the police either on
cops on his bed shooting a woman running
away.
It's like there's gotta be a better way.
You can't catch her bro.
No,
no,
I agree.
That cop was bad.
I think you've got to,
that's what I'm saying is that I'm
not some goody two shoes she doing,
it's running away.
She was just running,
had a military drill four or five,
whatever it was.
They had a military drill in DC where
most of the roads were shut down.
What was the story?
Jamie?
Can you find it?
The woman gets shot blonder noise shot
but for the White House somewhere.
How many people get shot
in this country every year?
Because someone just can't handle pressure
right in front of the White House.
About 14 trigger finger
does know what to do.
Just make the wrong decision.
It's mental illness.
We don't blame guns cause you use a car.
Yeah,
but,
but it is true that about
half of them are suicides,
but the rest half is like
people can't handle it.
And uh,
that was like four or five years
ago because here it is right here.
Capitol Hill,
United States,
uh,
Miriam Carey,
a dental hygienist from Stanford,
Connecticut attempted to drive through
the White House security checkpoint in
her black Infiniti g three,
seven coop.
Uh,
she struck at USC as a service officer,
but that's a lie.
Did,
they had the main roads and
I'll try to like anti cop,
black lives matter.
It's not treated.
They had all the road shut down,
but she was trying to drive through a
security checkpoint that could be still
possible that they had all the roads
shut down and the checkpoint was army and
then she went to another and it was
army and then they just shot her.
Neil,
they,
I guess the cops,
they shot her and she had
her daughter in the car.
Huh.
That's a horrible story.
I don't want to end it with that.
But,
but my point was I don't
judge things about money,
black people.
Cause that was really a big story
at the time when I came out,
because I'd seen the footage,
I was watching live and saw
him taking her head lady.
I said,
it's a black lady and,
and,
and what the hell?
This woman was like,
Eh.
They were like,
oh my God,
he cares about black people.
Yeah man,
I care about whatever they call it.
They are,
am I saying what was that moment?
And they like all just bought
product and it was like,
they say outpouring and
letters and flowers.
Like you stood up for a black woman.
I'm like,
dude,
half of the black people incepted
in this country are boarded.
Joe,
those planned parenthood,
she said a real number.
Yeah,
it's like 60% some shitty.
They were hired.
It was all shut up.
Margaret Sanger said we're targeting
black people and you know what?
The other day I see big population as
he dumb white people done black people.
All these B,
I get like there's too
many people in seminaries.
There are.
I can get to it a little
bit to the point is,
is that you're going to like target
black people and then tell them that you
care about them.
When you're the KKK Democrats and you've
got Margaret Sanger shut up and you're
doing all this,
and I walk out of a mall,
I give them all two years ago in Houston,
the same black Israelite group that
was yelling at a yelling at the,
at the Covington Catholic kid saying,
you're all Nazis when they attack
them or the same one they cover,
they're like black people.
Black people are God and white people
are the do and we're going to kill the
white people.
And so I'm sitting there walking out
of this mall after Trump got elected in
Houston.
I remember,
cause I was there with my wife,
she wanted like a Burberry
coat or something.
I was out visiting family
and these black guys go,
we're going to cue you.
I didn't hate him because
they were black guys.
They were literally Nazis and I remember
sitting there in that parking lot
walking across and I said,
well if you such big men heal me now,
and it wasn't
tough.
They're saying,
oh okay,
we got to kill your last.
I want to end this show on a positive
note against black people die.
I know you know,
no one's going to run in.
The black people are like that 1% of
10% of 1% the point is is that I've
literally,
you go to a black,
he was real light group.
Yes.
I wrote a story about it on my way,
way back in
the day to tell her I was
hanging out with them.
They were saying that George
Washington was a black man.
They had all this crazy
interpretation of the Bible.
One guy would read and
the other guy would like,
repeat what you
George Washington.
They were saying,
they,
I'm saying,
I'm going to kill you
like superheroes.
It's a very unusual organization.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Everybody was blown.
I wasn't putting down blown
and I know you weren't.
I know you weren't there.
The He,
you know his take on it.
I mean,
I don't think it's a unified front.
I don't think all black Israelites across
the country have the exact same ideas.
Keep breathing.
We got to end this.
It's almost five o'clock.
I'm gonna say five hours.
Yes.
Don't hit anybody.
Let's be friends.
Eddie Bravo.
Uh,
thanks for coming in man.
Keeping this thing like
info wars.com and news wars.com
they blocked the everywhere else.
It is the verboten.
And you have a,
you have an Instagram page though.
You do have an this.
Well,
don't plug it a little bag.
Hey,
they're picking everybody's free speech.
We got,
whether I agree with the white
supremacists or the black supremacists,
I don't whether I agree with the sign
intolerably although the buzzer looms,
the plot is we should agree with free
speech and say no to this and not have
some sell out to Shyna
where Chris to go to China,
you got to waive all your rights here.
Here,
Alex Jones,
Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll see you guys soon.
[inaudible] we're off tomorrow.
Daily wrong info wars that side.